at seven a tribute to former supreme
court justices louis brandeis and felix
frankfurter speakers include justice
stephen breyer senator daniel patrick
moynihan and a grandson of the late
justice brandeis
but first former defense secretary dick
cheney he spoke wednesday at a forum on
the oil trade and the pipeline
operations in the caspian sea hosted by
the u.s russia business council his
remarks last about an hour
ladies and gentlemen
we're now going to
turn to our distinguished luncheon
speaker
who has noticed
that he's been invited to be the
luncheon speaker and that we've served
him bread and water
he says he's not going to forget that
we're on notice
but uh they're stopping this uh the
collection of the service and
so that we can have have quiet in the
room
we have a
wonderful person to address us and bring
these themes together
i'll remind you that there are cards on
your table and the staff of the
conference will be walking around
uh towards at the end to pick up cards
uh that that you have questions on and
they'll pass them up here so i want to
remember remind the staff to do that
and to introduce our speaker
um
great pleasure that i turned the panel
over to richard edmondson from pennzoil
who will indeed introduce our speaker
thanks
[Applause]
it's not often that uh one gets the
honor of introducing someone who has had
as distinguished a career both in
government and in this industry
as secretary dick cheney
uh today we do have the honor of uh a
few minutes of his time
on some very critical subjects to our
industry into this particular part of
the world
secretary cheney was appointed chairman
of the board and chief executive officer
of halliburton company in january of
1996.
he boasts a long and distinguished
career in government culminating in four
years as secretary of defense in the
bush administration
in 1969 he joined the nixon
administration and served in a number of
capacities
before leaving the government in 1973 to
become vice president of bradley woods
and company and investment banking firm
when
gerald ford assumed the presidency in
august 1974 secretary cheney was invited
to serve on the transition team
and later
became deputy assistant of the president
in 1975 he became assistant to the
president and white house chief of staff
secretary cheney later became the sole
congressman from wyoming and was
re-elected five times
in
1989 he became secretary of defense and
served in that capacity until january
1993.
he directed two of the largest military
campaigns in recent history
operation just cause in panama in
operation desert storm in the middle
east
he was also responsible for shaping the
future of the us military in an age of
profound and rapid change
at the end of the cold war
for his leadership in the gulf war
secretary cheney was awarded the
presidential medal of honor
by president george bush on july 3 1991.
he serves on numerous boards and is a
member of the board of trustees of
southern methodist university and the
american enterprise institute
please join me in thanking
secretary cheney for joining us today
[Applause]
you might have added that
i've been a good customer of
cambridge energy research associates
over the years
until i got lunch today
it's all right dan we'll give you
another another opportunity we didn't
pay you for your gourmet skills anyway
but for your uh
your knowledge and and uh
encyclopedic knowledge of our business
and our industry well i'm delighted to
be here today to have a few minutes to
talk with all of you and i promise to
try to to be uh fairly concise and keep
it to the point and not wander on too
long because i know all of you are are
that i'm standing between you and lunch
and
some of your customers of ours and uh
i'm not eager to
to stay in that position for too long a
period of time
let me uh
at the outset uh state that
perhaps something obvious but but for
somebody who was former secretary of
defense i used to spend a lot of time
thinking what are what are the strategic
regions of the world what are the truly
important areas that we have to be
concerned about
this was especially true as the cold war
ended and we moved from a military
standpoint
with respect to our strategy to focusing
on a regional strategy no longer being
concerned about global conflict but
being concerned upon key strategic areas
that were important to the united states
and i can't think of a time until
very recently
when we've had a region emerge
and suddenly become as strategically
significant as has been true the caspian
it's almost as though overnight suddenly
uh
opportunities and possibilities have
arisen there obviously uh primarily
because of the the collapse of the
former soviet union and the emergence of
of the newly independent states of that
part of the world but i want to hear to
here today i want to talk a little bit
about uh
sort of a broader perspective on the
caspian region i know you've heard from
many experts today people who spend a
lot of time out there and and have more
knowledge and intimate knowledge about
it than i do
but i wanted to speak a little bit about
the subject from the perspective of my
prior hat as a former government
official in my current role in the
industry as chairman and chief executive
officer at halliburton
let me start with one fundamental
premise that i think guides certainly
our thinking about it and clearly the
world needs energy
the estimate that
we find we use in our modeling is the
notion that between now and the year
2010
that uh annual
demand for oil will increase by two
percent
each year and along with a natural
decline of about three percent in
production from existing fields that
means by 2010 we need another 48 million
barrels a day of production just to meet
those requirements
it's either got to come from new
production or from enhanced recovery
from existing fields and of course most
of that's likely to be found outside the
continental united states
the u.s is the world's biggest consumer
of petroleum and petroleum products an
adequate supply of reasonably priced oil
is clearly absolutely vital to the
american economy and yet most of the
world's oil reserves some 97
are under the control of foreign
governments
for the rest of the world including half
of the world's population currently
making the transition from planned
economies to free markets energy will
clearly be the critical building block
and that's transformation
today international oil and gas
companies have plenty of capital but are
presented with a limited number of
opportunities
in new areas providing the scale and the
return attractive to the industry
most of the countries with really
sizable oil reserves are still closed
including much of the middle east saudi
arabia kuwait iraq iran for the most
part
opportunities in russia are on hold
mexico is closed and venezuela only
recently opened up
other areas are mature such as the north
sea the u.s and indonesia
so the caspian region with truly vast
undeveloped oil and gas resources
represents new investment opportunities
for companies
in an otherwise opportunity constrained
world
of course with opportunity come
obstacles problems and risk many to do
with the transportation of oil markets
still development of caspian oil ought
to be good for the countries involved
the investing companies and for world
oil supplies so it's worth the effort
obviously for us to try to find
solutions
my experience and perspective on
geopolitics
and energy tell me one thing very
clearly
the caspian region is of enormous
significance to the future of a
diversified and balanced global oil
market
in the coming years as global oil demand
grows the world will need new sources
the caspian has great hydrocarbon
potential to meet those needs but the
realization of this potential depends
not only on commercial attractiveness
but also on politics
as the struggle to get these resources
to market involves numerous countries
with competing interest
howard geopolitics shaping the events in
the region since the collapse of the
soviet union world competition has
shifted from geopolitical and military
power to economic and commercial
competition
this is reflected in economic
competition in regions around the globe
the caspian is on the front lines of
this global competition as nations and
commercial interests now jockey for
influence
over the caspian region's vast oil and
gas resources and the access routes to
markets
while the newly independent nations face
the challenges of statehood
outside countries are still vying for
influence and domination
the power game is being played out
through pipeline routes and commercial
competition
i won't delve into the specifics of
pipeline roots and security i know
you've spent a lot of time on that
already today but i do want to speak
about some of the broader political
issues and the primary interests
of the main international players
aside from of course the countries
themselves
the main players clearly are russia
turkey iran china and the united states
each group has distinct concerns and
motivations
russia looms large over the entire
region by virtue of its proximity
and history of soviet control over these
countries
as secretary of defense i used to think
about this region of the world as a
target
um now as the ceo of an energy service
company obviously i have a slightly
different perspective
but there's to some extent the target
analogy is still appropriate because of
the way in which the the rest of the
world is sort of zeroed in on what is a
clearly vital piece of real estate
with its near abroad policy russia has
attempted to assert continuing influence
over these countries by applying
pressure in numerous ways such as
pushing them to join the commonwealth of
independent states
russia has also sought military bases on
many of these territories some would say
that moscow wants to keep the newly
independent states weak
by limiting oil exports with a fallback
position of ensuring
that if caspian oil does flow it goes
through russian territory
with constrained export capacity it does
not make sense for russia to back out
its own crude oil exports in exchange
for transit fees from caspian oil
exports
caspian area crude is likely to move
through russian pipelines when it suits
the russians interest
my view is that russia ultimately wants
to maximize its economic gains from the
leverage it has over these newly
independent states
overall russia is concerned about
setting precedence in dealing with a
variety of issues with the newly
independent states particularly about
the exploitation of natural resources
they want credit for any economic or
energy development that took place when
these countries were soviet republics
moscow wants to establish its rights
early even if it means slowing
development part of this is reflected in
their position on the lake versus c
legal status of the caspian
the bottom line in my mind russia wants
to maintain political leverage in the
near abroad
turkey another important player clearly
has some goals similar to russia but
also some of its own unique concerns
like russia turkey would like political
leverage in the caspian region and wants
to maximize the economic benefits that
would evolve from that leverage
turkish cultural influence over newly
independent countries in the regions has
been somewhat limited and as investors
they have limited capital
however they obviously would like to
play a key role as an export route
favoring a pipeline pipeline route
through turkey devoid prosperous oil
tanker traffic
the risk to the turks is an alternate
pipeline route out of the black sea such
as one through bulgaria and greece
turkey has a dynamic private sector and
turkish interest would also like to
broaden key commercial alliances and
diversify sources of oil and gas
supplies to meet their own rising energy
needs
complicating turkish concerns and
pipeline routes are issues of kurdish
insurgency the armenian azerbaijani
conflict and deep suspicions and
relations between russia and greece
a broader concern for ankara and the
post-soviet cold war era is simply to
maintain geopolitical significance with
the west
iran is another story but like russia
and turkey it also desires political
leverage and influence in the casper and
region
iran would like to establish key
commercial alliances and share in the
economic benefits of developing caspian
resources iran's proximity provides the
most direct exit route for certain oil
and gas exports if pipelines could be
constructed across its territory
asian demand may provide a better market
than the mediterranean for caspian oil
iran has apparently now moved in favor
of carving up the caspian rights among
the littoral states instead of a 45 mile
limit
after the breakup of the soviet union
and the creation of the newly
independent states it's fair to say
that iran's potential influence has been
heightened in this region
now china is also becoming a player in
the region i was in china just a few
weeks ago to have
a session with the head of the cnpc the
chinese national petroleum corporation
and he wanted to talk about kazakhstan
and cnpc's investments there as well as
in other parts of the world
china's goals are clearly both economic
and political chinese influence is also
seen through the aggressive positioning
of cnpc in the uz and acute vinsk
projects in kazakhstan there's the
potential for a substantial movement of
oil and gas through pipelines which
could stretch across kazakhstan an
additional exit route for energy
which goes neither to the west nor
through the straits of hormuz but
directly to a huge market in asia
this option has only begun to be studied
seriously the chinese can take a much
more long-term strategic approach in
some respects than can an international
oil company they may well undertake the
investments a private company might not
make
clearly their definition of what
constitutes a successful commercial
enterprise is probably different from
that of most private companies
and they may well turn this proposed
pipeline into reality so in broad terms
these are some of the key geopolitical
concerns of the major players
of course the newly independent states
have the most at stake
their very independence and viability
are on the line
each of these nations has its own
priorities nation-building
solidifying independence developing
their economy fostering political
stability and ensuring their defense and
security
dynamic leadership is helping the
transformation in azerbaijan president
alief is bringing stability and securing
investment in his country while
simultaneously seeking azerbaijan's
political objectives and the
international diversification of
investors to broaden the support base a
resolution of export pipeline routes and
the legal status of the caspian sea as
well as a resumption of usaid and a
resolution of the armenian conflict over
nagorno-karabakh
president nazarbayev whom i've heard
friends refer to as the george
washington kazakhstan is also to be
congratulated on the progress his
country's making
these leaders would no doubt like to
increase their nation's geopolitical
importance even further and take
advantage of the leverage that will come
with that
but what of u.s objectives
u.s strategic interests in the region
are buried and often in conflict with
one another
first the u.s supports the independence
of the countries of the former soviet
union
change is underway in the region and the
u.s needs to encourage and create the
environment for strong viable
democratic states
these nations are being transformed from
being part of the soviet hinterland to
being free societies
it is in the u s interest to see them
enjoy peace and prosperity
a high standard of living and to become
countries that can contribute to the
community of nations
developing the economies and the natural
resources of this region are a key part
of this process and i think also
obviously a strategic interest to the
united states
however the administration's policy
toward the caspian region is strongly
affected
by our middle east policy specifically
the notion of dual containment of iraq
and iran
some observers would point out that the
unintended result of the policy towards
iran
is to give russia even more leverage
over the independent states of central
asia and the caucuses by blocking export
routes south
out of iran
thus our policy towards iran contradicts
our policy toward encouraging
independence for the states and the
caspian region
as a broader policy the u.s also wants
to see more diversity in the sources of
the world's oil supply and to encourage
opportunities for u.s companies and
commercial interests
although middle east countries including
iraq still have
vast undeveloped oil reserves and
potential it is in our strategic and our
economic interest to encourage the
opening up of new areas of supply
this can create a more balanced and less
vulnerable world market
so what is needed to ensure the
independence and the development of
these countries independence requires
economic strength and i believe this
will come from a free market foundation
hand in hand with democracy
the republics need to establish their
own independent sources of wealth to
finance this economic and political
independence one of the main drivers of
economic growth and independence clearly
will be the development of their oil and
gas resources
a crucial element in the caspian's
economic development is the urgency
of receiving the benefits for developing
these natural resources
the time it will take
for significant exports of oil to begin
and then for oil companies to recover
their cost could mean that the local
economies and people will not see
direct benefits for some time
of course there may be secondary
benefits from jobs and infrastructure
it's important for these new governments
to show financial and economic gains in
the short run
if they're going to keep their countries
on track
while oil may be a key driver i think
diversity of the economic base is also
important this applies to diversity
among foreign investors big and small as
well
infrastructure is clearly another
crucial component to economic growth and
this goes beyond just oil pipelines
building the infrastructure and
developing the oil and gas resources
will clearly require massive foreign
investment
what is needed to create an attractive
investment climate there clearly are a
range of political problems that need to
be solved mostly interrelated with
export pipeline routes one key issue to
be resolved of course is the offshore
boundaries the lake versus sea dispute
is still a major impediment to foreign
investment and a key element for foreign
investment and economic growth is peace
in the region
that should be pursued through both
bilateral and multilateral channels
there also needs to be stability in the
application of the rule of law including
a reliable framework for production
sharing contracts the nations must
recognize they are in competition with
the rest of the world their investment
climate must be attractive and i believe
free markets are a key it is important
there be a level playing field for
developing the energy resources the
caspian
cooperation and competition among
companies should be based on good
business not on outside government
pressure or spheres of influence
in other words the development should be
approached on an economic
rather than on a geopolitical basis
this is all part of free and open
markets
economic interdependence should be
regarded as a positive force countries
are often concerned about being
dependent on their neighbors but
economic links can bind the interest of
countries together
cross-border investments and shared
infrastructure like pipelines can lead
to greater stability by hard hard-wiring
relationships solving the problems
involved in developing the great
resources of the caspian region will
require a lot of cooperative effort
companies will have to work together
with each other and with multiple
governments
success in developing the oil and gas
resources in the casper and the rest of
the world for that matter depend on the
degree to which market forces are
permitted to work
market forces are transforming the world
and energy is the crucial building block
we would not enjoy the enormous peace
and prosperity and opportunity that we
enjoy at the end of the 20th century if
it weren't for the enormous impact of
market forces in the global economy over
the last several decades
wrong-headed policies can interfere with
the free market with disastrous results
the white house and congress share the
blame
in my mind for misguided policies like
wage price controls back in the 70s
and the sanctions on azerbaijan iran and
other nations imposed for essentially
domestic political reasons
when prices are relatively low
politicians are less concerned about
long-term supply security and
vulnerability and they feel free to do
things such as using oil sanctions as a
foreign policy weapon
the oil industry makes large long-term
capital investments in fixed assets in
developing countries all over the globe
the long-term horizon is often at odds
with the pressures of short-term
political issues
companies must write out changes in
governments and policies and shifting
diplomatic relations
the us government needs to extend its
horizon as well and think about
think about the longer term strategic
interest that are involved
i'm often asked what it's like going
from being secretary of defense to
becoming chairman and ceo at halliburt i
explained there are a lot of
similarities
the biggest problem i faced as secretary
of defense was the united states
congress
now that i'm chairman of ceo at
halliburton the biggest problem i face
is the united states congress
another question i'm often asked since
halliburton operates in about 120
countries around the world is what about
political risk isn't it dangerous to to
function in that many places don't you
run into problems
with political risk various places
what i find is that while we operate in
some pretty hairy places we're far more
likely to be shut down in a country by
developments in washington than by
anything that's ever happened to us
overseas the biggest political risk we
face as a company and as an industry
is in fact right here in washington dc
on capitol hill
the fact is the u.s oil industry is an
invaluable strategic asset for the
united states congress needs to
understand that and unfortunately they
don't
it may well be that the average oil
executive knows more about foreign
policy than the average congressman with
the cold war over congress is now
dominated by domestic concerns and
domestic interest groups
i heard a disturbing statistic the other
day it was that uh
of our freshmen
who now arrive in washington to begin
their service in the u.s congress 30
percent of them arrive without passports
30 percent have never been outside the
continental united states
there is a silver lining in all of this
it's comforting to note that one of the
institutions held an even lower esteem
than the oil industry is the us
congress i actually moved up to a more
prestigious profession when i gave up
politics
and became part of the industry
let me turn for just a moment if i can
to the question of sanctions because and
and some of you heard me on the subject
subject before but it's very important
and if we don't talk about it nobody
else will
the sanctions problem has gotten worse
frankly in recent years we've now had uh
tabulation done the other day some
35 times in the last four years the u.s
government has imposed sanctions of one
kind or another on foreign on u.s
companies doing business or operating in
foreign countries
congress sees sanctions as the low-cost
option no troops no casualties and no
appropriations but there is a cost to
the u.s and using embargoes
our sanctions policies demonstrate a
total lack of any real understanding of
the long-term strategic interest of the
u.s
as a foreign policy tool sanctions are a
blunt instrument
the motivation is often us domestic
politics not foreign policy
considerations for example following the
sanctions on myanmar texaco pulled out
and was replaced by foreign companies
including petronas how are the people of
myanmar really any better off for that
change
in terms of efficiency sanctions rarely
achieve the desired result
it almost never leads to a change in the
policy of another government
i want to distinguish between
multilateral sanctions and unilateral
sanctions i think that's important i
think multilateral sanctions can in fact
sometimes work and are sometimes
justified and i would cite the current
policy with respect to iraq as being a
place where
multiple multilateral sanctions are
appropriate and ought to be supported by
the united states
the key is that they are international
that there's wide consensus for
supporting those sanctions and that they
can be enforced unilateral sanctions
those imposed only by the united states
almost never work hard put to find a
single example of a time when u.s
imposed unilateral sanctions have ever
had the desired result of changing the
policies of the countries they were
targeted on they aren't adopted for that
reason they're adopted to appease
various interest groups in the u.s
who've lobbied for some kind of a
congressional response
to an issue of the day
secondary boycotts such as now
authorized by the helms burton act
applied to cuba punishes foreign
executives from canada our largest
trading partner by not allowing them
access to the united states for years we
the united states fought against
secondary boycotts when they targeted
israel now we're trying to impose them
on others
this is a reversal of years of u.s
principles on open trade
we traditionally have been the advocate
of lower tariff and non-tariff barriers
encouraging the free flow of goods and
services and capital ideas across
international boundaries we are the
biggest advocates of the rule of law in
the international marketplace
now all of that is being undermined
with an increasing application of
sanctions
designed to display our anger
with some foreign government
the fact these sanctions rarely work
means the u s government is often
adopting a policy that is doomed to fail
thereby raising doubts all across the
spectrum about our national credibility
sanctions also have unanticipated
consequences the sanctions on iran i
believe have worked against our foreign
policy goals of independence for the
nations in the caspian region
they interfere with reasonable efforts
aimed at developing
the natural resources of the central
asian and caspian republics azerbaijan
is clearly adversely affected by
congressional limits on official
assistance from the u.s driven by
domestic policy pressures generated by
the conflict with armenia
i recently returned from a
10-day trip through the gulf
the u.s continues
to push sanctions on iran which are not
supported by any of our other partners
in the region
but in effect what happens is are
insisting upon a policy that is
generally perceived to be a failure we
undermine our capacity to build support
for other policies which are important
such as for example trying to reassemble
the coalition and dealing with the
current crisis in iraq
doubts about the quality of us
leadership in one area begin to
undermine our capacity to provide
leadership in other areas
historically congress has tried pushing
sanctions but often presidents and the
executive branch blocked those attempts
in the past it was the executive branch
that took the long view on foreign
policy and defended u.s strategic
interest
now frankly there's less forthright
opposition from the white house
as the clinton administration has jumped
in on sanctions as well for example
forcing conoco out of the deal in the
gulf
so congress and the executive branch
share the blame for these policies that
are odds with what i believe are
long-term u.s vital interests
to wrap up what's needed now we must
raise the level of dialogue i think we
have to focus
on broader questions of long-term
strategy rather than responding to
short-term political pressures and we
need to adopt a sense of urgency about
progress in this region
i gave a speech similar to this one to
the u.s azerbaijan chamber of commerce
earlier this year
it's remarkable how little has changed
in almost a year
most of the same problems and issues
remain the development issues of the
region need to be resolved soon
if we are still debating these same
topics four years from now which is
possible i think this will be
unacceptable to the people of the region
and certainly have serious ramifications
the us will have lost prestige the
industry will have lost opportunities
and instability in the region may well
by then be on the rise
leverage
hostile to the interest of the newly
independent states may well increase as
time
progresses without adequate developments
of those resources
the u.s needs to take steps to expedite
progress and to stop the imprudent use
of sanctions
the caspian is of great importance to
the world oil markets and global
economic and political stability
we in the industry have an obvious
interest in seeing that the word goes
out
that the caspian region is a vital
strategic interest but it's important
for us as we do so to remind everybody
it's not just a question of the economic
well-being of those companies that want
to invest
in the region it goes to the very
question of whether or not the people
millions of people who live in those
newly independent states the former
soviet union will enjoy the fruits of
prosperity and peace that
they so richly deserve thank you very
much
the team is should be gathering
some questions uh
they're coming
i'm sorry
uh mr secretary
secretary pena's remarks indicate a
clear preference
for the big oil pipeline to turkey will
american policy more firmly and clearly
oppose russian interference and covert
action programs in the south caucuses
and will america become more engaged in
resolving regional conflicts
well you should have asked secretary
payton in that question
i
i think you can tell from my remarks i i
really think that
to some extent we need to focus up upon
economic issues and let the market
operate
and it's unrealistic and unreasonable i
believe for us to get into the business
as a government
of trying to force a political solution
that may in fact not be the best
solution economically if we want to
operate in accordance with free market
principles as best we can
and supposedly we do then i think it's
better for us to to let the marketplace
make those kinds of judgments and
decisions
the
the difficulty i have
while we can certainly express our
preference uh perfectly legitimate for
the us government to do that as i say
i'm i'm concerned because i see our
policies out there being shaped by
considerations that have very little to
do with what is in our long-term
strategic interest it's part of the
business of government to evaluate
interest and decide what really is vital
to us and i don't think we've done that
in this case
given the contradictions you pointed out
between u.s policy towards iran and our
caspian interests what specific policy
changes towards iran would you suggest
i'll be the first to admit that the
relationship with iran today is is
obviously a very difficult one
it goes back
at least
to the fall of the shah in 1979 it's
still a very
hard subject i think for american
political leaders to come to grips with
partly because of what happened in 1979
when our embassy was taken and americans
were held hostage
on the other side obviously it's a
problem we shot down their airliner in
1988 the great loss of civilian life
coming out of iran if you look at the
relationship we can find ample
arguments on both sides to continue
down the course of iran but i would hope
that we would take advantage of the
change in government that's occurred
there recognize it's a long-term
progress process this is not going to
happen overnight it's not a question of
one trip or one layer one communication
is the process in my mind of beginning
quietly and carefully over a sustained
period of time to try to rebuild a more
normal relationship with what obviously
is a a nation that historically has been
important in the united states clearly
is important to all of our friends in
the region out there and
i think long term would
benefit from closer relationships with
the us but it requires creativity and
subtlety and sophistication in terms of
how we deal with those kinds of issues i
think
that at this point we seem to be in the
mode of repeatedly penalizing and trying
to impose secondary boycotts now on
companies of other nations that are
trying to do business in the area i
think specifically most recently for
example of the move by some of my
friends on the hill to shut off xm
credits for american firms doing
business with gazprom because gasprom is
contemplating doing business with total
and iran
the losers in that process not only
doesn't we don't make any progress in
terms of trying to rebuild relationships
with iran a number of american companies
obviously are going to be seriously hurt
and my guess is the project will go
forward anyway
um so we keep coming back to this notion
that we don't have the kind of
what i think would be a sophisticated
subtle approach to begin to build those
relationships just in terms of how we
address them with respect to style and
tone and the kinds of issues we choose
to raise with them whether we try to
communicate privately or whether we do
everything in the newspapers
and i think we could do a better job
than we have of
of seeking consciously to rebuild those
relationships taking a long-term five or
ten year perspective because that's what
it'll take
you mentioned the crisis in iraq
can you give us your views on what is
happening there what should be done and
the risks associated with it
uh i uh thought i gave all that up when
i left government and i uh
well let me let me take a crack at it it
is a serious problem um
no one should underestimate that i think
at the outset it's very important for us
to insist upon full and complete
compliance with the unsecurity council
resolutions
it would be a serious mistake for the
u.n
uh or for the coalition that was
involved in that effort to now back off
and and somehow
uh allow saddam hussein to get on with
developing weapons of mass destruction i
think the reason the crisis developed
when it did
is because uh he has something he wants
to hide i think it also developed when
it did because he perceived the
possibility of driving a wedge there but
excuse me between the members of the
security council and the coalition so
he's acted as he has he's trying to
manipulate the process
i am not encouraged when i see the
administration relying upon mr primikov
to go negotiate some kind of quote
settlement with the iraqis
uh back at the time of the original
crisis mr primakoff try to do exactly
the same thing
and if he had been successful we
probably would still be negotiating
about whether or not the iraqis were
going to withdraw from kuwait
that was was unacceptable then i think
it's unacceptable now
i think the part of the difficulty that
we're faced with here is that
that the u.s the quality of u.s
leadership in the region and the ability
to hold that coalition together that was
put together with enormous effort and we
kind of took it for granted once it was
established but it was very hard to
assemble a coalition in the first place
but once it was put together it needs to
be tended to
and your ability to maintain that
coalition is affected by the perception
of the members of the coalition of the
quality of your leadership in other
areas and of your effectiveness with
respect to the other kinds of policies
you pursue so we're pursuing a policy
with respect to iran that most of our
friends in the region think doesn't make
any sense
that begins to raise questions about
their willingness for example to sign on
support to coalition action if we've got
a breakdown in the peace process which i
think many people in that part of the
world believe
then
and and they don't see the us able to
deal with that breakdown in the peace
process
then again that raises questions about
the quality of our leadership in terms
of dealing with iraq
we're out hammering
the gulf states on attendance at the
most recent nina conference in in doha
difficult thing for them to do given
current public opinion in that part of
the world and the difficulties and
breakdown of the peace process
uh they clearly are uncomfortable doing
it president mubarak was traveling
through the region when i was there
basically organizing resistance to
attendance at the mina conference
and then we come back around a week
later and say oh by the way we want to
use your air bases in order to launch a
military operation against iraq it's
going to be very hard
to get support and approval for that
we're in a situation now
as i look at it i think well there's a
lot of talk about the coalition coming
apart i worry that it's already under
enormous strain
and when i see president mubarak in
egypt who's always been a great friend
of the united states who was absolutely
vital
a key link together with king fodd in
saudi arabia during the gulf crisis six
seven years ago the man who organized
the arab league to support the united
states position out there and committed
troops to the effort helped us liberate
kuwait and take on the iraqi armed
forces
they see him now actively and
aggressively opposing
u.s policy in that part of the world is
an indication to me that we had a
breakdown here sometime in the recent
past
so that we no longer have the kind of of
stature and the kind of quality of
leadership that's necessary in order to
manage an extraordinarily complex
diplomatic situation to produce the
desired result but if we back off at
this point if we allow
saddam hussein now to begin dictate the
terms of compliance by which we make
concessions
and no longer insist upon full
compliance with the u.n security council
resolutions we've got a real problem and
that shouldn't be allowed to happen and
if you have to ultimately obviously you
may have to resort to military force and
if you do it ought to be quick and
decisive and and very painful
the u.s government imposes unilateral
sanctions on u.s businessmen through the
foreign corrupt practices act should we
reassess u.s policy in this area
uh i'd say no
i uh i know that uh there's the view
and i've i can i've encountered it
myself
that some of our foreign competitors
are able to pay
bribes
make
corrupt payments to others in other
countries some of them are even able to
deduct them as a business expense
from the standpoint of the united states
and and as a u.s firm operating and say
in over 120 countries around the world
uh i'm perfectly comfortable with the
foreign corrupt practices act uh our
people know what it says what it
provides for the people we deal with
overseas know exactly what's required
and how we're going to operate and do
business and frankly it makes it easier
for us to do the right thing and i think
we ought to do the right thing i don't
think
you i don't think you can take the
united states and our our business
sector which i think is a great
strategic asset the fact that it is
american companies that are out there
all over the globe
uh moving the the world forward
i don't think we can lay claim to
be successful in that area
if at bottom we participate in what are
in fact corrupt transactions and they're
going to be a mistake so i'm saying
i'd like to see the rest of the world
come along and
adopt and live by our standards i think
we ought to push for that
internationally especially with some of
our close trading friends and allies
i can even name some countries if you'd
like
but i
i would not repeal the foreign corrupt
practices act i think it's a basically
good policy and we're happy to support
it
your discussion with regard to russian
interests strategy in the caspian region
seems to suggest a sinister threatening
element to russian motives
do you think such tones contribute
towards a positive commercial approach
with the principles of countries and
companies working together in the region
i don't certainly don't intend
to be
overly critical from the standpoint of
of russia with respect to the issue of
the near abroad i think
so i find it perfectly understandable
that there are still questions
on the part of some of my friends in
moscow about what is ultimately going to
happen in the near abroad will there be
uh is there any possibility for example
of recreating
the uh the old soviet union or parts of
the old soviet union i think that's
still
a political debate that we'll hear more
about in in the years ahead
um with respect to
open dialogue and debate and hopefully
democratic practices in in moscow and
the former soviet union so i don't mean
to be overly critical there i think if
you look
though at
the
at geography if you look at the history
of the area if you talk as i often do
with the friends in the newly
independent states
i would urge my friends in moscow
to think in economic terms that it's in
their interest to see those resources
developed that again the marketplace
ought to be allowed to work here
and if the marketplace is allowed to
work then it's clearly going to lead to
the development of those resources and
the access of those resources to global
markets and that's in everybody's
interest that in the final analysis
i'd like to see our friends in russia
frankly move the ball in terms of
developing their oil and gas resources
and i would like to see the same thing
happen with respect to those republics
of the former soviet union those newly
independent states and i think if that
happens the prospects will be bright for
everybody in the region
far better outcome
if we allow
those developments than if they're
interfered with sort of artificially for
political reasons
please join me in thanking secretary
cheney for these insightful comments for
our industry and for this reason
let me echo that i think we all know
that dick cheney is a very effective uh
ceo of a great company but he's also a
uh i think a statesman and a wise man
and we thank him very much for sharing
his hard-headed wisdom with us today
again thank you
thank you uh we'll now resume lunch and
um
and then resume the program thank you
you
[Music]
my
coming up next on c-span bw dot
c-span.org click on that 25th
anniversary icon
washington journal continues
joining us now is neil king of the wall
street journal mr king why are you
writing so much about uh halliburton in
the wall street journal recently
i think it's a variety of reasons really
there's some
i mean obviously just the prominence of
the whole post-war rock scene and who's
doing what kind of work there uh there's
it's also just the fact that halliburton
represents about half of all the work
that's going on there in terms of money
they're also the ones that are
tending to and caring for the troops
there
unlike the other contractors that are
all doing work restoring the
infrastructure of iraq and doing a
variety of things like that school
projects and so on
halliburton main presence on the ground
is to feed
clothe lawn do the laundry for house
build bases the whole thing for the huge
military presence there as well as all
of the people that are there as
diplomats and the like and the green
zone in baghdad and all that and then of
course there's just the huge political
sensitivity of halliburton because of
its uh previous connections with the
vice president
and um
you know to the degree that that
actually matters which is debatable but
it's obvious that the democrats are
making hay out of this as much as
possible
and there's just a huge degree
of attention paid in particular to the
work that halliburton is doing there
because of its size and because of its
political sensitivity on capitol hill we
saw that last week there was hearing
in one of the house committees there's
likely to be more and you're probably
going to hear the word halliburton a lot
going into the summer
through the political campaign
you said that halliburton is getting
about half the money going into iraq now
well getting isn't maybe exactly the
right word i mean because of the huge
cost of of um doing all this service
work under this one particular contract
and looking after the troops
uh well over half the money that's going
into iraq projects is going through this
this particular halliburton contract
it's bringing fuel in it's it's bringing
water and food everything that
the troops need there so
last year it was about uh 3.8 billion or
something like that it's a little hard
to say because part of the problem and
part of the controversy is they're the
the numbers are so sort of fungible and
all over the place um
and uh halliburton has been very slow on
his bookkeeping which is one of the
reasons that
a lot of attention has been paid to
whether doing there by defense auditors
or the pentagon
but one thing that's extraordinary about
the work is how halliburton won a
contract in 2001 it's called log cap and
it's this contract that basically caters
to the needs of the us army all over the
world
and their work under that contract in
2002 the first full year after they won
it was about 500 million of course that
was before iraq they were doing work in
the balkans and a few other places last
year it went to almost 4 billion so the
sheer
increase in the size of the work and the
incredible number of people thousands of
people that they had to send into kuwait
and iraq to do that work is one of the
reasons that
the critics say that their whole kind of
back office shop of just keeping track
of what they're doing with all their
various subcontractors and so on has has
become such a huge problem what are
halliburton's total revenues for a year
oh
because you say about 3 billion is going
to halliburton yeah you know what i'm
actually i don't cover them so much as a
company that way so i'm not really
this this work is is significant in
terms of uh
its overall turnover uh i can't tell you
offhand what the percentage is but it's
not that significant in its overall
profit because these uh
figure they this particular log cap
contract for instance that i mentioned
uh they work on a one percent profit
margin and then there's a small
incentive that's built in if they do it
particularly well under a number of
criteria yesterday you had in the wall
street journal an article u.s general
criticizes halliburton now what is this
issue
well
this story was was important for one
reason mainly in that most of the
concentration at the moment has been on
uh
contra i mean sorry auditors within the
pentagon critiquing
various of their accounting things
kickbacks that had happened various
things that actually didn't have that
much to do with the performance on the
ground and how satisfied the customer
actually was which is the army this was
one of the first times that the top
general general sanchez in iraq uh in a
letter had had um basically elucidated
various concerns that the army had about
the actual performance of halliburton on
the ground uh is it fair to to draw vice
president cheney into the fact that
halliburton has contracts in iraq
yes and no i mean
to me i think the idea that somehow
other
vice president cheney had something to
do with them actually getting work there
is
is a bit of a stretch
on the other hand i think there is a
relevance in that
it was when mr cheney was actual
secretary of defense that a lot of the
kind of privatization of the work that
is now going on with the military really
began in earnest uh he actually
requested that uh halliburton or kellogg
brown and rooted subsidiary do some of
the work looking at the feasibility of
some of this privatization and then when
he was at halliburton
starting in 1995 is when a lot of this
really got underway and when they won
some of their more important contracts
to do that kind of work he had nothing
to do i would at least have no evidence
that he had anything to do with the
contracts that they're now working on
under there but there is a sort of
interconnection between him and the
pentagon and the work that goes on with
halliburton that goes well back before
he was vice president we're talking with
neil king of the wall street journal
about halliburton and iraq the numbers
are on the screen those who support the
democrats top line middle line for those
who support president bush and
supporting all others you see the third
line there
mr king is uh
is
i completely forgot what i was going to
say so we're just going to move on to
calls gross point michigan you're on the
air good morning
hi there um i just had a question i had
heard that and i could be wrong that uh
president clinton hired halliburton to
work in the balkans do you know anything
about that
yeah that's true the under i think it
was log cap one i'm not really sure we
don't need to get too much into the
details but they were brought on to do
the work that they uh were doing there
then there was a moment when another
company they're only actually very few
companies number of companies that do
this kind of work it's very labor
intensive um the profit margin is low
and it's it's uh the the difficulty of
it is the just the huge enormity of the
services that you have to be able to
provide so there was a time when another
company called dyncorp actually took
over this contract and then um
halliburton or kellogg brown and root
really to be technical about it won it
back in 2001. so yeah it's not as if
you know halliburton has only gotten
work under uh you know when a particular
party is in office or anything like that
yeah that is true and so there aren't
other many other companies that do this
kind of work very few very few
uh brunswick maine you're on the air yes
good morning good morning c-span thank
you peter and happy anniversary to
c-span uh mr king um i think i just
heard you say that we're building bases
in iraq
um i um i think that supports the theory
that we were
um going to war for oil thank you very
much
i don't really think it supports any
particular theory really may support
more of the theory that others have that
we wanted kind of a permanent foothold
in iraq but what they're doing at the
moment is consolidating bases down to
there's a whole huge troop rotation
going on and they're wanting to put uh
more troops on fewer bases and
halliburton or kellogg brown and root is
involved in doing all of that
consolidation i don't think particularly
it has anything to do with oil but
bringing up the whole oil issue they are
actually working under
another contract that we haven't really
mentioned which is to restore the uh oil
uh operations in the south of iraq
at the beginning of the war after the
war they had a contract that actually uh
helped them work throughout or had them
working throughout the country that was
then rebid
last year and they are now working only
in the southern half another company is
doing oil work in the northern half what
is the status of oil rebuilding in iraq
do you know
yeah by and large it's actually a fairly
good news story at the moment to the
extent that only in recent weeks if they
finally come back to the to the pre-war
uh level of production um exports have
started to go up a fair bit and the
revenues that they were making before
the war which were still historically if
one meant back say 10 years
low and it doesn't even come close to
the actual abilities that iraq has to
both pump oil and export oil but
a lot of the the horrors that were found
there after the war which had very
actually almost nothing to do with war
damage and more to do with looting and
various things that happened after the
war that many of those uh things have
now been repaired and fortunately the
kind of sabotage that we've seen a lot
up until recently of blowing up
pipelines and things like that has
subsided a bit so actually at the moment
it's fairly good news applewood
wisconsin you're on the air with neil
king oh it's appleton oh i apologize
wisconsin one hour from green bay
good morning um my comment was excuse me
i have
a son who is a lieutenant colonel in the
army
i have a grandson who is now serving in
baghdad and he was home over christmas
and when we were visiting together they
were talking about how impressed they
were with the performance of halliburton
they figured that whatever you give to
halliburton it has done quality
and right and so on where they had dealt
with other companies that were not
as
who performed as well so i just thought
that um you know in in discussing how
much money everybody is going to charge
and i don't know about excess charges
i'm i'm not into that but
um
that at least that they felt that the
performance that halliburton does do is
very high quality i just wanted to make
that comment okay
yeah i think it's completely a fair
point i mean the long gone are the days
when by and large troops went into areas
and were cooking their own food
and uh eating it and none of none of it
being terribly well being cooked by 22
year old
you know uh grunts that were just there
wanting to do something else i mean it
is the case that i ate a fair amount of
the food in various places that is made
by kbr or halliburton uh subcontractors
and uh it's good you know they have uh
trailers that a lot of these people are
living in they do
they clean the uniforms of soldiers who
might have previously had to clean them
themselves this is one of the the things
that they're trying to get through in
the various ads that they're now running
nationwide
in the effort to kind of rehabilitate
their image or whatever again a lot of
the criticism so far hasn't really been
addressed at the quality of the services
but more the cost of what it's taken to
deliver that and whether or not they've
just been very shoddy in in
the finding of subcontractors and the
lease in the the determining of cost
uh what's the status of the over cost um
overcharge investigations what with the
gasoline you mean or the meals yeah
there though yeah there are two areas
there one of them was uh the whole thing
that came to light a month or so ago
where
they had kind of had a bizarre rather
loose system of tabulating meals so that
they would say at a particular huge base
that on any given day 30 000 people
might show up so every day they would
charge for 30 000 meals even though
every day only five or six thousand
people actually showed up
so at the moment they've had to withhold
a fair sum of money like 170 some
million dollars as they try to work out
this discrepancy and come up with a
better system so that's one thing the
other thing is the whole bigger
controversy in some ways about
fuel charging all of the gasoline that's
been brought in from kuwait a particular
subcontractor that they chose in kuwait
gas that in some cases was about twice
what others were charging coming in from
turkey and so on that's also now uh part
of the investigation that's gone to the
attorney general i mean the inspector
general's office at the pentagon and uh
has now uh brought in the services of
the justice department as of last week
so those are i should i guess under
investigation long island you're on the
air good morning gentlemen i hope you'll
be patient i do have a couple of
questions uh one is um prior to um or
right as mr chaney had come into office
wasn't there some questions as about his
um accounting there was like an
accounting scandal he was doing
something with his books i may even have
something to do with arthur anderson do
you know anything about this neil king
uh the only thing i know about that is i
mean i'm not really sure about the
i do remember something faintly about
the arthur anderson thing but there was
a lot of talk about had he kind of
divested himself from halliburton
basically a lot of the things
options and things were put into kind of
a blind trust he's not really making all
that much money at the moment off
halibut there is still some stock
ownership i'm not completely up on the
details of that though palm springs good
morning
good morning
um i was wondering how many other
companies there are that can
can do a big job like this are capable
of something this size
i don't think there's that many and and
if there are we sure wouldn't want to
get one out of france or someplace like
that
i'll hang up and listen thank you yeah
uh i don't know whether you want to get
one out of france or not they're
actually oddly enough they're i'm
forgetting the name but there is one
french large at least catering company
that does actually a lot of this kind of
service work when it comes to dining
halls and that sort of thing that we
have worked with in the past
like i said before they're actually just
a couple of companies probably
five at the most only two that have done
this sort of thing most recently which
is dyncorp and halliburton
the argument though the counter argument
which people are starting to make is if
you look at something like iraq which is
such an enormous project that what
actually makes sense is to break it up
essentially and say all right why
doesn't somebody do the food part of it
why doesn't somebody do the laundry part
of it what does somebody do
the housing part of it there are many
many companies that could take on one
chunk a lot of the difficulty is not so
much
doing it
as it is the keeping tabs of it and
having a large enough kind of accounting
department behind the scenes to keep
track of the huge number of
subcontractors and like that you have in
place and that's the one area that
halliburton has really stumbled on has
halliburton returned your phone calls
yeah they have by and large they've been
i mean they are very responsive uh they
tend to like to deal uh more in email
format so i will email them a question
and let them know when those particular
stories come out they have yeah they
sometimes respond numbers overly
abundantly though they will send you
know very big long needy emails that are
you have to kind of pick your way
through they've been much more reluctant
on the other hand i was in iraq last
month for a while and i very much wanted
to spend time
with kbr getting a sense of what they
were doing on the ground and what it
amounted to and and as one caller
pointed out sort of what the quality of
the actual work was um they were less
inclined to do that i'm not really sure
why and we have a reporter that's over
in that area now wanting to do some of
that work and i'm not sure how receptive
they've been
they're just a bit wary of that but i
think it would be in their interest to
let people really see
the magnitude of what they're doing and
and get a better feeling kind of up
close for for what it amounts to most of
my work here
from the washington point of view has
been the criticism from
the auditing people at the pentagon and
so on so but yeah where they
headquartered the headquarters in
houston which is where halliburton is
based
but what about in in iraq do they have a
headquarters there well their main
operations when it comes to interacting
with subcontractors and the like has
been out of kuwait city um and
increasingly of course they do have a
very very large presence in baghdad it's
i mean in the green zone area which is a
fortified walled five square mile or
kilometer whatever it is very large area
in central baghdad where i spent a fair
amount of time last month you really
can't go anywhere without running into
uh kbr services even the big pool right
next to the palace then i'm sure saddam
and his cronies used to spend a lot of
time in in the summer there's a sign
there that you know kbr is the one
that's keeping the chlorine at the right
level and please don't swim in it at
certain times and so on um so they are
omnipresent there
how many employees do you have any idea
kbr has something like 20 000 some
employees around the around the world if
i have it right they have uh
many many thousands in iraq uh i'm not
sure when it when you count also the
subcontractors a lot of this work is is
you know kbr is the one who handles the
main thing and then they give but i
think they have something like 100
contract subcontractors out of kuwait
doing every every variety of different
work where are all these people staying
in baghdad
um largely there are some of these bases
that are uh outside near the airport but
a large number of the people are staying
in
just huge compounds of trailers uh
within this green zone and also you know
big that people are sleeping on cots and
that sort of thing um i would say most
of them are staying either in the green
zone or on a few of the other um
you know fortified protected bases
outside of baghdad itself are these
american workers for kpr that are over
there um they are largely kbr has had to
really um work hard to keep people well
to recruit them for one and to keep them
there because it's not it's not the most
pleasant work especially when you're in
iraq some kbr subcontractors have been
killed doing various things i mean
there's especially lately been a lot of
civilians that have been killed
they're bringing in i'd say a couple of
hundred people every week to try to keep
up with the need there um on the other
hand the people that are performing a
lot of the work for instance the people
that are doing the cooking uh in the big
palace dining facility or mainly
pakistani or indians or people brought
in from other parts of the world this is
which is typical in kuwait and saudi
arabia and places like that boca raton
you're on with neil king of the wall
street journal yes good morning a
comment and a question if i may
first of all i don't i don't think the
issue is whether or not the cheney is
directly hiring halliburton i think
the issue is that they're the most
favored ones obviously because of their
former relationship with him and it's an
opened a lot of doors
for them to get in and get all these
contracts
i think that uh
question would be and i read somewhere
last week where
halliburton was awarded a large large
contract and i can't remember how many
millions of dollars uh in any event they
were awarded that contract and
immediately
uh subbed that contract out for several
several million less you know making the
the company itself and i do remember
this figure they netted a quick 17 to 70
million dollars profit
after having been awarded a contract by
the government which was supposed to be
the lowest we assume
and
sub it out to someone else who's met
themselves making a lot of money and now
all of a sudden uh they rake in a quick
70 mil without without even having to
get their hands dirty yeah neil king uh
actually that's not the way it works and
these these contracts are not for fixed
work if you talk i don't know maybe he's
talking about some other kind of
contract but they're working are you
familiar with what he's referring to
though no okay no i know that this would
not be the case if he's talking about
iraq work because the work that they're
doing in iraq is not you know do this
particular job how much will you uh
offer to do that oh you'll do it for 100
okay here and then you'll give it to
somebody else to do it for 70. the work
is
we give you orders to do certain work
task orders they're called
you then do them hopefully which is the
debatable part at the best possible cost
or the most competitive cost and then
whatever it costs you earn a particular
percentage above that one percent it's
called cost plus it's a particular form
of contract this is not a fixed price
fixed work contract that they would then
sub out to somebody else and make a
profit on subbing it out
uh how long have you been with the wall
street journal
uh
11 years something like that i worked
for a while in europe i've been in
washington about five years and
according to this information you were
also a cab driver in new york where did
you get that is that not true it is it
was a while ago when i was in college
and that did a variety of things you
know
next call blue ridge georgia good
morning good morning uh congratulations
to c-span
i'm wondering uh mr king if
these civilian workers would have to be
replaced with military personnel if we
did not have this contract and the other
question very quickly is
how
can we possibly dispel the notion that
we went to war for oil
thank you
um yeah well the first point is that's
that's exactly the point that those who
are in favor of this whole setup make
and that is that
it's better to have civilian contractors
doing the work than to have
soldiers who are meant to fight and uh
do all that warfare entails
and not have them working in mess halls
and the like as to whether in the end
it's actually cheaper to do it that way
or more competitive is is is something
that's still being debated uh i haven't
really researched that point myself
on the other point i don't know how you
dispel that i'm not really one who
actually sides with that view myself and
i i suppose it's if there is anything
that will prove it or disprove it it'll
be more that time will tell and whether
the u.s moves out as it says it's going
to and isn't in the end uh in control of
iraqi oil which at least as the plan
goes they're not going to be in a matter
of months do you think halliburton gets
extra scrutiny at the pentagon
yeah that's a good point that's
certainly the point that the halliburton
people make which is that the cheney
connection has been more of a bane for
them
of late than it has anything else and i
think that's largely true um i mean huge
amounts of attention are paid to
halliburton in part because of the size
of the contract and because of the
political connections of the past um and
as well i think one might be able to
argue that i i think that there has been
a high degree of vigilance at the
pentagon they have an enormous number of
auditors now in iraq i mean i think at
the moment it's like 40 and soon to grow
to 70 or something like that i when i
was there i was running into these
people even in some of the most
far-flung uh and least hospitable places
in iraq i was at a power station in the
north of iraq in a town called beijing
one of the most dangerous areas of the
country a great kind of gruesome rainy
soggy
morning and we go into the mess hall
little place to have a coffee and
there's this lone pentagon auditor
sitting at a table um i don't know how
she'd gotten there but i assumed she
kind of got there under her own steam uh
so there this was not a halliburton
project but there there is a lot of
scrutiny going on there and it's
certainly ramped up and as articles like
this have come out and the various
scrutiny out of capitol hill i think
it's intensified uh how did you get into
iraq and how did you travel around and
where do you stay when you're there
um we have a house that we've rented
wall street journal does yeah
largely because the notion of being in a
hotel kind of had lost its appeal from
the security side
um i i took two ways i went in by car
which at the time this being uh what
early last month was thought being to be
superior to flying in because of just
sort of like you know
pick your poison i guess a little bit uh
it's about a 10 hour drive i went in
with a cbs television crew and a convoy
it wasn't really my uh favorite way of
going i would prefer to sort of gone in
a lone car but in the end it was fine
and and when i left i decided to fly out
there's a royal jordanian has flights uh
three or four times a week it's kind of
spooky because it's all you know the
joke there is uh well you have five
minutes of risk as compared to several
hours of risk on the highway but if you
get hit and you're several minutes of
risk taking off you're not likely to
survive while you know you might stand a
better chance driving out in the end i
decided to take the several minutes of
risk if the plane takes off and kind of
corkscrews up over the
over the airport trying to stay out of
the range of any uh anti-air or any uh
surface-to-air missiles in the end it
was you know hold your breath for a
couple of minutes and it was fine and so
it went up pretty quickly it did yeah it
was i was a little dismayed when i came
out on the runway and looked and saw
that it was like a scene from casablanca
or something it was this you know
propeller plane with the propellers i
was kind of hoping it would be a jet and
get us off the ground faster but maybe
this also allows for them to turn a
little bit easier when it goes up i
don't know but it was uh it was fine in
the end ella quippa pennsylvania you're
on the air
well the things that i'd like to mention
is how
how uh mr king seems to be a mouthpiece
for the republicans how he can gloss
over the fact that they overcharged for
25
000 meals which would probably be in
excess of a hundred thousand dollars
okay stay on the line caller let's get a
response from mr king
uh that's a kind of humorous accusation
because i've done we've done most of the
writing of most of the stories that have
caused probably the most pain over the
last few months to halliburton just
because we've stumbled on a lot of
things that have been
embarrassing to them and the meals uh
issue is something that we wrote about
first
we've been very aggressive in writing
about the whole fuel uh overcharging
issue
i mean i i can certainly go on and on in
a critique of the various uh stumblings
that they've had there and the evidence
of overcharging and
and the like so i don't i don't know
what to say about that caller go ahead
well it seems to me that
they were given the bid without without
any bids at all
it's profiteering it's just a republican
way to steal the rest of the treasury
and
as far as the previous caller
the fact of how can we make it sound
like we didn't go in there for oil when
in fact we did go in there for oil and
to finish the old man's unfinished
business
neil king
well okay that's i mean there are
various points i don't happen to i mean
i think we went under there and there's
various dubious arguments uh and that's
obviously become clear i don't buy
particularly that we went in just for
the oil if it didn't have oil we
probably wouldn't have gone but that's a
different argument
um
they're right i mean yeah it is the case
that uh there was a essentially no bid
contract for the work that they are
doing there or were doing there under
the oil
work that went out essentially in secret
before the war started um that probably
wasn't the way it should have happened
in the end that contract has been rebid
they did happen to have won the
southern portion work um i think there's
a degree
i mean i think there's a lot of area for
fair criticism towards haliburton i also
think that there's a degree of hyperbole
that surrounds the thing at the same
time
the continued use of the word no bid
when in the end for instance the
majority of the work that they're doing
there
under this whole log cap contract
looking after the military was
competitively bid
people don't often point that out in the
kind of constant repetition the word no
or the whole phrase no bid
i don't think i'm being an apologist for
halliburton however i don't mean to
obsess on this but back to the airport
in your flight out of there what was it
like to drive to the airport what was
the security at the airport was there a
counter did you call in actually
there are various kind of weird perils
when just being in iraq at all i mean
one of the scarier things just because
the road to the airport like a roads to
a lot of airports around the world is
sort of its own you know maybe somewhat
somewhat well not similar to the road to
dollars but it is a road to the airport
and because of that there's also been a
lot of targeting of troop convoys and
the thing along there so that's they've
had to cut down with the palm trees and
things to try to clear the way so that
there won't be explosive devices planted
um otherwise when you get there there's
a laborious you know they have to look
through the car and that takes a long
time and then you finally get cleared
through and in the end you take a bus
but but once you actually get to the
airport it's really astonishing because
the airport is new newish it was built i
suppose in the 90s and very rarely used
because there were no real commercial
flights for years in the 90s
and uh nice inside there was of course
one only one counter so a lot of other
uh available space
and uh then once one was cleared through
and you went to the kind of departure
lounge there was a departure board with
all the destinations including las vegas
chicago
abu dhabi paris london
all these departures that were they
hadn't flown to those places since 1990
so i was amazed that they ever had flown
to las vegas obviously you would have to
stop somewhere on the way but even the
fact that there was las vegas uh being
announced on the departure board of the
at this at the uh what formerly known as
saddam international airport i thought
was kind of funny neil king wall street
journal thanks for being with us
pleasure manuel miranda will be out here
next he's the former council to uh
senate majority leader bill frist he'll
be talking about the senate judicial
nomination process yesterday we talked
to tim curran of roll call who's the
editor roll call about manuel miranda
situation
dot com and click on books
halliburton came under renewed scrutiny
tuesday when auditors urged the defense
department to hold back payments of
nearly 160 million dollars for allegedly
over charging for meals in iraq in 2003
wednesday the company held its annual
meeting in houston amid protesters
next on book tv dan briote looks at the
history of the company and its
relationship to vice president dick
cheney in discussing his new book the
halliburton agenda
this is an hour
good evening
i'm lisa joycigorsky the executive
director of the federal city club if
you're not familiar with the federal
city club i encourage you to visit our
website www.federalcityclub.com
in the meantime i'll summarize
the federal city club was founded in
1963
to protest the racially oppressive
practices of other washington d.c clubs
now it's in its 41st year the federal
city club remains non-partisan
and racially inclusive
our members are professionals from
diverse backgrounds
education training careers interests
viewpoints
and points on the political spectrum
our programs reflect
our keen interest in public affairs
from kenneth starr
to john dean
from eugene mccarthy
to dick thornburg
from tucker carlson to eleanor clift
our speakers are public
figures
and thought leaders
our programs are smart
provocative and spirited
tonight promises to be no exception
to introduce our speaker i would like to
now turn the podium over to the federal
city club's vice president allison adler
dan briote is the author of the national
bestseller the iron triangle inside the
carlisle group
the secret world of the carlisle group
an award-winning business journalist he
has written for forbes
wired
red herring and the industry standard
he has appeared on numerous radio and
television programs as an expert on the
co-mingling of business and politics
particularly as it pertains to the war
on terrorism and the military-industrial
complex he lives in connecticut
and now i present the author of the
halliburton agenda
the politics of oil and
money
dan bryode dance
[Applause]
thanks everyone thank you allison
i appreciate everybody coming out
tonight and i expect that we'll have
some lively discussion
um
i want to talk about
four things from the book i'm going to
read from the book a little bit
uh to give you a sense of what it is
that i'm talking about but there are
four main things that are covered in the
book
that i think are the most important
takeaways
one is the history of the company which
i think is
critical
when you're trying to put the events of
the past three years into context
we've all read a lot about halliburton
in the news
over the past three years since the war
began
and
there hasn't been a lot of understanding
of this company what do they do
why are they so controversial why are we
reading about them
so much so i'm going to try to put some
of that into context
with their history
also
i think i would be remiss if we didn't
look at the parallels between this
conflict and vietnam
and the role that
halliburton and its subsidiary kellogg
brown and route played in both of those
wars
we're also going to talk about dick
cheney a little bit
who was the ceo of the company from 1995
to 2000.
and finally i'm going to touch a little
bit on the military-industrial complex
what is it what does it mean
and why should we should be concerned
with that
so
i'll start off uh with a little reading
that'll give you a sense of the history
of the company
and we'll go from there
though dick cheney took the game to a
new level it's always been played this
way at least by kbr kellogg brown and
root the subsidiary of halliburton that
is attracting all the political
attention with its role in the 2 billion
and counting contract to rebuild iraq's
oil infrastructure
kbr was first formed then called brown
and root in 1919 and the company was a
political animal from the very beginning
building roads in rural central texas
hermann and george brown learned early
how to influence public officials in
pursuit of lucrative county contracts
their relentless and brazen brand of
politicking evolved steadily over the
years and culminated in their
relationship with lyndon johnson an
unprecedented business and political
association that propelled both the
browns and johnson to the tops of their
respective professions
yet the story of halliburton and more
accurately kbr
is more than just a tale of the
confluence of business and politics in
america it is also the story of how
government contracting and outsourcing
has evolved over the past 100 years and
how the military came to advocate the
privatization trend
what we are seeing today in iraq
the secret letting of no bid contracts
the strange and arcane bureaucracy
behind military outsourcing the army's
dangerous dependency on kbr
all can be explained by following the
trajectory of kbr from its early days of
navy shipbuilding in world war ii to its
role in building airstrips and prisoner
cells in vietnam
the cycles of kbr's war business are
repetitive but distinct
during world war ii no one criticized
the company for the role it played in
supporting the war effort
vietnam brought with it heavy criticism
from the anti-war anti-profiteering
element but little talk of the company's
ties to prominent politicians
the iraq war has cast a light on the
potential for politicians to influence
the government contracting process
so that's just a quick overview of
what kbr and halliburton have been
through over the past 80 years both
companies were formed in 1920
and both companies started in texas
and
brown and root in particular
had
an astounding relationship with lyndon
johnson that lasted the better part of
40 years
they bankrolled many of his campaigns
all of his campaigns actually except for
the first congressional campaign
and
continue and in turn lyndon johnson
sent many many very lucrative contracts
um into the hands of brown and root
including uh dams uh including
work in vietnam navy shipbuilding doing
during world war ii um
and also uh
an incredible story that's that's in the
book but i won't get into about a
project called project mohol
which literally was
designed to drill a hole all the way
through the crust of the earth and
pierce the mantle
and this was done for scientific reasons
ultimately it did not work out and part
of that was because
it was a political decision to to give
the business to brown room in the first
place
interestingly donald rumsfeld was the
young congressman from illinois who
pointed out the relationship between
lyndon johnson and brown and root at the
time which ultimately scuttled the whole
deal
so we see him
now on the other side of the fence
i'm going to read a little bit about
brown and root in vietnam
and i think that
if you've been following the news about
the contract in iraq and halliburton's
work in iraq
you will hear a lot of terms and see a
lot of similarities between
vietnam and iraq
at least in terms of the role that brown
and root played there
in 1965 a year after johnson stepped up
america's participation in vietnam brown
and root joined three other construction
and pr and project management behemoths
raymond international morris knudsen and
j.a jones to form one of the largest
civilian-based military construction
conglomerates in history
the group which came to be known
collectively as rmk brj
went on to do more than two billion
dollars worth of work in vietnam of
which brown and root took a 20 cut
the contract was a cost plus 1.7 percent
contract meaning that the consortium
would be reimbursed all costs plus an
additional 1.7 percent profit
a method of contracting that encourages
the contractor to markedly increase
costs thereby increasing their profit
the world would be reintroduced to this
concept nearly 40 years later when
kellogg brown and root won the same type
of contract in iraq
even as early as 1966 reports started
reaching back to the homeland that the
united states was pouring money into a
sieve called vietnam
one study by the new york times found
that nearly 40 percent of the billions
being spent in vietnam was being stolen
used in bribes or outright wasted at the
rate of half a million dollars a day
rmk brj came under fire for not kiting
costs and wasting upwards of five
million dollars in its first year in the
country
its workers were manipulating currency
and selling goods on the black market
dozens of employees were sent home as
punishment
by 1968 when most of the country had
grown weary of the war
senator abraham a ribacoff a democrat
from connecticut filed a report with the
senate's permanent subcommittee on
investigations alleging kickbacks in the
construction consortiums in vietnam
claiming that millions were being quote
squandered because of inefficiency
dishonesty corruption and foolishness
and quote
he ordered an immediate general
accounting office investigation into
rmkbrj
the gao investigation completed in 1967
charged rmk brj with losing 120 million
dollars during its first five years in
vietnam
it said that quote normal management
controls were virtually abandoned end
quote and that millions were lost due to
lack security
after decades of receiving accolades
from government agencies and the
military brown and root was coming under
fire for wastefulness and inefficiency
the pentagon actually acknowledged some
of the blame in 1966 admitting that it
had misled the contractor lowballing the
estimated costs of the construction but
by 1968 johnson's last year's president
rmkbrj was significantly scaling back
its operations to about 15 000 employees
the public impression was that brown and
root was part of a war profiteering
machine that monopolized work in vietnam
mistreated workers and wasted millions
of taxpayers dollars
so
the gao is again investigating um brown
and root uh or kellogg brown and root
the subsidiary of halliburton that's
doing the majority of the work in iraq
there are again charges of of waste and
overages
and a lack of institutional control
it's a very very similar situation to
what we saw 40 years ago
and i think that
many people are coming at this um fresh
and have never heard of halliburton
before and rightfully so i mean the
company is an oil field services company
it's not exactly the the stuff of the
front page
but at the same time this is a company
that has been in and out of the news
for the past 80 years
in an almost cyclical and predictable
fashion
so let's
move on to dick cheney
dick cheney was ceo of halliburton
between 1995 and 2000.
when he left to become george w bush's
vice presidential running mate it was
thought that he had done a wonderful job
at halliburton the company certainly
loved him
he received a 30 million dollar
severance package he is still receiving
deferred salary payments from the
company
on an annual basis of about 150 000
a year i think this year was 175 000.
um
and so the relationship between dick
cheney and the company uh still
continues to stay he's still in touch
with the executives over there and they
value his opinion
but what he did while he was ceo um
was in fact very much in misunderstood
one of his
biggest tasks as ceo was the acquisition
of dresser industries
and that turned out to be an absolutely
disastrous acquisition it saddled the
company with close to four billion
dollars worth of asbestos liability much
of which should have been uncovered
during the due diligence process before
the company was acquired
he also changed accounting rules uh
within the company and failed to inform
shareholders in a timely fashion that
has resulted in an ongoing sec
investigation of the company
but and let me begin reading at this
point
far more disconcerting though
is the work that the company has done in
iraq
the country against which dick cheney
waged war twice during his career in
public office
between stints as secretary of defense
and vice president while cheney was ceo
of halliburton
he helped to rebuild iraq and enrich
saddam hussein
circumventing strict sanctions and
putting money into the pockets of
america's public enemy number one
in 1996 a un program called oil for food
was created as a way to provide
humanitarian relief to iraqi citizens
while keeping in place the international
economic sanctions against iraq and the
saddam hussein regime
the idea was to allow iraq to export its
precious oil in exchange for
humanitarian aid
everything from first aid and medical
supplies to the most basic food and
water requirements
there were strict there were
restrictions on the type of goods that
could be imported by iraq anything
deemed even remotely for military use
was strictly prohibited it seemed that
the world had devised a clever way to
obtain the much needed oil of iraq
without shouldering the burdensome
crisis of conscious
associated with doing business with a
brutal murdering dictator
not surprisingly the oil for food
program was exploited for personal gain
on both sides of the deal making
the council for international justice in
a september 2002 report estimated that
for every six billion dollars a year
iraq earned from the oil for food
program saddam hussein made two billion
he used this money for everything from
luxury goods to weapons and training for
his military
oil for food was the main source of
income for iraq
but the system was rife with corruption
skimming schemes and kickbacks
worse the united states was consuming 75
percent of the oil exported from iraq
under the program
the oil for food program was so
thoroughly corrupt that it was reduced
to a punchline
general tommy franks the us commander of
forces in iraq called it quote oil for
palaces end quote
saddam hussein and his sons were growing
richer by the day exploiting the poorly
audited program by providing substandard
services for its people and pocketing
the rest
it is estimated that of the 57 billion
dollars the country earned through the
oil for food program only 23 billion of
it was spent on humanitarian goods
that comes to about 170 dollars per
person per year
or less than the united nations spends
on dog food for mine clearing operations
it was through this program that
halliburton did business with iraq
between 1998 and 2000 the years that
dick cheney was ceo
in september 1998 halliburton closed on
its 7.7 billion stock merger with
dresser industries the company that gave
george h w bush his first job
the merger made halliburton the largest
oil field services firm in the world it
also brought with it two foreign
subsidiaries that were doing business
with iraq through the controversial oil
for food program
the two subsidiaries dresser rand an
ingersoll dresser pump company signed 73
million dollars worth of contracts for
oil production equipment while cheney
was ceo
cheney told the press during his 2000
run for vice president that he had a
quote firm policy end quote against
doing business with iraq
he admitted to doing business with iran
and libya
but iraq's different he said
originally cheney denied the business
ties to baghdad outright telling abc tv
in the summer of 2000 that quote we've
not done any business in iraq since u.n
sanctions were opposed on iraq in 1990
and i have a standing policy that i
wouldn't do that end quote
executives at both subsidiaries said
later that no such policy existed
three weeks later cheney was forced to
admit to the business to the business
ties but claimed ignorance
he told reporters that he was not aware
of dressers business in iraq and that
besides halliburton had divested itself
from both companies by two thousand
in the meantime the companies did
another thirty million dollars worth of
business in iraq before they were sold
off
but ignorance of the contracts
was also ruled out as an as an excuse as
cheney was forced in the uncomfortable
position of either admitting he didn't
know his company was trading with saddam
hussein or that he just didn't care
now
halliburton and
kellogg brandon are extremely political
companies and that comes with the
territory of being an international firm
and the type of business that they do
so you may be wondering if you know
anything about dick cheney's history
and his resume you may be wondering how
he became the ceo of a company like this
in the first place
he had literally zero business
experience he was a career politician a
career public servant
and a very dedicated one at that
in 1995 halliburton named dick cheney's
ceo surprised many people cheney had
actually toyed around with the idea of
possibly running for president
he had toyed around with uh with some
other ideas but ultimately he became the
ceo
of halliburton
so why why did they want dick cheney as
their ceo
i think this will give you a good idea
brown enroute had nearly doubled its
government contracts from 1.2 billion
dollars in the five years prior to dick
cheney's arrival to 2.3 million dollars
during his five years as ceo
halliburton soared from 73rd to 18th on
the pentagon's list of top contractors
its government contracting business grew
91 percent
in the five years before cheney took
over halliburton secured 100 million
dollars in government-backed loans from
the u.s export import bank
during the five years of cheney's tenure
that number increased to 1.5 billion
from 100 million to 1.5 billion
by the time he left in 2000 to become
george w bush's running mate
the reason that halliburton had chosen
dick cheney as a ceo had become clear
though cheney continued to deny that he
had any influence on halliburton's
government business
during a vice presidential debate in
2000 al gore's running mate senator
joseph lieberman mentioned casually that
chaney had done well financially at
halliburton
cheney responded by saying quote i can
tell you joe the government had
absolutely nothing to do with that end
quote
um that's a little tough to believe
considering
the remarkable increases in government
business that the company experienced
during his tenure
and also considering there would be
really no other reason for a fortune 500
oil services firm to hire a career
politician to be their ceo
so why is all this
somewhat disconcerting to me and to
other people in this country
you know
i think the most obvious reason is that
as a taxpayer i'm very concerned with
how my money is being spent um and if i
feel that it's being misspent
i want to know why and and who are the
companies that are behind it
so right now that's uh that's on the top
of my mind
but also there's something uh that
dwight eisenhower referred to as the
military-industrial complex and i talked
about this last year at the federal city
club
when i was speaking in my book the iron
triangle
and i think it applies even more to
halliburton and the military-industrial
complex or the iron triangle
is essentially the confluence of
uh the defense industry um
politics and big business and when those
three
when those three powerful forces get
together and start moving in the same
direction
um
policy can get made business changes can
happen um and and the influence of the
defense industry uh can be a little
disconcerting
so i'm gonna read a little bit uh about
the trend of privatization in the
military the trend of outsourcing to
private contractors
um like halliburton and we've all read a
lot about this recently in the press
and hopefully this will resonate a
little bit
it seemed reasonable that a privatized
military would be more nimble efficient
and cost effective if open if open
competition was cultivated
competition would cut down on the
burgeoning bureaucracy of the government
and create a growing new industry in the
united states that would even help fuel
the economy it had worked in other
industries to varying degrees so why not
the military
but the military is not like other
industries the distinction between
public and private market markets is
simple the government or the public
sector is expected to act on behalf of
its citizens spending their tax money to
better their lives
the private sector is motivated solely
by profit
in the case of waging war and action
taken to ostensibly improve the lives of
citizens
it would seem that the government should
remain the sole dispenser of funds and
the military should remain the sole
recipient
peter singer author of the definitive
work on the subject of military
outsourcing puts it like this
in fact providing for national and hence
their citizen security was one of the
most essential tasks of a government
indeed it defined what a government was
supposed to be
the result is that the military has been
the one area where there has never been
a question of states outsourcing or
privatizing
even the most radical libertarian
thinkers who tend to think that
everything should be should be left to
the market made an exception of the
military
all viewed national defense as something
best carried out by a tax financed
government force
so that's obviously changed a great deal
in the past 10 years really since the
great peacetime dividend at the end of
the cold war the reduction in troop size
and we've seen
since then a number of smaller
skirmishes and smaller deployments
but a very very active military
nonetheless
so we have needed as a as a country
we've needed to outsource a lot of the
functions of the military
one of the obvious uh functions to
outsource was logistical support for the
army in the navy
this
involves everything from
building housing for troops
cleaning latrines
feeding the troops
doing their laundry
any task that you can imagine that is of
a non-military nature or non-combat
nature
could be left to to a private firm
that firm as it turns out right now is
kellogg brown and root the subsidiary of
halliburton
they have done work uh since 1992
under a contract called log cap a
logistical augmentation program for the
army
this is a massive massive contract and
obviously we've seen the size of this
contract balloon in iraq
to
close to 9 billion right now if all of
the task orders that are currently in
place were to be fulfilled
obviously just a massive amount of money
for for a single contractor to
to receive
there have been questions about whether
there should be multiple contractors
doing this kind of thing maybe have a
two contractor system where they compete
on on each
task order so as to avoid the time
critical issues that the army
experiences
but to also maintain some competition
um but as it stands right now there is
one company kellogg brown and root that
does all of the logistical support for
the army
and that creates a bit of a problem um
as we saw in bosnia in the mid 90s i'll
read a little bit about that and then
i'll open it up for questions
the main problem with the work in the
balkans was lack of oversight by the
army
from the army's perspective everything
was running smoothly after all brown and
root made their lives considerably
easier
by assigning ever increasing amounts of
work to the contractor the army was able
to reduce force size and concentrate on
more important things and it wasn't
their money that was being spent
there was also a fundamental and more
systemic problem occurring
the army was unclear about how the log
cap contract was to be used
originally the contract was quote
intended to be the option of last resort
end quote
but the army had come to think of log
cap and subsequently brown root as
another branch of the military
at their beck and call
the results were disastrous and
fantastically expensive
critics say the brown and root benefited
from the confusion the gao found that
the company overstaffed and oversupplied
the army resulting in higher costs and
in turn higher profits for brown and
root
in one instance brown and root was
tasked with building a firefighting
force to staff the camps in bosnia
kosovo and macedonia the company
submitted a plan for 116 firefighting
personnel army engineers concluded that
no more than 66 were needed
but brown and rue was able to haggle
with the army finalizing an agreement
to staff 77 firefighters and the
corresponding amount of trucks and
equipment despite the difference of
opinion on the matter the army gave in
to brown and roots requests showing the
rising level of authority the company
had in influencing army policy
indeed the army was confused about its
authority over its primary contractor
in december 1999 the administrative
contracting officer at camp monteith in
kosovo
issued a task order to brown and root to
build a tent for use as the post office
at the camp the government estimated the
cost to be six thousand dollars so the
officer placed a ten thousand dollar
limit on the cost of the construction
giving brown and root amp a wiggle room
upon hearing this the lead
administrative contracting officer at
camp bondsteel sent an email to his
equal account monteith telling him that
brown root quote is the army's customer
and that such funding limitations affect
the army's relationship with the
customer end quote
how the customer vendor relationship in
in the balkans got so turned around as
anybody's guess the army is of course
the customer in the relationship not the
reverse
so that's an example of the amount of
power
that a sole contractor
that that the army and the navy have
come to depend on
uh
wields in the battle time situation they
don't have time to upset the contractor
they can't bring in another contractor
in this case in fact in bosnia uh in
1997
kellogg brown and route lost the co the
log cap contract to dine corp um but the
government found that it was impossible
to take brown and root out of bosnia
because they were so entrenched they
were so involved in every aspect of the
army's dealings there that they would
there was no way they could bring in a
new contract it would cost them too much
money it would be too expensive and and
and take too much time
so they carved out that entire piece of
the world and left it in kbr's hands
and
in 2001 kbr won the contract back again
this time for a 10-year installment
so that's pretty much the four things
that i wanted to cover and i'm eager to
hear uh what you guys think and uh and
what you would like to know
so if anybody has any questions
fire away
i'll take the liberties and start you've
pro you've presented
lots of questionable circumstances
um certainly motives
were crimes committed were laws broken
can you spell it out for us well there
were crimes committed back uh during the
lyndon johnson era and those things
didn't come out for a good 20 years
after that which is tends to be the way
that these things happen
after some of the public servants and
executives from the company have left
and moved on in their career and they
sort of no longer fear a consequence
these things start to come out
i expect those things to happen
today
have there been laws broken yes there
have even today
there have been
issues of bribery
that the company has admitted to and
they've had to pay fines for that those
have broken international codes
there are ongoing investigations
by no fewer than four government
agencies into halliburton right now
sec gao pentagon
and i believe the army corps of
engineers is also looking into them
so
do i expect
foul play to come out of that yes i do
and i think that you'd be pretty naive
not to not to expect some some foul play
to be found
um
you know if you're referring to
you know the issue that is on the top of
a lot of people's mind which is did dick
cheney have anything to do with getting
halliburton these contracts in the first
place
that is a much much tougher nut to crack
that is something that i i don't think
you'll ever find a smoking gun to to
prove anything of that nature
it's not like he was writing memos to
the contracting officers at the pentagon
hey could you give my buddies a helmet
some help
he certainly had motive and means to do
those things anything other than that is
pure speculation though
yeah
these days we have a very small
volunteer army relatively small compared
to what we've had in some past years
on the surface
it doesn't seem unreasonable to contract
out some of the things to the private
sector that the army used to take care
of entirely itself when we had
draftees for example
to me
the key issue is is how good a job
brown and root is doing in these tasks
that it has taken on
uh and
i i wonder how
how good a job you feel that it has done
you you've touched on some of the
weaknesses some some obvious problems
but well
is this an inept outfit no not at all
it's it's been it's been very up and
down um their history in world war ii um
brown and root went into the ship
building business and created something
called the brown ship building company
they had no experience in anything even
close to shipbuilding before but they
got the contract
through some connections and
were phenomenal at it they did an
incredible job uh they won many many
awards from the army and the navy
excuse me um
and blew everybody away with how
efficient and quick they were
the strength of this company is
quickness uh they can mobilize in a
heartbeat they've got people all over
the world um they were incredibly
effective in somalia
they were very effective in bosnia
although they spent a lot of money
um
in iraq they have had
in vietnam they had considerable
difficulty in iraq they're having
considerable difficulty i think
at least part of that stems from how
insecure both of those regions were and
are
and and how difficult it is for their um
for their employees to move around the
country they've lost 34 employees
already in iraq they've had employees
kidnapped uh you know the thomas hamill
obviously escaped he was a halliburton
truck driver
so
it is very difficult for them to do
their job in iraq
that said
the
the difficulty
that most people have when it comes to
military outsourcing is the fact that
these people do not
fit into the chain of command they
cannot be court-martialed and they can
leave whenever they want to
and if they are not available
for whatever the task is that they have
to do
the military ends up suffering greatly
from that
and it goes well beyond what halliburton
does in some of the logistical support
that they provide although that is
absolutely critical to the army's
operations over there the army could not
operate without these guys
there there's also
companies that do security detail
weapons maintenance
things of that nature
can be deadly if a contractor isn't
there to fix a tank uh or a contractor
isn't there with the manual for how to
fire uh howitzer or you know whatever
the issue is it sounds absurd but that
is the that is the modern day army these
are private companies that are making
these uh
these machines and sometimes there is
not a soldier on the battlefield that
knows how to maintain them
so the argument cuts both ways you can
agree you can achieve some some great
efficiencies in that model and it's
certainly politically palatable
because you don't have to send as many
troops over there right now in iraq the
estimate is that there is one civilian
contractor there for every 10 troops
that we have there
and that's a lot of people
so uh so it is it is a growing concern
and this administration has shown
certainly uh shown a real proclivity to
towards outsourcing um and i think uh
that there there's got to be a balance
um you can't go too far with it
there was a political decision
down the level above them that the army
is going to become smaller and leaner
and more will be outsourced
and kbr have done a wonderful job of
picking up the slack
countering them into the cost issue of
kosovo is that they were so efficient
the army basically said i cannot get rid
of this contractor that's so valuable to
our operations
in iraq and i've not heard about cases
of soldiers going hungry or tanks being
unable to move because no oil
trucks were available
to
uh to deliver the oil so it sounded like
despite horrendous
conditions against them not to mention
all the political pressures at home our
kpi's been delivering the goods of the
u.s forces in iraq
um i would have to i would have to argue
that
there
they have been criticized by the
military itself
and this is that's a very rare thing to
happen to have an actual military
official come out and say that
our contractor is not doing its job and
they have done that
there have been problems with the
food delivery
substandard conditions in the kitchens
and and meals not being delivered on
time and drinkable water not being
delivered on time
and gasoline not being delivered on time
now a lot of that you know the company
will tell you
that a lot of the reason is because the
security environment is so unstable
at the same time you know
if if it were a military operation
taking care of these tasks for the army
would they do a better job of getting
the goods to the camps
it's hard to say in many cases a lot of
military personnel are diverted
to providing
to provide the security detail for the
halliburton employees as they try to do
their jobs
in this case there have the costs some
of the costs have been inexcusable the
cost over charges
have been inexcusable
and the explanations have not
uh pacified the pentagon so the pentagon
is pursuing an investigation into
um into
haliburton's work in in country um and
they have also come under fire for not
paying their subcontractors on time some
of their subcontractors have not been
paid in over a year
and some of them are in danger of
insolvency right now because halliburton
is not coming through with
with their payments
so and they subcontract about 50 percent
of the work that they do out there uh so
there have been times in the past where
this company has come through with
flying colors um somalia comes to mind
world war ii comes to mind um but that
is not the case in iraq um and the
circumstances uh surrounding how they
obtained the contracts in the first
place is very controversial
um
and that is also being looked into uh so
so the whole pretext for the work that
they're doing there and the nine billion
dollars of of contracts uh that they
have potential of gaining uh is under
scrutiny
yeah
dan why is uh
the vice president's picture on the
cover of your book
well um i think that
when you think of halliburton um i think
most people today think of dick cheney
right away he's the one who
sort of made this company famous or
infamous if you will um
it's true that uh that dick cheney is
actually a a relatively small part of
this book this this book is a corporate
biography that looks at the company from
1919 all the way through to the modern
day um but at the same time you know for
the current reader
of a book about halliburton
they need to help have some help
identifying this company who who is
halliburton oh yeah it's dick cheney's
company
and
and i want to read a little bit about
what dick cheney had to do with uh
what's going on uh in iraq today in the
halliburton contracts by your own
admission though there's not a shred of
evidence that he had any any kind of
arcane
influence on the whole process
uh that's true there there is no
evidence that dick cheney had a hand in
actually you know steering contracts to
his old company but i think if if that's
all you're focusing on if that's the
only part of the story that you think is
important i think you're missing a much
the much broader story here which is i
have other questions also but i mean i'm
looking at him right now yes i heard
what you have to say and you know i
don't understand why my picture isn't on
there today the truth
that you have as much proof
about
my influence on those contracts as
apparently you do on him right but he
spent five years as the ceo of the
company and i think that that uh and is
now the vice president and uh yeah but i
can create any scenario you like on a
situation like that is all i'm saying
i you know
philosophy two and freshman college you
know false syllogism
you know if your basic premises are
wrong
then undoubtedly you're going to have a
conclusion that fits but it's incorrect
well i don't think by putting dick
cheney on the cover book that i'm
promising uh that i'm going to tie him
to the contracts in iraq no he does but
doing that as far as i'm concerned it
fits into the current
that
fits into the current level of
administration bash
and you know i mean if that's the way
your people want to market it i think
that dick cheney is responsible for the
state of this company today
the the decisions that he made during
the five years that he was ceo have put
them in the position that they're in
today which is
they now have two of their subsidiaries
that have had to declare bankruptcy
including kellogg brown and route
and they are also uh one of the one of
the government's biggest contractors and
that had a lot to do with uh dick cheney
and his time at the company subject of
the
harvard business review of a failed
executive as opposed to uh in this
situation and that's all covered in here
as well the other thing is the question
is um
what companies would be
capable
of being competitive with them
um over the past 10 years the number of
companies
that
would be able to do this type of
logistical outsourcing has diminished
greatly
partially because of the the size and
length of the contract that kbr
originally won in 1992.
now if you've got a five-year contract
to provide all of the logistical support
for the army uh during that time any
other company that would be suited to
that kind of work would have trouble
finding work obviously because there's
only one army
so
the the length of these contracts has
limited
the amount of competition that can
naturally be in this marketplace and if
you talk to um if you talk to peter
singer uh who i quoted earlier um he
will tell you that the
the basic motives behind privatization
uh which is competition uh and and
penalties uh those are the two sort of
governing forces of the free market
that there's open competition
for the business in the first place and
then if you don't do the business well
there's penalties for that
have been eroded by this contract
because kbr has held it for so long
because they're now inextricable from
the army uh
their the competition has waned there
really is no one that can step in and do
it and the the army is finding it very
difficult to penalize the company um for
wrongdoing or overcharges or things like
that because they become so dependent on
them as uh the example that i that i
showed in uh in bosnia pointed out
wouldn't gsa do that under the liquid
data damages clause in any contract did
you do with the government well there
are other uh organizations that look
into these things and and try to keep
these guys honest but
you know when you're working in a
wartime situation
i think a lot of those constraints go
out the window
however in this case i'm encouraged to
see that there has been a lot of
scrutiny
and there is a lot of ongoing
investigation by those government
agencies to look into uh just how kosher
this business has been
within he has already touched on the
question i was going to ask earlier
are there not oversight committees in
charge of such kinds of contracts my
experience has always been that you know
you're chosen
you do the job because of your
capabilities and certainly halliburton
has proven over the years it has extreme
capabilities and very difficult
situations however there have always
been oversight kinds of committees to
keep halliburton at all in check do we
not have this we do have this um
a lot of the folks who do that kind of
administrative oversight of these
contracts
are under intense pressure they have
thousands of contracts to look over in
fact during the clinton administration
that work force was significantly
reduced
by about
a third
so there are not as many people doing
contract oversight and if you talk to
some of the experts in the government
contracting field they will tell you
that these people are terribly terribly
overmatched and can't possibly do
the job that they need to do in fact the
government has outsourced some of the
jobs that are in place
to uh uh to to oversee outsourcing
contracts um so
it's a vicious cycle
what's the difference between the mafia
and halliburton
one they have no competitive bids two
political but boys like dick cheney or
[ __ ] cheney whatever you can choose
and third
no competitiveness
uh
they have the end zone on the contracts
where is where's the difference
uh the difference between halliburton
and the mafia um well i don't think the
mafia is registered with the sec or um
or you know has
shareholders that i know of
um
you know
you can
you know i think halliburton is is a
legitimate company um and in fact their
oil field services business is an
outstanding business for them if you
talk to financial analysts that cover
this company they will tell you
this company should ditch kbr they
should spin it off sell it to someone
it's not their core business uh and it's
not something that and they and the bad
press that they get from it is killing
them
however if you look at how things
unfolded in iraq
kbr was in iraq first they were in uh
they were in kuwait um they built camp
uh arif john
um they were there putting together the
housing for the troops under log cap
under an existing contract that was
already in place
that's not in question
halliburton was then brought in their
parent company
to do the
infrastructure repair of the oil of the
oil infrastructure in iraq
why halliburton was given a no-bid
contract to do that uh is is anyone's
guess you know i've talked to the folks
in the army corps of engineers who
awarded that contract and they said well
it was a secretive contract because it
was not you know it was national
security issue um and and we felt the
time was of the essence
i talked to people who were banging on
the government's door who are very
capable of doing oil repair services
they were banging on the government's
door back in november of 2002.
when when the war drums first started
beating about iraq
haliburton was given that contract at a
convenience because they were the parent
company of kbr and they were already
there and there's no reason that that
contract should have been no bid um
there's no reason that it should have
been secretive um it was it was a
contract of convenience so uh you know
do their do their connections have
something to do with that yeah i think
they do i mean i think you'd be really
naive to think that they don't
um
you know at the same time do i think
that there's anything you know along the
lines of the mafia i doubt i doubt it
goes uh quite that nefarious allison
despite the
broad entrenchment of
across the board in the rebuilding of
iraq and the allegations of billing
irregularities i have read that the
actual profit margins are quite thin
can you comment on this that's a very
good point and that's something that uh
that that i touched on earlier when
these financial analysts are looking at
the company and they're interested in
you know the shareholder interest and
they're saying why are they keeping this
company around uh one of the reasons is
for what i just told you which is that
kbr
got halliburton this incredibly
lucrative contract um to do to do the
oil infrastructure repair work um it was
sort of used as a stocking horse for
that contract um you're right the
the profit margins for this type of
business are very very slim
it is not an attractive business to many
other companies
which goes to rich's point you know how
many companies are there out there
that's doing this not that many
but remember that these contracts are
cost plus contracts so
while the profit margins may vary
between one to three percent they are
guaranteed profit margins you will not
lose money on these contracts um so and
the more money you spend the more money
you make um so
so there's no risk involved
in terms and no financial risk involved
for a company like kbr to do this kind
of work the profit margins are slim
but you know at the same time it is a
guaranteed profit and i don't know too
many companies that would turn would
turn that down
but dangerous for many of these
individuals who are there absolutely and
we've we've seen a lot of that recently
yes
can you
explain some of the similarities and
differences between the power sources
within carlile and halliburton and
if
if there's a crossover
there's not really a crossover between
these two companies they're in very
distinct
marketplaces carlyle group is of course
private equity firm
um that's much more in the financial
markets um halliburton has you know
actual products uh and services that
they deliver um so uh the the the nature
of the two companies are very very
different where they sort of intersect
is in the area of what i've been calling
the military-industrial complex
they are both companies that uh wield
political influence
both by people they hire and dick cheney
is not the only political
ex-politico that
the haliburton has hired over the years
so
they will political influence
they are involved in the defense
industry
and they are major major businesses in
this country major major economic forces
um so when you combine all three of
those things uh you you've got a very
very powerful force um in this country
and in this economy uh and so so i think
that uh you know the similarities
between the carlyle group and
halliburton uh pretty much end there
yeah
what is the paper trail if one can find
it
for
kellogg brown and rude
halliburton in the
joyous process of election contributions
and well you can
all of those are readily available you
can go to opensecrets.org and see just
how much
halliburton has contributed to the
republican party and to the democratic
party over the years you can see their
individual
contributions uh to
uh to individual politicians
and you know you'll see a a heavy um
heavy uh
balance on the republican side not
surprisingly it is it is in the oil
business and uh and that's very typical
for them um i don't think you know i
looked i poured over those numbers again
and again and tried to see you know
what they were doing why they were
spending money
here or there
and i honestly think that
they're no different than any other
fortune 500 company
in this country in the way that they
sort of dispense those funds um i think
that the type of influence that they
wield is uh is much different than uh
than the kind of thing that you can
register and look up if you read bob
carroll's biographies of lyndon johnson
and it was
halliburton or brown root at that time
covered their backside by contributing
to both sides right you know it's an
insurance policy and i'm sure isn't that
going on today well
in the carroll books
if you look at
what was going on during lyndon
johnson's senate campaigns in 41 and 48
i think they were
that was uh there was an unbelievable
amount of money uh changing hands there
and most of it was going right to lyndon
johnson
so while they would make contributions
herman brown was an incredibly astute
politician even though he never held
political office
he spread his money around very very
strategically
and he
was known in in houston and in texas and
really on the national stage
as a guy who had politicians in his
pocket
now back then it was illegal for a
corporation to make a donation to a
campaign um so they found other ways to
do it uh they would
make individual i think an individual
could make a camp a campaign donation of
up to five thousand dollars uh so herman
brown would
distribute all of these uh bonuses and
other types of payments out to his
friends and
subcontractors and whatnot and they
would then turn around and
make those donations to the campaign
there was also a lot of cash floating
around
big bags full of hundred dollar bills
that found their way to the johnson
headquarters
so
back then it was much it was it was sort
of the wild west of politics certainly
in texas at that time and things were
done a lot differently there was much
less oversight
it's it's much different now like i said
i mean you can go to a website and look
up exactly how much halliburton has
donated to
various parties
but it's uh i i would say more subtle
it's more subtle exactly
difference maybe
it's still the fact that a state house
is a dome where the cash register is
different doesn't mean better
you're right it's still happening
yes
first comment about the one to three
percent returns i'm guaranteeing that
investment returns you'll get probably
better returns for that if you invest in
five year notes of the u.s government
so you can get guaranteed
lawyer-free returns just fine but you
won't get the cash flow that these guys
are getting from from this kind of
business
possibly goes with it
but taking
on a higher point the
military-industrial complex
how is that conflict how is that
industry different than any other
industry that has
national interests in this
pharmaceutical industry have just
written
into
legislation that the government cannot
negotiate prices right the farm
community from the top subsidies are all
over the place i mean how is this
industry different than the other
industry who tries to influence the
government to maintain its interests
well i may be uh unique in this regard
but i i happen to think that the
military is a totally different industry
than other industries in this country
and part of what i read
out of the book earlier
was was why that is why is the military
different uh than other industries in
this country
part of it's because the military is is
the part of this country that goes to
war
and that is uh i think a very
significant difference between you know
the pharmaceutical industry or any other
industry that wields political influence
um
what dwight eisenhower was saying in his
farewell speech uh when he referred to
the military industry and warned against
uh the formation of a
military-industrial complex is that he
felt that there was the potential for
this industry for the defense industry
with political time with enough
political clout and ties to influence
this country's decision military
decisions and that is a very very
dangerous uh precedent to be set if
you're talking about profit-driven
companies
influencing our nation's leaders when
they decide when and where to go to war
that i think is uh is much more
disconcerting uh than uh than other
industries like pharmaceuticals although
though those have their own problems is
there any other reason
anything similar to that
having having directly influenced the
decision to go to war essentially did
they do what eisenhower would fear that
the military industrial conference
company would do
any proof that anyone that decision to
go to war had anything to do with
no no of course not um there's there is
certainly a lot of speculation around
that point um there are conflict of
interest rules that are built into
government um that are meant to uh
avoid the the even the potential for
something like that to come about
with dick cheney still receiving
deferred salary payments from haliburton
with him still in touch with the
executives at the company
i think that conflict of interest uh
those conflict of interest rules have
been violated um i think that that that
does constitute the potential
for his decisions to be influenced
i'm not saying they were i'm just saying
that that the potential is there and
that's something that i'd rather not see
in in the public servants in this
country how much they contribute to the
tax base
how much does haliburton contribute to
the tax base i don't know that number
offhand but the reason i think about
that is that
if in fact they are an american company
and say the 87 billion dollars that was
put through congress in order to help
the rebuilding there right
the taxpayers money is going back
to an american company
providing
employment for american
people plus others obviously locals i
think that's a dangerous argument to be
making i think that's
making the comment that it would follow
that that's the case right and that's
why i ask when it's all said and done
yeah i mean if you backed out the
numbers
the business to a french government you
know schlumberger is actually uh
halliburton's biggest uh competitor um
but they're sure as hell not gonna get
the contracts
in john dean's recent book and i guess
he spoke here recently
which i haven't yet finished but he
points out that
he makes the argument i should say that
uh
cheney was aware of these enormous uh
asbestos litigation liabilities with
dresser at the time
that the merger occurred in the takeover
purchasing company and
he suggests that
that chain was aware of this and knew
that this was in effect a
kind of ticking time bomb that was going
to
devastate the stock price of the company
now of course uh halliburton's stock
price dropped dramatically along with
the rest of the market
first of all do you even get into that
in your book
yeah i mean
i touch on the fact that um
within the decision-making process to
acquire dresser
there is some evidence that the
executives of the company were aware of
asbestos liability
though publicly on the record those
officials have said that they thought
that that asbestos liability it was far
far less uh than it turned out to be
they thought it was ima that's exactly
what they called it in the prospectus
that they put out to the shareholders
they called it immaterial um it turned
out and and uh to their defense uh
the nature of asbestos litigation
changed somewhat
over that over that time
um
however
it is inexcusable for a company of that
size to acquire another company of that
of dresser size um and not
understand the full extent of what of
the liability that they are acquiring um
that was clearly a mistake um and it's
another one of the things that um you
know rich you were mentioning that you
know maybe this book should be about the
the fact that cheney was a really bad
ceo and there uh is a lot of evidence in
this book about um what cheney did wrong
as ceo and i think that that really tops
the list um
and over and over again cheney has said
publicly i wasn't aware of the asbestos
litigation i wasn't aware that we were
doing business in iraq uh i wasn't aware
that we changed our accounting rules and
fair and failed to uh uh tell our
shareholders well what was he doing and
he was the ceo of this company and uh
and and these are major major decisions
that this company is going through um so
it obviously begs the question you know
what what was this guy working on the
whole time he was like
i wanted to make one comment and ask
another question apropos not knowing i
mean i'm
i do corporate investigative work and
you know that's an absolute basic thing
that you do is a litigation search and
so you you know
right this is a system straight these
are public records right you go and you
pull those files you look at them and
you
you know make an assessment about what
that's about and that's just all part of
the standard package yeah that
undoubtedly was done before the
acquisition
so i mean it just sort of bolstered your
point so it's not clear whether they
knew about it and chose to downplay it
for the sake of getting shareholder
approval of the deal
or whether they really were unaware of
it and were
not not very uh diligent on the deal
in terms of the stock price drop
the market was going to hell during that
two years anyway
was there any sort of a differential
analysis
within that
company of that type in those businesses
in terms of how their stocks performed
relative to halliburtons
in other words something where you could
point to it and say
this company's stock price declined far
more than other companies of its type
and
the asbestos litigation did have a
material absolutely i mean if you look
at those numbers uh you will see that
halliburton um suffered with the rest of
the industry and then suffered more
because of uh the massive asbestos
litigation i mean we're talking about
you know i think the final settlement
offer was 4.4 billion dollars that's a
massive chunk of money to be paying out
for for getting you know zero benefit uh
from it so
they essentially
shut down dresser
and bankrupted kbr
all throughout this process so they've
taken a tremendous hit from this uh much
more than than companies of their ilk
was there a particular day when you know
the stock went off the cliff on the
basis of some news about that
i don't know what the exact day was but
i think there was a moment when it
became suddenly clear how serious it was
i think the number of suits filed
against them had reached uh such a
massive level something like 400 000
suits um that once the press got ahold
of that uh the share the share price
really uh dipped dramatically but i
don't know when the exact date of that
was yeah you also talked about the
bonuses that they may have received
during those
years
oh the bonuses that the executives yeah
i don't actually know what their bonuses
were but but i know that uh you know
dick cheney walked away from the company
with 30 million dollars so um it wasn't
uh at the time that he left the company
it was not seen to be the disaster that
it is today um and uh sort of
inexplicably the the company still loves
dick cheney um they they look to him as
sort of a godfather um you know i've
talked to people in the industry who say
you know these these guys love to talk
to dick they love to get his opinion on
things and um and i look at his track
record as ceo and wonder why they would
ever solicit his opinion again but uh
i'm not really sure
maybe it's because he knows some things
because he's vice president i think i'll
take the liberties for the last question
americans have a very short attention
span we're in an election cycle
um
polling around white water for instance
tons you know tons of confusion
disinterest checking out
why should americans care about this
should
should they why and can you give us the
sound by the answer
number one reason they should care about
it is because it's your money being
spent and you should want to know how
it's being spent um
the second uh most important reason i
think is if a company
like halliburton reaches this level of
political influence and um and and
economic influence
it is it is a danger it is uh it is
approaching the military industrial
complex
and that's something that we should all
be vigilant about
because we want to feel that whenever we
go to war we're going to war for the
right reasons for the moral reasons
whether or not you believe that this war
is for those reasons or not you don't
want to have that doubt in the back your
mind
that there were other economic interests
involved something that hasn't been said
something that hasn't come out um and
and i think the american people deserve
that and they deserve to feel good about
uh deploying their troops someplace um
and in this case this is just one of
many things that has uh made a lot of
people sort of doubt our motives and our
interests in going to war
thanks everybody
[Applause]
dan briote is the author of the iron
triangle inside the secret world of the
carlisle group his latest the
halliburton agenda is published by wiley
for more information visit wiley.com
rowan scarborough has covered the
pentagon for the washington times for 15
years
next he discusses his new
protop chatterjee contends that private
contractors have benefited the most from
the war in iraq in his new book iraq
incorporated
this talk is an hour 40 minutes
anytime
okay hi everyone welcome tonight um to
uh a reading of iraq inc by protop
chatterjee did i pronounce her name
correctly i hope so i've known him for
several years he's a very close friend
but i still had to write down what i
need to say about him because i know him
as a close friend and i forget
what an accomplished journalist activist
and so many other things prothap
actually really is
so just to give a little bit of a
background
again i've known protap as an
environmental activist for at least
maybe five years or so
i've also known him as uh the host for
the kpfa northern california radio show
terra verde
did i pronounce that correctly
americanized somewhat prostop is a
filmmaker um responsible for um
gold rush and
some other films
a lot of the footage from fahrenheit for
911 yes is some of the yeah is also
protops
little known fact
he's a multi-awarded
investigative journalist who's written
for the london's financial times the new
republic in the u.s the guardian and
independent in britain and what he
didn't think i'd say
and i'm letting you all know is that
prothop writes extensively for playboy
magazine
yes
i don't know if he poses
[Laughter]
oh that's what you told us
okay in any event um well just one
second before i turn over the mic to
prothop just wanted to say a quick thing
about the space welcome you all to the
space and let you know that um this is a
space that we created actually for
events just like this for these kinds of
exchanges of ideas um with this kind of
art in the background this and many
other exhibits
that we've had here uh just to sort of
generate ideas um and host people also
using the house as a model for
environmental living and learning and
being so welcome tonight and um thank
you pro for tonight and here he is
thank you everybody for coming out and
as malou said i have written for a lot
of different organizations and in fact
playboy actually did commission me to
write an article about iraq which ended
up not getting published partly because
of the fast-changing nature of what's
happening in iraq today is that what's
news today three months later for
monthly magazine is no longer in fact
news because things change so rapidly so
my question in fact isn't really that
easy to write a book about this and i
think there are in fact subjects that
you can take a step back and look at the
bigger picture that indeed is what this
book iraq inc
that came out in november attempts to do
and it's really looking at private
companies in the middle east but it has
much bigger implications for the way war
is conducted
throughout the world and especially by
the united states
so in iraq inc uh i'd like to actually
introduce you to
uh four the four major issue areas that
we deal with and the first really is the
issue of military logistics so today
unlike wars
of past years
we actually have a company running and
building the military bases so they
build the bases they clean the toilets
they cook the food and this is a company
that many people here probably heard of
which is halliburton
the second aspect of the occupation of
iraq is the reconstruction so where the
united states and years of neglect under
saddam hussein have resulted in the
destruction of a lot of the
infrastructure companies like bechtel
have been hired to rebuild this
the third area of
private sector involvement in iraq is
that of private security companies and
so here you have something akin to the
mercenaries of old where people for
money will come and uh guard facilities
and provide um
even not just uh private security but
even intelligence so the kind of things
that the cia and and the military did
once upon a time these are now things
that are done by private companies in
iraq the final section of the book uh
looks at the fact that we've privatized
the government institutions themselves a
private company was hired
by the name of science applications
international corporation to plan the
ministries in iraq a private company
called research triangle institute of
north carolina was hired to teach iraqis
about democracy so i'd like to take this
opportunity actually to read a little
bit from each of the chapters and then
take questions from you about the
broader picture
the book as books tend to be you know
take a little time to get published so
the last the last thing that i wrote in
this book was written in july of last
year and in the last nine months a lot
more has come out and so i'd like to be
able to take this opportunity to
actually explain how things have evolved
and how much more we know
about especially the fraud and the
wasted taxpayer money that that's
occurred in iraq
um so the first chapter is called
operation sweatshop iraq and it's really
about that company halliburton and the
amount of money they made in iraq today
we know they've made 10 billion dollars
in contracts for the provision of every
kind of service
and the reason the
chapter is called operation sweatshop
iraq is because of the very nature of
the way they do business there now
typically in a sweatshop most people
assume sweatshops pay bad wages uh in
third world countries well actually
sweatshops typically pay better wages
than local companies often in order to
get people to work for them and that is
in fact what's happening in iraq so in
iraq iraqis have no jobs as much as 75
percent of the population didn't have a
job and so uh the company halban paid
iraqis a hundred dollars a month in
order to work for them when you have no
job 100 is better than nothing at all
it's not a living wage a living wage for
family living income is 500 a month
now they wanted to bring in people to do
jobs they didn't trust iraqis to do and
jobs such as cooking for american
soldiers because the u.s military is
afraid that iraqis might poison
the soldiers they've hired outside
workers typically from india and the
philippines and sri lanka and and they
paid them high wages say 300 a month
now for
jobs that they want americans to do uh
in particular driving the trucks they
need to pay more than somebody would get
in
the united states so for example there's
a guy who used to haul chickens in
in texas and got 12 an hour he was
offered a job for 70 000 a year which is
a really good
salary
for an american and so people journeyed
overseas they went there and did these
dangerous jobs uh because they thought
they would make a lot of money in actual
practice some of them got killed many of
them didn't get paid what they expected
to get paid hal button in fact paid them
16 an hour
once they worked out the fact that
they'd worked for 12 hours a day seven
days a week you know 365 days a year
so
this is the nature of the military
logistics jobs uh in iraq and i wanted
to
read briefly from uh the first chapter
looking especially at what
one of the main things that people have
been interested in iraq which is the the
state of the oil fields
because iraq's principal incomes comes
from drilling for oil uh in in southern
and in northern iraq and this is uh from
my travels in southern iraq iraq just
outside of basra
uh and it's a description of these oil
fields uh an oil field called al zubair
red shadows rippled across the desert
sand of southern iraq as great 10 rules
of smoke billowed out from the sheet of
flames dancing bright orange of the 12
outstretched chimneys
it sounded like a jet engine from almost
100 feet away
and if i looked into the flames i could
feel my skin burn i stepped back
glad of the blue cool sky
that allowed me to rest my eyes before i
glaze back into the hypnotic fire
eventually i tore my gaze away and
walked back with hamid miyala a foreman
for the south oil company who has worked
here at the zubair oil fields for 27
years of his life he was glad to keep
his job when saddam hussein's government
was ousted by the u.s invasion in the
early spring of 2003
since the invasion his salary had been
raised to two hundred dollars a month
almost five times his pay under the
baathist regime
the two hundred dollar paycheck one of
the highest that local
workers can earn was the product of a
long strong union struggle to maintain
iraqi jobs because the occupation
authorities preferred to hire foreign
workers despite the fact that they
command much higher wages
over the turbines they pumped the oil
from the welts the portabasra and made a
crew of three indian and pakistani
workers now being
a south asian myself i was able actually
to communicate with the workers in
bengali and urdu and so they told me
their stories
this particular group of people were
dressed in the blue uniforms of the
al-kharafi company a kuwaiti
subcontractor working for kellogg brown
and root a subsidiary of halliburton
in 2003 halibut had won contracts that
ranged from cooking meals delivering
meal and building bases to repairing
iraq's oil industry that year the
contracts totaled more than eight
billion dollars and in total in fact now
it's been the the total number of
contracts so far from iraq alone is 15
billion dollars when you think about the
fact that we spend 100 billion dollars
in iraq that in fact is in a big chunk
of the money is going to this one
private company
abdul hakim a crane operator from lahore
pakistan had worked in persian gulf the
longest of three men
after working there for 10 years he and
his colleagues earn as much as fifteen
hundred dollars a month
seven times more than the iraqi
counterparts
quote the company gives us free housing
and food and drives us here every day
across the border and i can visit my
family in lahore every year it's a good
job he said
as we chatted we were joined by two
indian workers sanjay singh and imam
hussein they had worked in the gulf for
only two years and made 550 dollars as
fabricators but they came from an army
of skilled mechanics shipped in to the
middle east from south asia
quote most of us are indian we probably
have 10 000 people in kuwait but we also
have pakistanis bangladesh in sri lankan
said singh
i left the oil fields for the nearby
city of basra to meet hassan juma who is
the leader of this south all company
union in the neighborhood of jumoria
where i pulled up to a decrepit
crumbling house i found piles of garbage
riding in the street inside i was
greeted by picture darkness a common
occasion in occupied iraq where bechtel
was struggling to restore full power to
the grid and what's most ironic about
this country where
we in fact derive a lot of our oil in
fact iraqis themselves you know are not
able to buy that oil since so much of
this is shipped to iraq and in fact in
basra itself despite the fact that so
much of iraqi oil is produced there
there is no electricity uh in these
cities
truman was surprised to hear about our
encounter with the south asian workers
just a few months prior to because just
a few months prior his union had staged
a wildcat strike to kick out the
foreigners
the policy of our company is to refuse
foreign workers we prefer to let iraqi
people do the work hal button agreed to
bring a few technicians they mostly
needed the workers the iraqi people he
told us
he shook his head grimly when i told him
how much the foreign workers earn this
is one of the reasons why we refused
foreign workers because the iraqi
workers will receive a very big gap
between his salary and that of the
foreign workers
saddam hussein had instilled the fear of
collective organizing these workers in
march 11 1987 when he abolished basic
rights including the eight hour day so
with the arrival of the americans people
were able to organize unions more
effectively than they did under saddam
hussein but if because that work had now
been handed over to foreign workers in
fact they were receiving less than under
saddam hussein's regime which employed
everybody but paid everybody very badly
saddam hussein's 1987 law asked the
right to form or join unions or to
bargain when unions in the public sector
were banned new unions were created from
the private sector according to law work
with management to increase efficiency
in work discipline
and this law creating state unions by
saddam hussein was in fact reaffirmed on
june 5th 2003 by paul brammer when he
issued a decree called the public
incitement to violence and disorder
and this edict announced that everybody
anybody who incited civil disorder
writing of damage to property will be
subject to immediate detention by the
coalition provisional authority security
forces and held as a security attorney
uh internee under the fort geneva
convention in 1949
so where once upon a time you had a
edict
issued by the brutal regime of saddam
hussein this edict in fact was
reiterated by the occupation authorities
under paul brahma
and in early december convoy of 10
humvees and armored personnel carriers
arrived at the office of the iraqi
workers federation of trade unions
whereupon the united states soldiers
stormed out
of the car arrested eight members of the
federation's executive board
the federation spokesperson abdullah
mussin said they gave no reason at all
despite being asked over and over and
although the eight were released the
following day there was no explanation
from the occupational authorities for
the detentions nor were these first
unionists to be apprehended two other
trade union leaders kasim
who is the general secretary of the
union and the unemployed and abdel salli
who's another lead of the organization
will arrest in november this is november
2003.
and the contrast with again this this
nature of the sweatshop where you have
indian workers working for about three
hundred to fifteen hundred dollars local
workers working for two hundred dollars
is the american workers coming in
and in early february the wall street
journal reported that hal burton was
shipping 500 american workers a week and
paying them four times the amount the
same workers could earn in haliburton's
native taxes offering up to eight
thousand dollars a month to drive all
trucks and so when i ask the oil workers
the members of the strongest union in
iraq what could be done to predict iraqi
jobs jumaa answered simply you can't
hide the moon each honest iraqi should
refuse the occupation our ambition is
for the occupation forces to leave as
soon as possible so one of the the
problems with creating the structure of
having
indian workers at a hundred dollars
iraqi work is a hundred dollars indian
workers at three hundred dollars and
then american workers at eight thousand
dollars is in fact you're causing a lot
of local
problems where local people are unhappy
with the american occupation and they're
saying
if if you continue this occupation you
continue not to give us jobs and you
have to understand that saddam hussein
people were paid badly but almost
everybody had a job there was a hundred
percent unemployment and even though the
enterprises are now more efficient today
what's happening is because many people
don't have a job they're joining the
ranks the resistance and and so
effectively by handing over jobs to
other other country nationals you're
actually
creating the seeds of of anger and disco
content within the country
i wanted to talk
briefly about some of the things that
have come out of halliburton's work over
there halliburton's jobs in the oil
fields were to supply oil and to supply
this oil you know to people uh in iraq
as well as to the military well
haliburton took advantage of the fact
that they had these contracts to
exclusively
provide oil to the uh american
government of the iraqi people
and in the last few weeks in fact and
this is not in the book this is you know
what's been happening recently
the us
the pentagon has
revealed documents that they in fact
didn't want to publish but a congressman
from los angeles henry waxman's office
uh put this out in the public domain
well halibut and trucked aisle which
they had paid
something like thousand dollars for and
then charge the u.s taxpayer uh 27
million dollars for and this has
happened again and again where the u.s
government was able to provide uh oil
themselves the the the department of
energy uh um uh within the the
military's own uh
energy division was able to supply oil
and and fuel at a dollar a gallon
halliburton was charging two or three
dollars for it and then pocketing the
the change and when this these factors
have you know come to light halibut and
said well we weren't very you know able
to take keep track of the money in the
past and we'll do a better job uh in the
future
the pentagon's own auditors did
an audit and they discovered that
halibut overcharged by 100 million
dollars when the us government
turned that audit over to the public
they blacked out the information that
showed how much they had overcharged by
on basis of the fact that hal button
said this is competitive information if
our competitors know that we've
overcharged they're going to use that to
win a contract by saying we were bad
company and the us government the
pentagon actually agreed to black out
that information about how the pentagon
had questioned their overcharging
um so this is and and once you start to
add up these little figures in the book
i talk about how halliburton i met this
gentleman by the name of henry bunning
and he his job was to buy towels for
soldiers now he figured he could buy
doll towels for a dollar fifty well
albertans said don't buy those tires buy
buy more expensive towels for five
dollars and the reason for that is a
system that exists within
military contracting which is called
cost plus so for every dollar you charge
you get to keep a profit and that's the
plus aspect of the cost plus
so if you charge a hundred dollars
albertan gets anywhere between two and
nine dollars profit well hey if you buy
four times as much equipment you get to
charge four hundred dollars and you get
a profit of between eight and thirty six
dollars and that's effectively what's
been happening
is albertan is
is buying redundant equipment and many
of the people i've spoken to in
haliburton have given evidence before
congress and and told me confidentially
that haliburton was overcharging
specifically because they could make
more money now
this in fact is uh is is overcharging
and making a profit because you're able
to buy redundant equipment not everybody
in fact was content to simply make a
profit through the cost plus system the
other people who said well hey what if
we double the price of what we're
selling we can then make an even greater
profit so there's a company called
custer battles who only shows up a
little in this book
but
basically what they did was they set up
a subsidiary in the cayman islands and
the cayman islands subsidiary called
secure global distribution
was bought equipment for the company in
iraq and so for example there was a
helicopter pad
that custer battles was asked to build
in mosul in northern iraq so it was
going to cost them say a hundred
thousand dollars they bought that
helicopter pad and then they charged the
government four times as much because
they bought it from their subsidiary in
the cayman islands which was a secret
subsidiary and so where they'd spent a
hundred dollars they charged 250
and then made a profit besides and they
got caught when somebody one of the
founders of the company left a piece of
paper on an office in baghdad showing
that they'd purchased equipment for
three and a half million dollars and
then build nine million dollars so this
wasn't the question of buying redundant
equipment this was outright fraud
and
one of the gentlemen who's in charge of
paying this company was a guy called
frank willis
and so in order to pay the company they
paid them money out of iraq's own income
because
if they paid them out of u.s government
uh money they would have had to provide
receipts back to the us congress and to
us taxpayer payer people like ourselves
so what they did is instead of doing
that they borrowed iraq's money and paid
them and frank willis who's the
gentleman in question worked for the
government has a photograph of how he
took two million dollars in brand new
treasury bills brought out of the
basement and handed it over to them uh
directly now you would ask why is this
company why does this company have this
contract why are they over billing is
this a company the government trusts
well actually this company custer
battles was created on the spur of the
moment in baghdad uh by two gentlemen
who had very little work experience but
figured that since they were formal
military they could make a profit at it
so mike battles and scott custer uh two
guys with a credit card asked the us
government for money and then with that
money set up a company and went from a
million dollar company in one year to a
hundred million dollar company you know
overnight in in a year and what they
were spending was our taxpayer money and
engaging in deliberate fraud and this
company has now been taken to court by
people who worked there who blown the
whistle on them
and when they went to court their lawyer
went to court and said
well hey
first of all this is not american money
this is iraqi money second of all this
entity that was created the coalition
provisional authority set up by
the um by the us government was never
legitimized by either the u.s congress
or the united nations therefore it's an
illegal authority and therefore you
can't sue us under u.s law which is the
law they're saying which is the false
claims act
so
the judge was incredibly puzzled by this
whole thing and he turned to the bush
administration and he said tell me is is
this legitimate money and the u.s
administration was asked to provide an
answer in january of 2005 and they said
give us another month february 18th they
had a date in federal court and the u.s
government said give us another 45 days
here's their conundrum if the u.s
government pays out
if the u.s government says yes this was
a legal authority they can be caught for
stealing you know uh uh for for false
the company can be caught for false
claims on the other hand if they say
well no this is iraqi money and this
authority was never constituted legally
well all the laws that uh that paul
bremer passed such as the union laws etc
become
illegal laws so they're caught between
you know a rock and a hard place between
the devil and the blue sea whatever
answer they get
you know is going to backfire on on the
government so we're waiting to hear uh
what exactly the answer will be
so custom battles is perhaps you know
just the tip of the iceberg or maybe
they're just a rogue company there maybe
not everybody does business that way but
i want to give you another com example
that the the public's very familiar with
which is a company called blackwater and
and again this is discussed in the book
blackwater is a company from north
carolina and blackwater was hired to
provide security they provide security
directly to paul bremer uh the the guy
who was in charge of iraq
now the individuals that you may have
heard of the four people uh that were in
fact caught and killed in fallujah in in
in late spring of 2004 worked for
blackwater and they were paid 600 a day
now for those uh individuals that in
fact was a very good salary compared to
what they made when they worked for the
special forces because they were paid a
couple of hundred dollars a day so
anybody who's being paid three times as
much is going to go work for somebody
else
what in fact has not come really to
public light was the black water was
subcontracted to another company in
kuwait
uh called regent and regent was
subcontracted company in
germany called uh called ess and ess was
subcontracted to halibut so that's 600
on the cost plus
regent was allowed to charge their
overhead and administration and the
profit
and a
region then could charge an overhead and
a profit to ess and ess could charge it
to hal button so we the taxpayer will
pay
1500 a day
uh for this individual who had they uh
worked for the special forces would have
been paid 200 a day and personally i
don't begrudge paying a somebody working
a hard job being paid
but i question the fact that thirteen
hundred dollars is being skimmed off by
intermediary companies in between who
are not even doing the job uh over there
i think that's a waste of our taxpayer
money and that's effectively what's
happening is that money is being skimmed
off the top by each of these companies
through the system called cost plus
and it's being skimmed off the top by
companies back in the united states
custom battles is based uh for example
in rhode island
um
the people at the bottom of the heap in
fact are the people who uh get not who
get killed in the streets of fallujah or
in in many cases the people on the very
front lines are in fact the the iraqi
soldiers who you hear about every day
the iraqi police are getting blown up
because they're holding the guns in
front of you know the embassy or or the
construction company
more so than that in fact the people who
they employ typically right outside the
perimeter of the most dangerous are
people from third world countries so in
this case many of them are gurkhas from
nepal and i want to read a quick section
from this chapter called soldiers of
fortune
man bahadur guru fingered a machine gun
his machine gun a little nervously the
view from the 18th floor of the sheraton
one of the tallest buildings in baghdad
was spectacular despite the fact that
most of the city had no electricity and
that only wealthy homes and businesses
equipped with generators lit up the
night
behind him halliburton employees chatted
over dinner
stepping out of the elevator i noticed
he eyed me with apprehension i wore no
badge and looked generally out of place
gurung island was a former gurkha
soldier one of a long line of soldiers
for hire
in 1817 the british army once employed
first employed gurkhas hadi nepalis from
the himalayas as a local supply of hired
guns in india
gurung works for the armor group one of
dozens of security companies in the
country his firm was hired by
halliburton to guard the employees who
live in the sheraton tower
gurung was far for home far from home
but it wasn't his first time away he had
worked previously in warton sierra leone
and in angola guarding ranger oil
facilities and many of these many of
these private guards in fact come from
working in oil fields in other countries
it's it's the business that's most
lucrative
i asked if i could get a drink at the
cafe and he reluctantly agreed to call
of a halliburton employee the answer was
an emphatic no and he asked me to leave
gesturing with his gun towards the
elevator i tend to leave stepping back
into the elevator on my descent i
noticed grunge colleagues stationed in
every floor
from the penthouse through the eighth
floor sporting the blue uniform of the
armor group a flak jacket and a machine
gun the gurkhas stood watch
the next day across town in the basement
of the convention center where bechtel
has its offices we met maniram guram
another guruka no relation outside the
united states council's office standing
in front of photographs of dick of bush
dick cheney and powell going watch
american soldiers iraqi government
officials and contractors hurry by
conversing in the business of nation
building but he was not a member of the
occupation forces his red badge
identified him as an employee of another
private security called global risks
for both these
riflemen iraq
god duty was yet another boring but
well-paying job allowing them to send
thirteen hundred dollars home to their
families every month it wasn't as much
as they earned in the british army
twenty five hundred dollars a month in
1990 but it helped pay the bills and
there were certain advantages the job
only lasts for eight to six months
whereas the british army postings in
exotic locales like brunei and hong kong
allowed for visitors visits homes only
once every three years
mani ramgurung told me that his group
was confined to the barracks at night it
men to trailer home where the food is
strictly english a euphemism to mean
western food provided by halibut and
sweatshop cooks from india whose base
pay was just three three dollars a day
while godzilla growing make a princess
salary by middle eastern standards their
iraqi counter parts make far less
muhammad al-husseini the ever cheerful
head of security at the barricades
outside the sheraton hotel told me that
he made just a hundred dollars a month
not enough to support his wife and two
kids but better than nothing in a job
with estimated 70 percent unemployment
i would like a job with the american
companies i have a second degree black
belt in karate and i know how to fire
every kind of weapon ak-47s m16s all of
them
but my friends work for halibut and
security make four hundred dollars a
month and american european security
guards make even more he can find it in
me
later i work i ran into two burly man
with large two-way radios and guns
waiting calmly outside an internet cafe
as i left
i noticed they looked european and wore
matching casual light green clothing
stopping to chat i asked them where they
were from trade delegation sir said one
with an english accent
the other had a bright uh strong
scottish accent and his his open flag
jacket revealed a logo on his shirt that
read alive security
indeed it is not it is not it is hard
not to notice the poker face men with
guns patrolling every sensitive location
in iraq unofficial estimates of these
numbers of these ex-soldiers for her
suggest that 20 000 armed men and a few
women too in iraq providing security
services to private companies government
facilities and occupation
forces the vast majority of these guards
are iraqis who earn between sixteen two
hundred dollars a month performing a
function not different from bank guards
in other countries in the world a
contract i was shown from group four
falc a british security company offered
two armed guards 24 hours a day for any
building for six thousand dollars a
month which the iraqi gods soldiers
salaries
amounted to just 10 percent
and i go on to explain the nature of
these different uh
uh soldiers if soldiers from nepal from
india from fiji at the bottom they need
gods from chile south africa ex-soviet
black personnel and then of course the
top of the uh heap uh the gods from
britain and the soviet union in fact
what's uh most interesting is a lot of
the people that have been uh found there
in fact a number of people have been
killed are people who used to work
for debt squads in el salvador in chile
in south africa three people who were
killed in south africa in fact were
people who had by their own admission
gone before the truth and reconciliation
commission in south africa and admitted
to being part of uh political
assassinations and in south africa the
way uh
uh the white apartheid gods were brought
back into the mainstream of life they
were allowed to go free
if they confessed their their their jobs
and and what they had done in the
previous regime the problem of course is
that once you've confessed it nobody
wants to hire you and in fact many of
them will like we don't have jobs so
when the jobs in iraq showed up they won
the first plane out to iraq and many
people there were ex-south african gods
now there there there are people from
chile there are people from colombia now
people from el salvador in the last six
months that have showed up there
and these are private security guards
some of them are training the iraqi
police force there's a company called
vanell there whose job was treating
people training people in how to join
the police force and join the army
now many of them in fact did a very bad
job and one of the reasons the iraqi
army is is in fact not able to do the
job they did is this company vanilla for
example in their training
for the first iraqi battalion was
basically showing them and then i kid
you not jackie chan movies and sylvester
stallone movies and saying you know
the the soldiers themselves were given
you know uh were were given
guns that you know uh without bullets
they were given uh um
uh uh um
they were given uh
uh uh
uniforms that didn't fit
and many of them deserted the army half
of the people that signed up in the
first place deserted probably with their
guns and probably joined the resistance
so on the one hand we're paying people
lots of money from other countries and
we're paying 60 dollars to these iraqi
soldiers trained by private companies
training them badly and they're leaving
with their weapons so you have to ask
where is you know a lot of this
resistance coming from and in fact the
us military has documented numerous
instances the people that have been
involved in shooting american
contractors american soldiers were
people who not only were working iraqi
police were not only wearing iraqi
police uniforms in fact worked for the
iraqi police services
so um this is um
the nature of the way these private
contractors have been training uh um uh
the soldiers and and the police in the
iraqi uh force
i want to read a couple more sections
briefly and then open it up for
questions
one i think of the interesting things
about the
contracting of private people within
the security forces is the fact we're
not only turning over private security
jobs we're even turning over the jobs of
interrogation
over to private contractors so
we have um
the interrogations in the abu ghraib
prisons which most people here probably
heard of which were
put all over television simul hersh from
the new yorker you talked about the fact
and they've been multiple pentagon
investigations the fact that these
people are involved in sexual abuse
uh all sorts of different kinds of abuse
well a lot of the people that did this
were in fact private contractors and i
personally know a couple of people who
worked in these prisons and they say
they were hired to do these jobs often
with very little
experience himself so there's a
gentleman by the name of stefan
stefanowitz he worked for private
company called kaki and kaki was
hired
actually by the department of interior
to do database contracts in the united
states
so this is the the agency of the united
states that does you know puts out
forest fires that contract turned into
an interrogation contract in iraq
and one of the men who was hired there
stefan stefanowitz was in fact trained
in imagery analysis which is you know a
euphemism for studying photographs and
looking for
you know um military equipment and
weapons of mass destruction well it's
defense stefan stefanowitz was put into
a prison and asked to interrogate people
so when he did that he had no experience
he'd not studied the geneva conventions
he did his job wrong in fact he was
involved in a lot of human rights abuses
that in fact now
has landed him in jail in the united
states so when we privatize these
contracts of intelligence of
interrogation and private security over
the people who may be qualified in in
fact in the wrong field we're handing
over you know human rights uh
sensitive human rights jobs over to
people who in fact we can never try back
in the united states because they are
not military uh uh officials a multi a
soldier who has been involved in human
rights abuse could be brought in to um
be tried in front of a military tribunal
a private contractor can only be fired
and especially if they have private
contractor from another country such as
south africa colombia
um
i wanted to read briefly um
uh um from uh the uh the fourth chapter
uh which is really about the the final
sector uh that is kind of an unusual
thing the companies had been hired to
teach people uh about democracy um
and uh one of the people that was hired
was a gentleman by the name of al haynes
and he arrived from houston
and his job he was a former city
official in the city of houston who had
quit his job after quietly using his
position to triple his own pension and
having endured a string of embarrassing
failures to balance the city budget
haynes who was the city of houston's
chief administrative officer resigned
from his job and went to iraq to lead a
team advising the city of baghdad just
over two months before his former boss
mayor lee brown
having completed the maximum of three
terms in office was about to step down
he left behind ongoing complaints about
his inability to save to solve the
city's finance fiscal crisis which dug
the mayor himself and himself
for example the end of 2000 haynes had
to bagel for a last minute loan of eight
million dollars from the city's health
benefits fund and a million dollars from
the workers compensation so the city of
houston could pay 9 000 police officers
and firefighters in december 29th
um it's beyond me how something like
that could happen it's not like making
payroll is a surprise councilwoman anis
parker said haynes defense was there
when strict rules and how much cash the
city can have on hand without facing a
penalty from the internal revenue
service
but that past june the city council was
forced to pay on a transfer
vote in a transfer 30 million between
funds in part to pay employees two days
before paychecks went out in 1999 the
city faced a cash shortfall of 38
million dollars
after overestimating tax revenues
but bad fiscal management plagued most
cities in the united states but what
makes haines most unusual was that under
his watch the pension bond the pension
board strapped the city government with
a 1.3 billion debt in 2003 that was
projected to 1.8
hit 1.8 billion dollars by 2009
a houston chronicle analysis published
in math march 2004 five months after
haynes departed showed that his pension
rose from thirty six thousand dollars a
year under the old 1998 negotiated
before he take office to 103 000
a year on the new 2003 plan which he was
in charge of negotiating so this man
tripled his salary then quit his job and
went to work for lucrative salary in
iraq whereas he can balance the budget
to pay police officers in the city of
houston
and while city officials fumed james was
almost half a world away living on
saddam hussein's son's palatial property
and haines
gave an interview to local
newspapers and he talked about how in
houston we have 88 neighborhoods and lo
and behold in baghdad you have 88
neighborhoods he marveled at the fact
that people had similar discussions in
meetings the similarities unbelievable
people make the arguments and i've heard
them before he told the cox news service
reporter
when when
uh his employee rti dispatched abraham
mustafa hussain the deputy mayor baghdad
overseeing the city's wide and sewer
system on tour of houston he marveled at
the same similarities there are 88
councils here we have the second thing
is our city is flat just like baghdad
and the services you have in houston are
similar to what we have i mean the sewer
network the same equipment we use the
same thing we have the same problems
with the roads we have he told the
national public radio in fact he told us
to an old friend of mine steve inskeep
but there are crucial different
differences between the two cities for
example the city officials in houston
are elected by the residents while those
in baghdad are appointed by the
occupation authority and managed by rti
another major difference is that neither
the city local city councils not the
city of council of baghdad controlled
budgets those budgets in fact were
handed out by the occupation authorities
so you have to wonder why at the end of
day this company research triangle
institute of america which was hired to
teach iraq is about democracy failed in
their task they went there
and their job
was instead of teaching iraqis about
democracy was to set up a system which
they called selections not elections
instead of electing people they
appointed people and lo and behold they
had a little bit of a problem here and
it was the fact that the us government
itself is often is chaotic and and badly
planned
so rti this private company set up a
local city council in taji only to
discover the pentagon had set up its own
city council so then the corporate-led
city council and the city council set up
by the pentagon ended up you know being
at loggerheads so
one arm of the u.s government doesn't
know what the other gov
is doing and and before you think that
this is a great conspiracy for uh
companies to make a lot of money i would
argue that there was a lot of chaos in
iraq and you know having traveled there
a couple of times i could see how nobody
really was communicating with each other
it's not an excuse but it leads to in
fact a disastrous situation for the
people of iraq and one that is in fact
exploited by
the resistance so you have people for
example
trying to repair bechtel a company from
right here in san francisco trying to
repair the infrastructure
the us government fired all the people
in charge of infrastructure in iraq
before because they said they worked for
saddam hussein those people joined the
resistance blew up the power plants
today people in iraq in fact despite the
fact that we've assigned 18 billion
dollars to this private company to
restore it by backtails on admission
half of these things still don't work in
fact there's less electricity less water
and worse sewage than before the war and
they met a lot of these back tail
workers and they're very frustrated
they're doing their best but things keep
getting blown up and one of the reasons
is the people that who knew the job and
in my travels um in in chapter two i
talked about meeting you know the
engineers in southern iraq where they
told bechtel employees this is how to
fix the uh the
the network the the power network and
bechtel employees said no well what we
need to do is build new power plants the
new power plants take a long time to to
bring online and so effectively what
happened was
it took so long that you know through
the hot summers people got very upset
and turned on the people that they had
in fact many people did well welcome the
occupation and thought they would see uh
you know better conditions down the road
today two years after the occupation of
iraq in fact
there is less water less electricity
except in certain places
and and in fact there's less oil pumped
uh by halliburton and south oil company
not all company than under saddam
hussein and i don't want to blame the
private companies for that this in fact
is a result of a very determined
resistance but effectively by handing
over power to people and and management
to people who have no experience and uh
bent on making as much money as they can
in fact
we have failed the effort to give
to turn democracy and and liberation
over to the people of iraq so
we in fact are in a worse mess than we
started
and um maybe i'll i'll i'll stop right
then and and take questions from the
floor and
in either what's happening in iraq or uh
what's happening uh in the privatization
of military in in other countries
because this is not simply something
that's happening in iraq it's happening
in the philippines it's happening in
colombia it's happening in afghanistan
um it's happening with u.s forces and
it's actually happening with um
the militaries particularly for example
the british government uh has
is following the same path of the us
government and turning over the
management of you know naval facilities
over to halliburton um which they're now
getting you know overcharged for
but um there's a question back there
yeah
there were some allegations during the
war that halliburton and subsidiaries
particularly kbr were sending
oil trucks and other vehicles in on long
distance convoys without spare tires
such that
what if and when the tire got shot out
or blown up they would just abandon the
vehicle and purchase a new one and that
was incentivized by the cost plus
bidding
how pervasive is that is that still
going on
and
what would be a more appropriate way of
organizing these contracts that would
eliminate
that because obviously the cost plus
thing was was dreamed up as a way to
solve
i imagine some other forms of corruption
well caspase was really dreamed up
because
20 years ago the u.s military
was in enrolled in a bunch of scandals
where they were being charged 500
dollars for a hammer and 750 dollars for
toilet seat
i'm kind of making those figures up but
really people are being charged a
hundred times more than they should have
and so the government said well we're
going to issue a manual which says this
is what things cost and you cannot buy
things for 500 that should legitimately
cost a hundred dollars and and kbr in
fact perfected the system of right here
in california and monterey of of create
of taking things from that army manual
and then buying extra things so in cost
plus taking what they should have bought
one thing and buying four things for
what it translated to in iraq was
actually sending these ghost convoys of
trucks um there are a couple of
legitimate reasons for this one is uh
they say that they they sent a lot of
truck uh uh trucks you know laden with
equipment from one end of a rock to the
other and they came back empty but what
uh what we've discovered in testimony
from truck drivers and i met with many
of these truck drivers in fact many of
those trucks went empty and came back
empty so much so that the truckers
estimated one in three trucks was
traveling empty and there was of of a
convived 28 trucks 26 of them were empty
and they have video footage of this they
have the the bills the way made up and
the reason is halliburton gets to charge
a thousand dollars for each truck
journey so the more truck journeys they
make the more money they make so you
have two thirds of these trucks going
empty and
the same thing is parallel in the
provision of food in saudi arabia one
particular bill that halberton handed in
for 42 000
meals cooked for soldiers it tended
they'd only cooked 14 000 meals so 28
000
meals were completely fictitious
albertans said well this is chaos it's a
wall we don't know what's going on but
these things are repeating again and
again and i've talked to truckers as
recently as november um 2004 where
they've repeated these same stories now
again there are reasons why the track
trucks were abandoned is that when
you're traveling on these highways
if uh the truck breaks down if you stop
to repair you know one of these you know
18 wheelers it could take you a couple
of hours you're open to being you know
blown up and so one of the reasons
halibut doesn't fix them
on the spot is they're worried that
something uh and they might get attacked
and so in fact uh they have the system
by which they
abandon the trucks now since they're
buying the most expensive trucks around
85 000 trucks and then abandoning them
for because the tower was blown out it
means a lot waste of taxpayer money but
more so than that halliburton's policy
is to blow these trucks up
just in case they fall in the hands of
the resistance so the end of the day
you kind of have um
a a problem because you have no way to
transport these materials
uh
because they might get blown up and if
they do i mean i i'm not sure that i
have a solution first of all i i think
that they shouldn't be sending empty
trucks that in fact is is is fraud and
mismanagement there there was in fact an
incident in which uh a group of 19 truck
drivers drove from uh camp anaconda to
the um baghdad airport and hal button in
their effort to get fuel to the baghdad
airport sent the truckers two different
ways um
and one
convoy got attacked and one didn't and
so of course the truck drivers were
upset they were like were we just decoy
and were our lives expendable you know
they've questioned this the the leader
of the convey was a man by the name of
thomas hamill uh the the convoy that was
attacked seven people died 12 men
escaped thomas hamill in fact was
kidnapped and a month later you know uh
uh he came back but once they got to the
baghdad airport the the people at the
airport said well we didn't need this
fuel why did you come in the first place
so no i don't know that hal button
deliberately plan to send these people
in the wrong place but
there is very poor management and people
sending convoys of trucks and that
happened multiple times where people
would show up with equipment and the
soldiers would be like we don't need
this why do you come here is it it's
incredibly chaotic because of war
because of bad management and in hal
burns defense you could also say that
they were asked
to do a small contract that they didn't
expect would get this large so they were
overwhelmed but that's no excuse two
years later uh whereas two years later
this is still happening people are still
driving those trucks those empty trucks
the trucks are still being blown up
and um things are not getting anywhere
so
i really think and the pentagon
themselves have admitted today there was
actually uh there was um a gao report
that in which the gao said the u.s
government needs to take more control of
these contracts they need to manage
these contracts
the problem you have in fact one of the
people that i met there was somebody who
was an auditor private company auditing
contracts of private companies and when
i asked
this person whether or not she was
finding you know uh instances of abuse
she said well if i report instance of
abuse i work for private company we'll
lose the contract to do the audit
so you have this catch-22 situation
where you you're damned if you do in
your damn if you don't go ahead question
over here um i read your book and
hearing you now you know i have always
commented it's powerful it's thought
provoking it's well researched
i think it attacks uh you know
an underlying theme is it attacks this
trend in terms of delivery of public
services that we privatize because uh
government is in ineffective government
is corrupt
therefore we should leave it to the
private sector to provide these services
um
and that's the whole thing that i'm
seeing
from your your book you know there's a
breakdown in the market and that
market-based or business-based
services is not the way to go in
delivering
social services public services health
services environmental services
therefore
what will be an alternative are you
saying we should go back to the old
paradigm which is
we should go back to government we
should trust the government to deliver
these public services or should we go
back to a third sector that's emerging
right now globally which is the
non-profit sector community-based
organizations non-governmental or
organizations private voluntary
organizations
who should be providing public services
well i think the key and there's been a
lot of debate as to whether
privatization is good or privatization
is bad and i think
really the the issue at stake i think
and there's a really good book actually
in the subject called in the public
interest commissioned by unions where
they look at not simply of course i'm
talking about war and i'm looking at
that but they look at at the provision
of water and the very services that you
mentioned
and and and the key thing i think is
accountability i grew up partly in india
and i uh
grew up in a city called calcutta where
we didn't have electricity you know 50
of the time i i i studied you know by
the light of a kerosene lamp for my high
school exams i'm well aware of the
problems with public sector companies
and how bureaucratic they can get but i
think private sector companies can do
the same thing the issue here is
transparency accountability experience
and the fact the public needs to be
whether it's the public sector or the
private sector be able to question
overspending be able to question the
absence of services and and i very much
believe that the non-profit sector is a
good answer to that because
because they don't their job is not
making profit their job is in fact
providing services they're a better
alternative and in fact you you see that
throughout the world in the developing
world in in in areas of conflict i
remember being in afghanistan in in late
december 2001 right after the u.s
invention and i met this czech ngo which
was restoring schools now they do that
for very little money because their job
is providing education when you turn it
over to the private sector the private
sector says our job is making as much
money as we can for our shareholders in
fact you have a conflict of interest
because they make more money when they
charge higher bills
that's not to say that a private sector
company can't do it well but you do have
to have an oversight mechanism and that
simply doesn't exist so where you have
you know u.s government soldier doing a
job for a thousand dollars if you're
gonna if that government soldier is
going to
leave the company go work for private
sector companies get paid three thousand
dollars we're not going to save money
we're going to lose money are we going
to have better services provided well it
depends on whether or not the company is
going to provide services to people who
let's say don't pay
now in in the case of people who want
water supply
if they don't pay will a private sector
company provide uh service to them
probably not unless they are forced to
so that's where you know the
government's role comes in is the
government going to write a contract
which ensures
that uh public survivors services are
provided to everybody so in my opinion
you need a company that's experienced or
public sector public sector or private
sector company
that is transparent and accountable and
if it does and a company and a system by
which the poorest of the poor and
everybody gets basic services and those
are guaranteed so let's say you could
have a free market and let's say gold
coins for example now since this is now
what somebody depends on i think it's
fine to have a free market in in the
trading of marbles or the trading up on
the other hand when you're talking about
basic human rights like water and
education this is something that has to
be guaranteed to the public whoever
provides it and i think the non-profit
model is a good one i think the private
sector could do a job but there has to
be very strict controls on how they
provide those services
um and uh in in in a situation like iraq
when you're talking about conflict
there's not a lot of people who will do
it um out of the goodness of their heart
and and the argument the u.s military
has come to me and and given is well hey
you know people don't want to work in a
war zone a lot of ngos have left iraq
and then that's very true
and of course you have this catch-22
situation where they've left iraq
because people profited out of it and
and that sort of thing but um it is true
that um
in in areas of conflict uh a lot of
people don't want to do those jobs but i
do think there are organizations like
the united nations that could play a
legitimate role there whose job isn't in
the united nations is bureaucratic and
and even if it's a public sector thing
they're not perfect
but their job isn't making maximum
profit
and i think whoever cheats whether
they're a public government servant or
private sector thing needs to you know
be uh held accountable and go to jail
you know if if they rip off the the
people
so i don't know if that answers your
question but there's a question in the
back
some companies such as blackwater and
triple canopy have been recruiting
soldiers from el salvador chile other
places in the world
i'm curious if the paragon continues
this trend of using private companies
to perform the military services and
these companies are hiring
foreign soldiers
does this make war more palatable for
the u.s public if it's not asking as
much of our citizenry and if we were
able to hire
these services rather than draft them or
ask their own citizens to perform them
the question is whether or not using the
private sector to uh uh to perform a lot
of the operations uh makes it more
palatable the u.s
public and i think that's a very
legitimate concern and and in fact i
would go beyond that in in the vietnam
war for example a lot of people were
sent all the way from the united states
to vietnam you know whether they were
reservists or national guard some of
their jobs people had to do everything
they had to peel potatoes they had a
clean toilet set to guard uh
you know the camp and a lot of people
didn't want to do that they didn't want
to be drafted to go to another country
where
they were not familiar with the culture
people didn't like them they were
getting shot at it was you know you know
uh they were far away away from their
loved ones today because we can hire
private sector employees to do that we
can actually move those menial tasks out
and and and in fact make it easier from
the point of view of soldiers soldiers
are like well okay all i do is show up
and
fire a gun i don't have to i don't have
to do you know kitchen duty kp i don't
have to do you know so it makes it more
palatable in fact for the soldiers
themselves except of course in a
situation like iraq when they get shot
at anyway uh but um
so it legitimize it it also makes it
easier uh for people in the the um in
the public not to notice the number of
people that are getting killed so for
the 1500 people that have died in iraq
there are at least 300
foreigners who have been killed and in
fact probably once you add in the number
of iraqis then we're talking thousands
of people it makes it easier because
we're hiring iraq history they're
expendable their names don't show up
they don't their families don't call
their congressman or congress person
so it makes it much much much more
palatable there's in fact an even more
devious uh uh uh practice that's uh
afoot in countries like colombia and it
it and again again it's it's trying to
change from the way we practiced uh the
military in vietnam in vietnam the us
government engaged in a secret war in
laos and cambodia which the public
didn't know about and discovered many
years later
so congress in an effort to prevent that
has actually stipulated to the u.s
government if it's involved in a country
like colombia they can only employ 300
individuals and 300 um
[Music]
us citizens
that's not an exact number but it's
close to the exact number
so in turning that com
that job over to private contractor you
can actually bypass congress's laws by
hiring somebody from a third country so
where once upon a time
in laos we sent 2 000 american soldiers
now we send 600 u.s citizens but 1400
salvadorans costa ricans filipinos to
another country and we in fact
basically bypass the spirit of the law
that congress
created in order to ensure that the us
government didn't
get involved in a secret war in another
country there were legitimate reasons
why the u.s government did that they
didn't want to get trapped in a war
mandated by you know you know a a
commander-in-chief that really the
congress had never approved so this is
the the slippery slope that we're going
down in using private sector contractors
apart from wasting taxpayer money where
in fact this is foreign policy you know
by fiat by by by the private sector of
course those private sector companies
could decide what they want to do
whatever they wanted and in colombia you
have those private sector companies in
fact you know fumigating fields you know
destroying people's crops and in fact
those individuals are suing the
companies uh suing suing the uh the
companies in the u.s government for that
and it's taken on a whole new um uh um
degree of of of of of war
which involved local people who are now
fighting back and so
it's it's an incredibly dangerous trend
so um another question over here
you mentioned that people are suing the
private companies in colombia and that
brings up the question in what ways are
private companies less accountable
than government if you do have the
recourse to sue
well the question the question is about
whether or not if you sue companies in a
third country such as colombia
why people are not accountable um uh
because there is an avenue well um
when we talk about human rights abuse
just to start with a very simple example
of the prison scandals in iraq uh
when a company is involved in
in human rights abuse the most that you
can gain out of that
is is the company losing the contract
you can't actually sue them for the
human rights abuse in the way that the
military tribunal can put a soldier on
trial and in fact soldiers were involved
in in human rights abuse in iraq have
been put on trial and been sentenced to
prison the private contractors can walk
away from the contract they are not
subject to military law
and of course if they are citizens of
the third country you know the question
is where do you sue them do you sue them
in iraq well paul bremer passed a law in
iraq which said you cannot sue a private
contractor in
uh iraq so then where do you sue them in
the united states well you could try or
you could try to sue them in colombia if
you see them in colombia maybe the
colombian courts don't really care about
what happens in iraq or maybe the laws
are not as strict as they might be in in
in the other judges or the juries might
not be as strict as if they were in iraq
in the country in which the crime was
committed so you're handing over
these human rights abuses these
environmental abuses or this fraud over
to a system of government
well particularly in iraq which is where
is now working uh because you know if
you're a judge and you uh act in against
the interest of the private contractor
private contractor might come and shoot
you now that that hasn't happened in the
united states but um
it is something you know that effective
there is no effective uh system and
you're dependent on a whole new body of
laws you can't get information from
these companies a lot of these companies
say well what i did there was
proprietary business information i don't
need to give this information to you
because if i give it to you you could
use that to um
as a way to win a contract there so a
lot of the information that uh
that a citizen could obtain from the
government is no longer obtainable from
a private contractor you can't get it on
the freemium information act so
the way you do this these lawsuits their
actual
ultimate end result
is very different from if the military
was doing it and i'm not necessarily in
favor of the military going and doing
human rights abuses either but i think
it's one step removed
i'll take another question back there
again
between the sector of iraq that's
controlled by the u.s or being
administered
uh mainly by the us versus uh britain
and other countries
well there is a difference i'm not sure
that it's necessarily because of of the
different so i mean the question was
really is there a difference between the
sectors in iraq that are governed by the
united states and sectors that are
governed by other countries well the two
biggest contingents there are britain
and and and the united states and an
interesting little factoid there were 30
countries involved in the coalition the
wilting which uh the coalition were
willing
i apologize for that
the the coalition the willing had 30
members eventually they added another
eight and so there was eventually 38 of
which it's now down to 19 many of those
countries have left because they're
getting shot at in spain the
government's again their people against
it and italy the people against it
well um
in the case of that there was in fact a
uh town and i forget the name of the
town uh in central iraq where um there
was uh and again i forget which country
this is an east european country was in
charge of the town
i think it was poland and what happened
was when they came under fire the entire
battalion fled and so
they were like we don't really want to
be in this war and so they just left and
so they had to bring somebody else in
in the sector which has which has the
most the biggest foreign contingent
which is which is southern iraq and
basra
there has been a great deal of
difference there's been a lot less
trouble in basra however having said
that
basra has actually governed is mostly a
shia
town that typically was more favorable
to the occupation and has actually had a
long-standing relationship with the
british going back you know 100 years or
some or something but there's been less
trouble there than in the american
government sectors such as the the
so-called sunni triangle around tikrit
and and and fallujah so there's a
difference whether it's attributable to
the american um uh forces i don't know i
personally witnessed an incident the day
saddam hussein was
was captured in southern iraq
where a man passing by um us we were
actually filming and he saw us filming
so he pulled the gun out and he shot
into the air
and so uh and maybe he did that for the
cameras i'm not really sure but what
happened was the british military pulled
right over grabbed him pulled him out of
the car took his gun away you know and
then miracle miracles actually let him
go now
in baghdad that would not have had been
what would not have happened uh the the
british are a lot more low-key in
dealing with these things they they they
tend to have a much better understanding
of urban war and and it may perhaps be
because their experience is in northern
ireland they understand how guru law is
they they're not as quick to uh to jump
up and and attack people and which is
why i think the americans have also
borne the brunt of the attack is they
have have not understood the nature of
you know people's anger and the british
have been more careful to deal with that
anger and to limit it in letting people
go when they understand the people
weren't actually trying to they're like
you shouldn't be shooting in a public
place but
we understand that you weren't trying to
kill somebody therefore we'll let you go
in terms of contracts
the bulk of the contracts the bulk of
the contracts have gone to u.s companies
the big ticket contracts 10 billion
dollars to haliburton 3 billion 2.8
billion dollars to bechtel the biggest
british contract is for 293 million
dollars it's the 10th the size of the
bechtel contract
not to say that they aren't other
contractors but typically these tend to
be subcontractors to american
contractors so for example there's a
company from sao paulo and uh one of
their workers was killed as a company
from china
they're companies from all over the
world but typically they're not really
the main contractors they work for the
american contractors and the reason for
that in order to get a u.s military
contract you need to pass a certain
classification test which is called
secret and then there's another level
which is top secret and and these are
actually acronyms it's it's a real
military acronym
i could go on about military acronyms
the military engineering um
uh contracts uh uh contractors who who
do what albanies do are called prime
brief and prime ribs the military loves
these acronyms it's really bizarre and
those are engineering squadrons they are
not making this up um
they do but they felt they're smaller
contracts so the british have given out
contracts uh there but they're much
smaller contracts
i'm actually not sure whether the
british use cost plus or not i i haven't
examined those contracts in detail
so um
other questions there's a question back
then how are we really teaching the
iraqis democracy and freedom
the question is how are we teaching
iraqis democracy well this company from
north carolina uh research triangle
institute uses a model that they had
used in other countries in el salvador
and and indonesia i think are the two
countries um it's what they call
selections not elections and it's
actually quite a
clever system except that it doesn't
work
their idea was you need to build up
civil society so when you take a place
which has not had an elected government
why don't you create a city council and
have those city councils um uh do public
services and that way you give people
you empower people in their uh in their
own um uh neighborhood and then they
might take political office so what they
did in uh in in southern city for
example or taji which is a town just
close to baghdad
is they invited people in
uh to bid for contracts and then they
invited them in to create city councils
and they said anybody wants to create a
city council come talk to us
so and they didn't they didn't uh
discriminate against people anybody
could come and of course the people who
came in to create the city council the
people who wanted to win the contracts
in the first in the second place so in
the first place they put their names
into box and they said we'd like to vote
for city council
and a hundred people showed up and they
said well who would like to volunteer to
be a member of city council so it was
the people who are willing to
collaborate with the united states so
out of a city of of a hundred thousand
people a hundred people showed up and
said
we are civic uh leaders and the
americans invited people in we would
like to elect a government so they
nominated people and they called the
system selection that election and then
those people they nominated people to go
to you know to the central government so
ultimately these were self-selected and
the us government you know checked to
make sure that these weren't people with
warrants out for arrest they weren't
about this they didn't discriminate on
people based on whether they were shia
or sunni or kurdish as far as they know
however they weren't really familiar
with the local politics and so in fact
people there
used the system to basically
win contracts and win city council seats
for themselves the whole thing kind of
backfired on them
principally because also they didn't
speak the language there's an iraqi
american a gentleman called
al-gharawi jabar
he's from southern iraq he
hated saddam hussein
fought against saddam hussein fled the
country went to phoenix arizona and
became ran the local refugee council
voted for george bush was in favor of
the war in iraq and then he got hired by
rti and he went back to iraq this is a
man who's a republican believes in
the u.s government once he got there he
realized the job he'd been had for he
was hired interesting enough to set up a
women's ngo
he was paid a salary of 80 000. the
budget he was given for the women's ngo
was 90 000
and then when the resistance shot one
person uh who was in the thing they shut
it down at the end of the day he said we
spend 90 of the money on ourselves
the people who are going and teaching
democracy that we go out have no
authority to hand power to the people
and they're not accepted by the people
when he wanted to travel and again
remember this guy's iraqi he speaks
arabic he knows
he was forced to travel with four
bodyguards from australia and he said i
can't go and talk to people uh about
these things because you know people are
afraid of my bodyguards you know you
can't really have a conversation
so when i asked
patrick gibbons a spokesperson for rti
in north carolina whether or not this
was true he said you have to understand
we spent 15 million dollars on local
contracts when i looked at their budget
it was 150 million dollars so
my friend al gore was in fact correct
ninety percent of the money went to the
local people who weren't aware of of the
local culture they went to the to the
rti contractors weren't aware of the
local culture and
wasted money many of them jabra told me
they even left their compound they
filled out forms they watched satellite
television and were afraid to venture
outside so much so and and and to to
actually jump to um a bigger picture uh
question of the whole reconstruction if
you go beyond democracy as of september
22nd 2004
the us government had spent 1.22 billion
dollars on actual
um
reconstruction of that 623 million
dollars has been spent in security so 50
of the money was spent in security it
wasn't actually spent on
building roads or schools
um so colossal waste of money another
question up here
so after the halliburtons and the
bechtels have left a second stage of
capitalism
that's being going to be infused is a
more consumer-based consumption so when
will the first mcdonald's and starbucks
be built in baghdad the the question is
when does the first mcdonald's or
starbucks be will be built in baghdad
well actually um
the uh privatization is something the
u.s government wanted iraq to engage in
and and they wanted consumer goods to
come in on one hand that has happened
actually in a huge way in another way it
hasn't um
in uh liberating the country they opened
the borders and enemies can come and go
and so in fact iraqis wealthy iraqis are
buying foreign goods in big numbers
if you wanted to buy a car under saddam
hussein you had to register it and you
had to you know if you registered it you
know you could be caught for you know
having you know money that you weren't
supposed to have under the americans
there were no taxes
and so the number of cars that are
flowing into iraq are 10 times what they
used to be before baghdad is one
giant um
parking lot
there's so many cars because there's a
lot of people who make money so in fact
private private sector sales
exist in iraq
everybody in iraq has a satellite dish
you can buy any foreign products if you
have the money of course and the
wealthier people are there so there
isn't a mcdonald's or there's there's no
pizza hut but you can buy pepsi you can
buy coca-cola you can buy any of these
products once upon a time
for some reason iraq mostly most iraqis
traditionally
drove
old chevys now you have new korean
companies selling cars their you know
daewoo and kia and that sort of thing
mcdonald's is not about to go there and
the reason is people are buying things
iraqis are buying things from kuwait and
jordan and bringing them in and they're
the ones that are making money local
iraqis
mcdonald's doesn't want to go there the
private sector foreign companies that
have gone there are companies of gander
that have gotten guarantees from amer
the american government most companies
are afraid of risking
their capital in a country like iraq so
even though iraq has tried to privatize
state companies no foreign investors
have actually invested because they're
worried that they're going to get killed
the only way they'll do it is if they're
guaranteed a profit if they're
guaranteed cost plus so i don't think
you're going to see the first
mcdonald's or starbucks very soon but
i would wager that you will see burger
kings and the reason you'll see burger
kings and this may seem a lot is burger
king has the contract to supply
uh food on us military bases so i was
recently in kosovo for example and the
u.s military base has a burger king on
it i was in a military base in in in
southern arizona and it had a burger
king on it i would guarantee that if
there isn't already a burger king in
iraq there will soon be one owned by the
company there is however starbucks in in
afghanistan although it is not run by
starbucks itself it is run by the local
soldiers who named it starbucks and
starbucks is aware that they haven't
shut it down they think it's great
advertising for them but that starbucks
is actually run by some
it's actually one by the soldiers
themselves it isn't run by starbucks so
um mcdonald's isn't coming there but
burger king is on its way
um
this is a question in the
[Music]
war effort in back is actually going to
the private sector as opposed to being
spent by the military
with military personnel okay the
question is what percentage of the money
being spent in iraq is actually uh going
to the private sector that's a number
that's very hard to to actually
uh determine and because there there are
many different ways the private sector
benefits from that so if we spend 100
billion dollars in iraq last year which
we did
some of that goes to buying weaponry and
weaponry is bought from companies like
lockheed martin and boeing and raytheon
so and that has always been true so a
lot of money that we spend on the
moultrie is given to weapons
manufacturers and i don't know what
percentages that is whether 20 or 50
but that hasn't changed
one way of judging how much money is
being spent there is the fact that
uh in the first gulf war in iraq the
number of personnel uh military
personnel that were on the ground one in
100 people was a private contract in the
second gulf war what we call the second
gulf war because of course in people in
iraq county iran iraq was the first gulf
war but in in what we call the second
gulf where one in 10 people on the
ground was a private sector employee
today in iraq one in four people is a
private sector employee and that's
because a lot of them are you know
security guards cooks etc now many of
these people in fact the bulk of these
people are people paid at a very low
level of 100
a month or
or or some such things so it doesn't add
up to a lot of dollars
we
our estimate of the 100 billion dollars
spent in 2004 eight billion went to
halliburton so we know eight percent was
spent right there and and then you could
add you know at least a billion for back
to l and and you can keep on adding
numbers and
i don't know it's twenty thirty forty
percent uh you can only guess
depending on how you define these
numbers
i'll take a contract from the gentleman
over here because he hasn't asked a
question
uh
we haven't talked
about the election the recent elections
and since we've been talking about
the outright criminal you know um
behaviors of the companies that have
been
hired or contracted
not to say of course that there's
nothing capable of that i think the war
in iraq is criminal to begin with and i
think there's some probability and i
think that you know we should soon
push first before even banking and suing
these companies
but really having said that as a prayer
as a preamble
we just have to have the election in
iraq
now
how is the election uh having an effect
given what you have said is there now
a an internal iraqi
you know mechanism to do exactly this
you know this regulation and
um
some mechanism to you know to serve
and you know criminalize these things
behaviors how is this you know happening
right now
so the question is twofold first uh the
speaker asked uh um
pointed out that uh the the
uh
the war in iraq uh was uh in his opinion
criminal and therefore
instead of just saying the companies
bush the the republican administration
should be sued and so the question
deriving from that is
can the iraqi people is there legitimate
iraqi government after the elections
that could bring such a lawsuit
now again the book iraq inc is
specifically about fraud and
mismanagement as opposed to the larger
questions of as to whether the war
should have been conducted or not
um
so i sort of prefer to stay on that
subject but however i think it is a good
question the question of elections and
what happened
is there legitimate authority that can
now decide whether or not this was a
legitimate war and in my opinion
or could take over control
so here's the thing is the the us
government wanted through rti to create
a system of um
[Music]
of indigenous governments so to speak uh
that would be different from two
particular sectors one is uh the
baathists and saddam hussein stooges
whom they didn't want to empower
and and also the fundamentalists uh who
they feared would bring in you know
al-qaeda and that sort of thing so they
were hoping for middle ground
and
the elections in fact are a little more
represented than one would imagine even
though they were they were boycotted by
the sunnis in fact they do represent the
the the the bulk of the people of iraq
many people did turn out to vote now you
have to understand democracy is not
simply about an election it is much more
than that
uh had there been a legitimate election
conducted by the united nations would
the shia have
been uh elected in great great numbers
of course the shia sixty percent of the
population so there's a good chance the
people that are in office today would in
fact be the people in office um
had there been an election that was to
everybody's liking um
uh having said that there's so many uh
uh disputes between you know the the
people that have been elected they
haven't been able to form a government
in fact things are still in this way the
the kurds and the and and the shia the
united iraqi lands that controls you
know the bulk of the votes have yet to
be able to actually formulate a uh um a
a central government and that sort of
thing so as of yet and and we're
speaking you know late march early
of 2005 there isn't in fact a authority
that would be able to take control
could that happen in the future possibly
um
right now it simply doesn't exist
because of chaos because of mismanaging
because the elections were not perfect
um
yeah so i i don't know if i could um
if that fully answers the question but
um
i think there's a degree and in fact the
government that has been elected is not
the government the u.s wanted in fact
the u.s government backed somebody else
ayad dalawi and in fact he was a distant
third in the election he's trying to
negotiate a place uh in in in the
current government
whether or not this means that um
[Music]
uh
the the the replacement government will
do american bidding i don't know
it's of course in the interest of
anybody who governs iraq to sell all to
the u.s government so i imagine that we
won't see a situation where
they decide they're not going to sell to
the u.s government they won't work with
hal but in fact anybody who's willing
for anywhere in the world needs you know
the some of the main technologies for
the drilling of oil were invented by hal
button so
indeed
a legitimate authority in iraq would
probably do business with albertan and
and might not sue them so it's kind of a
complex equation maybe we'll take uh
two more questions and
um and call it quits
any other questions um
out there over there
have i had my life threatened i have not
had my life threatened uh uh in any way
um however the work that i do is is
clearly dangerous um the hotel i was in
uh the al fanara hotel in baghdad was in
fact the hotel that nicholas berg stayed
in who
gained some notoriety when his head was
cut off he actually stayed three rooms
down from me at the same time he and i
both traveled the same way to baghdad
and i forget the exact dates now it
roughly april 6th of last year i arrived
in baghdad coming through mosul and
kirkuk he arrived the following day um
we we we ate in the same breakfast room
his the last
uh
time he was seen you know when he met
with andrew who was a neighbor of mine
he
um
left you know on april 9th he was only
there for three days i was there for
much longer and he was kidnapped and
killed
he and i and anybody working there faces
those same threats um
i as somebody who is south asian
probably faced less of a threat than
somebody who is obviously a white
american however indians and nepalis
have been targeted and and
kidnapped and in fact nepalis have been
killed there i have never been
threatened directly
i have been
been subject to some very upset
emails uh who said that you know you
know they wish that i would die but you
know you get that all the time i don't
consider that a death threat i have been
threatened by the u.s military and
banned from bases uh right here in the
united states from uh work that i've
done relating to iraq
but nobody has uh uh directly uh
threatened me but when you work in
countries like that you're always
running a risk i mean you're running a
risk you know in in the streets of
oakland nearing this risk in the streets
of new york
people are heavily armed people are
jittery um
and and they're uh you know
ready to shoot in a moment's notice when
i
went to
the u.s base in kirkuk
i had
permission to visit
and i walked up and unlike a lot of
people who traveled in big white
fast chevy's they get shot up i prefer
to travel in local uh
taxis and and cars and i did that
so the us the the soldiers immediately
caught their guns and they were like
stop right there and they were like you
know put your hands in the air
drop everything you have and you know
walk to us you know and they were like
what are you doing here and i'm like i
have an appointment and in fact the the
person who invited me on the base from
the u.s military was sort of hiding
behind not really want to get involved
in this because i had to walk this sort
of gauntlet of 100 meters where had i
like you know the italians uh
journalists you know made the wrong wood
i could have gotten shot
despite the fact i had legitimate
business on that base so
you
this happens every day all the time when
you're there and
i've been there several times i'm going
back again and i'm sure that that will
be
something that i will face but that's
part of my job
so maybe one more question up here
given how
profitable the whole business of
war and
occupation and peacekeeping is do you
see any
light at the end of the tunnel
this is i'm a journalist the question is
do i see any light at the end of the
tunnel but given how profitable war is
do i see um uh this you know coming to
an end and i assume the assumptions will
we see more peaceful you know future or
some such thing
i'm a little skeptical i i personally
don't think that the bush administration
went to war to make a profit as a result
of it a lot of people have made a profit
and of course the the
the end result of not simply going to
war and turning loose 19 year olds in in
such a uh in in such a charged
atmosphere uh both soldiers and
contractors when they come back to this
country
as you had with vietnam vets etc people
who are psychologically traumatized and
in fact that has happened in the united
states people have come back from the
war and then opened fire and on and
killed people so i think
by perpetuating a system of war in a
country where asking uh not only where
in fact traumatizing soldiers and then
we have in fact created a whole industry
there are hundreds of companies that
have been created to serve you know the
war on terrorism those companies need
business they're going to want to seek
business from elsewhere whether or not
they seek it from
the u.s government or by creating
another war they're going to seek it
from companies that may have less than
savory intentions whether it's whether
it's drilling for oil on a land where
people don't want them to be present and
and then this has happened in the past
they hire private security companies to
work there so even if we never go to war
again i think these people will want uh
business they've tasted the profit
they've they understand there's a
business out there um
i think we've you know we've opened
pandora's box and and it's going to be
very hard to shut it
maybe one more question there
actually went to war there was exactly
an atmosphere like
some recession creeping in and a lot of
people were
thinking that you know we can get up the
recession and actually the war in some
level was sold exactly as one was called
the economic problem the united states
i got that something from a brother of
mine who was with the marines with
marines and he was really hoping that
after the war actually could save the
economy
so was bush actually
in a way responsible in sending exactly
the message that exactly this is
a war where everybody could make
business and all of this halliburton
thing
are just a part of the whole thing so
the question is was um uh did we go to
war so that we could get out of a
recession and and revive the us economy
i don't get the technical detail of it
and i don't know that bush is really
aware of of this but
the modern system of economic accounting
gdp was actually created uh in the
second world war and this gets into a
lot of complex economic theory and uh
that
gdp is actually designed to promote war
and it was actually that the system was
created to legitimize the second world
war and this is you can look at look it
up in economic textbooks it's not a
conspiracy um the the the the um
numbers and the numbers have shifted and
changed over the years and what's
interesting is if you look at any war
economy the economy booms during a war
this is you can look during the second
world war you can look during the
vietnam war you can look during the
korean war you can look during the
war in iraq and in the cold war there's
the peak because gdp measures production
industrial production and industrial
production in fact often counts very
much military um expenditure and and uh
so
did bush plan that to get us out of the
recession uh i don't know i don't know
that he understands economics that well
but uh um
uh the the the truth of the matter is
that um
the the country was going into recession
there's not a lot of money out there i
think in many ways the war was in was
was done in order to to distract the
american people from the fact that a
recession was around the corner was
already happening and so
by distract you know people are very
patriotic and and people want to stand
behind the president i think popularity
ratings went up because bush was
involved in saving the country from
terrorism
that it so happened to benefit his vice
president you know um a great deal
you know was by dubai
[Music]
but
perhaps the economy and i haven't looked
at numbers for the war in iraq perhaps
the economy has picked up because we're
spending more money uh it's it's not a
sustainable
uh economy however it is probably
boosting at least some economic
indicators
and of course
you know you have to question the fact
that out of this
war people like dick cheney the vice
president united states you know is
making as much money from halliburton as
he makes from haliburton
from from the u.s government we pay him
198 000
a year as vice president that's his
salary his
uh
deferred income from halliburton which
was agreed on before the war
is 168 thousand dollars a year now you
have to question whether or not if a man
like that who okayed the contract and
and we have adam zachary time magazine
has actually uh produced has found the
memos which indicate you know sign it
it's benefited these companies and so
the companies benefit out from from it
ultimately um
and
you know they they did they plan the war
i don't think so i'm not a conspiracy
theorist did we go to warfare those are
issues they don't really address in the
book
i'm really concerned with how we're
spending our money if we're actually
bringing liberation to the iraqi people
in fact if we're not putting ourselves
in a more dangerous predicament because
in fact we're going to end up getting
shot at because we're trying to profit
out of something that we have no idea
how to manage we have companies that are
inexperienced
secretive
and unaccountable and really i think
the point that iraq inc is trying to
make is that we need
transparency accountability and of
course we need legitimate political
decisions um but from the point of view
of some let's say let's say it was a
good idea to go to war it was a good
idea to occupy the country it was a good
idea to have companies run it we've
still failed at that and that's with
iraq the message of iraq is we have
completely failed in our endeavor to use
the private sector to run a country
could it ever happen
maybe but if this is the case study it's
a complete failure
i'll take one more question over there
this information that you have given us
is amazing
uh
people
[Music]
can they on can we only get the
information from your book or is it
publicized
all this information you have given us
okay the question the question is uh how
can you get information about this is it
just through buying the book and of
course the the book iraq inc which is
published by seven stories um is
available on amazon and and independent
bookstores encourage people to go to
independent bookstores but um i actually
run a website as mulu mentioned earlier
called corp watch
we are an investigative journalism
website and we uh
produce articles and we continue to
update this so every two weeks we
published an article investigating the
mole free and so a lot of the stuff in
haliburton is now nine months old we
have published new articles in halibut
and how they've
wasted taxpayer money
we will publish stories not simply about
fraud but from the truck drivers and the
and the workers themselves in iraq and
whose stories we're telling recently
there was an article on the
privatization of intelligence uh that's
happening in fort huachuca in southern
arizona how private companies have been
hired to train the interrogators that
have been sent to iraq
some not just the military even 50 of
our intelligence budgets being handed
over to private companies so those
articles and more we publish every other
week on the website which is
corpwatch.org
c-o-r-p-w-a-t-c-h dot org and there's an
ancillary website which is called
warprofiteers.com
and so you can get more information
there people who don't
look at the website about those things i
mean like
me i read the newspaper i listened to
the news on tv but nothing i've never
heard any information about this until i
listen to it well i would probably
encourage you know your local newspaper
and radio station to cover these stories
and some of them do but for a lot of
people this is sort of mind numbing i
mean i i meet regularly with people in
the new york times the washington post
who use this material in their books and
it's hard there's seven thousand
contracts out there in iraq in iraq
alone you know it's very hard for
journalists
journalists in iraq uh you know cannot
leave their compounds very hard to get
this information and so it's hard to
report in something you have no
information on so you know maybe because
i'm a journalist i feel like i feel like
i need to defend my profession but um
there are newspapers that report on it
um and and some of them are less
accessible actually one of the
newspapers that were put a lot in on the
fraud in in with halliburton is the wall
street journal but in fact most people
don't read it business people read that
so
tends to be the more
uh um
uh uh uh the bigger newspapers that
cover that that have bigger that have
more personnel but it is hard to get
that information so
i apologize for my profession
so a lot of people are um
are
not as lucky as we are for getting all
this information
[Music]
well thank you so much and uh if there
are no more questions maybe we'll
i'll be available to sign books in the
back if people are interested in buying
books
but thank you so much for coming out
[Applause]
protop chatterjee is program director
and managing editor of corp watch an
organization established to counter
corporate-led globalization iraq
incorporated is published by seven
stories press visit sevenstories.com for
more information
[Music]
coming up a discussion on first
amendment rights for government
whistleblowers
then a discussion with two republican
congressmen on the future of their party
followed by remarks from the u.s
ambassador to canada
[Music]
a discussion now about the first
amendment rights of government
whistleblowers we'll hear from a former
procurement officer at the army corps of
engineers who leaked information on
no-bid contracts awarded to halliburton
the close-up foundation hosts the
hour-long event
hello and welcome to the museum in
arlington virginia for this week's
close-up at the museum discussion of
whistleblowing hi i'm john moleski of
the close-up foundation in a moment
you'll hear from college students who
join us from various points around the
country they're here under the auspices
of the washington center and they're
taking part in internships around the
city and you'll meet some of them hear
what they're doing in just a moment
first i'd like to introduce you to our
panel joining us is stephen cohn stephen
is chairman of the board for the
national whistleblower center and the
author of four books on the subject
including the first legal treatise ever
written on whistleblower law
here's the book whistleblower law guide
to legal protection for corporate
employees
co-authored this with some people one of
them another of our guests but also
joining us is bonatin greenhouse buddy
greenhouse is a former chief civilian
contracting officer for the united
states army corps of engineers
she objected to no bid contracts for
reconstruction in iraq that were awarded
to a halliburton subsidiary she was
demoted from her post and her bosses say
for substandard job performance her
supporters say for retaliation in
response to her objections over the
contracts
also with us as i mentioned co-author of
the book michael cohen michael is
brother to stephen and his general
counsel at the national whistleblower
law center he is representing ms
greenhouse he is her attorney
good morning and welcome to the
discussion good morning good morning let
me start stephen with you with just some
some definition talk to us about the
term whistleblower and what is the
specific definition in this context well
a whistleblower is someone who exposes
waste fraud corruption environmental
violations some form of wrongdoing
and suffers retaliation
nobody likes the messenger no one likes
to hear the bad news and and throughout
history whistleblowers have been subject
to retaliation the whistleblower center
exists to provide support for the
whistleblower be they democratic
republican does it matter who they blow
the whistle on or what it's a
non-partisan organization that supports
whistleblowers you can learn more about
it at
whistleblowers with an s.org that's our
web page and it lists the clients and
the cases and the services we have is
there i i don't want to oversimplify
this but is there a cultural barrier to
whistleblowing and that everybody is
told by their parents not to be a snitch
not to tell on the other kid all that
type of thing and you grow up with that
as seen as some sort of dishonorable
activity
there's no doubt many of our clients say
i'm not a whistleblower they hate the
term they hate the connotations and they
will go down for their whole life saying
they're not a whistleblower but i think
one of the most important things to get
over that stigma
when time magazine put three
whistleblowers on the cover when the
american people learned that
whistleblowers could protect billions of
dollars in their investment
whistleblowers could expose faults in
the war on terror that protect everybody
whistleblowers could save
billions and have saved billions and
billions in taxpayer dollars for
fraudulent contracting
then i think the the connotation changes
and part of what we want to do is to
make it positive i mean when someone has
the courage
to really live the first amendment why
was the first amendment even passed
when you go down you look at history it
was passed primarily to support
whistleblowers they didn't call him that
but it was passed because
people understood
that someone in a position to know of
wrongdoing needs protection when they
step forward and help everybody else i
think there's also a cultural aspect in
our society where we have pushed moral
and ethical values and come from a
country where we where we have civic
education in school where we stood up
against what we called a tyrant back
then and people stood up and said
wrote on the declaration of independence
there is the first act of whistleblowing
in the country and that has
resonates and so when whistleblowers
come in when they say i'm not a
whistleblower they're not identifying
themselves as a whistleblower they're
really identifying themselves as a
patriot and that's what we really see
coming into our office are real our
patriots
who have raised serious concerns and are
now
uh in the middle of a battle with very
little support and and being shot out
from all directions how did you get
involved in this in this
aspect of the loss certainly you didn't
go after the big corporate dollars no
when i graduated uh college i decided
that i wanted to actually do a study
which was what would our society allow
you to do without
ending up dead or in jail or something
another and i
looked around and said i'll become a
lawyer and then i will take on the most
powerful institutions i can figure out
how to take on without a profit motive
involved and let's see what type of
change our society will allow me to
accomplish or
will i end up dead in the gutter or
disbarred or something and so it was
i ended up in whistleblower protection
because that's where people had the most
uh dynamic information to give forward
and you could really do the most for
somebody and that's where we ended up in
law i did not end up this barter in the
in the gutter but did have a death
threat every once in a while but who led
the way steven who was the original
rebel in the family here well it's funny
because i was the first one to get
involved in whistleblower but mike
landed me the job he knew somebody made
a couple of phone calls but it's the
same thing i mean for me it was public
interest law using the law to serve the
public interest that's what i wanted to
do when i went to law school that's what
i wanted to do when i went to college
and whistle blowing is just an amazing
area because you get to work with people
like bunny
everyone says a lawyer you know you're
duty-bound to represent your client be
they a murderer be they a perjurer a
polluter
but you the lawyer pick your clients
that's your ethical decision
and to have people like bunny as your
client is the greatest honor because
then you can use your skills and your
intellectual power and your education to
help people like her that's the choice
and that's what really it's the
difference i think back to some of my
clients who who did incredible things at
the epa or the fbi or or in corporate
america and i say god these people are
heroes and i got to be part of that
process i mean it's just you know that's
the reward bunny at what stage in this
story did you
did the term whistleblower occur to you
is that what you might be becoming
well i didn't like the term either you
know as whistleblower
but remember one thing i am first bonnie
greenhouse and i am a civil servant
a civil servant who came into government
taking an oath of office
of saying that with procurement
particularly
i had to ensure
you know that the procurement process
was at the highest levels of integrity
was at its fairest
and that had preferential treatment
toward none
so for eight years at the u.s army corps
of engineers i have been doing just that
job
you know regardless of what the
consequences making sure that my
leadership knew exactly what were the
risks
and what were the circumstances that we
were getting into and what things were
going against
uh compliance to the law
and making sure those things were ready
your job was direct response to those
criticisms over multi hundred dollar
toilet seat so that way yes absolutely
and i think that's when the first of uh
contracting and acquisition reform
started
uh and we brought about the defense
acquisition workforce improvement act
you know which started changing things
and professionalizing that contracting
workforce
so as i said i didn't like
whistleblowing because i was simply
doing my job what in in doing your job
what was it specifically that you
objected to in this in this circumstance
well at the beginning of the iraq war uh
we were into
the the culture is that whenever we're
in a contingency or in an emergency
there needs to be things that are done
quickly and that they
must be done by sole source i'm saying
that is not necessarily true
because we government are in charge you
know of the rules
and we set the rules we set all the
rules of engagement that we do we can
have a competition within ours we can
have a competition within days it
doesn't have to take the 30 days or the
45 days that is usual practice
but we are in charge you know of that i
objected to
first of all i saw some things that were
conflicts of interest as to the reasons
why we were going sole source you know
with the halliburton company
i saw that
if we were going out with a contract
that was supposed to be a bridge
to get the war started
it should not have been for five years
it should not have been for
a set two base year two years base and
three year options
when we were sitting back in washington
and it's simply by the stroke of a pen
we could have extended that contract if
things were the insurgents were as
terrible as they they may have expected
them to be
and so i objected to that i objected to
a five-year contract when it came to me
to sign
the sole source justification for that
and who initially did you take your
objection to uh initially of course to
my uh
um the management at the core of
engineers uh to the head of the
contracting activity uh at that time was
general flowers i told him why i wrote
the reservation that i did
because i had to protect the integrity
of that process and what was the
response that you received from your
supervisors
at first i thought that he understood
but obviously now in the um process of
being demoted he didn't understand so
how did how did it go public how did
this become an issue that went beyond
the other well i was working uh any
civil servant is first going to work in
your
chain of command to try to get uh issues
resolved and i did that if you would see
my
uh
the long list of emails you know going
back and forth trying to get everybody
to understand what i as the principal
assistant responsible for contracting
you know had to ensure of
i did that
and then not until
uh just before the election you know did
i get a letter uh from uh general strzok
at the time who is now the uh the chief
of engineers uh in the commander of the
engineers uh telling me that i was going
to be reduced uh in grade and removed
from my position now you take it i i
just briefed him on october 1st of that
year just before the election
he gave me a letter dated october 5th
so he had not been in command
from the time i got the letter or taken
my briefing as my entrance to him to
understand the problems and the
challenges that i needed him to work
with me
uh and and only those number of days did
he give me a letter to say i was going
to be removed but general strzok was
also the architect of the uh iraq
contracting activity before absolutely
and bunny had already
told the secretary of defense's office
about the problems it was known
throughout the army what was going on
and had you ever received any negative
feedback in in job evaluations prior to
this demotion i had
my initial job
evaluations were
were level ones that's the top
uh i've had one level two
what they did was they i had when
general flowers came in i got a level
one the next year uh i had a level uh
level one when the commander left and
retired and they changed it to a level
two and so the next year i went from a
level two to a level five and a level
five is the lowest
as if i sat there and i did nothing and
if you were to look at the track record
of all that i did and all they
complained about because i was writing
on documents you know in order to
uh make sure that our people in the
field uh were
educated around what it meant by
fairness integrity compliance and all
those things that are that we must lift
up in government and did you approach
the whistleblower center or or did you
were you approached by them well i was
trying to work in-house uh michael cohen
was my lawyer you know under the eeo
process the equal
employment opportunity process and when
they when the corps of engineers saw
that they were losing the aeo process
they then just decided well
we can just do it
and and we'll just do it and give her a
letter and say that she's removed
because within the ses of the senior
executive service there is a little
loophole that they have there
saying that if a senior executive gets
to
performance rating of failing
within too unsuccessful i shouldn't say
failing unsuccessful in uh three years
that they can
be removed to have adverse things done
to them
they are the people who wanted
to make sure that bunny greenhouse was
removed they had
felt that i had more power than the
chief of engineers in the business of
contracting and it wasn't about power
it was about doing the right things for
the right reason making sure that the
level the playing field was level for
all of the groups that wanted to
participate in our process whether it
was small businesses or women-owned
businesses or whatever the case and
large businesses mike if you talk about
questions
the whistleblower center doesn't reach
out to whistleblowers they essentially
come to our office or seek assistance
and we do have a nationwide attorney
referral service we're only able to help
a small
handful of people who come in but you
wait for them to ask generally yeah and
they're coming in about almost about a
thousand requests per year and we have
lawyers and just in almost every of
those thousands how many can you handle
we can maybe do 10 or 15 at the most we
have lawyers
uh and members in in every state of the
country so the vast majority will just
get referred out to a lawyer who's also
an expert in whistleblower law or has
some background and experience in it and
and we'll try to pick up the cases that
we can it's a resource issue but but
bunny's case was just spectacular
because
you know she was in a position
to know and in fact
something else to keep in mind in terms
of how people first learned about it
they didn't like her writing on the
contracts and and writing protests
and the reason for that is another law
known as the freedom of information act
which is a critical public interest law
which we use all the time it allows
people to get it so groups out there
actually through freedom of information
act had obtained the contracting
documents and learned about bunny before
she even stepped forward
just how did you just wipe that stuff
out and claim national security
is it possible to do well they do
exemptions all the time but in that one
they did mike i want you before we go to
questions i need to comment on where the
litigation is now what are the where are
we in this uh right now we're still in
the eeo process we've been fighting it
out to say that
internally there should be
the ability for her to bring her
discrimination claims of race and sex uh
and whistleblower all in one proceeding
and go forward the army is refusing to
do that we're sort of had a stalemate
there
at some point we will probably move into
federal court
you know there's a
resource issue and
it's very time consuming costly to to do
type this type of litigation so we're
trying to get our ducks in a row we need
as much support as we can
uh public support uh
whistleblower cases are often won by the
public's coming forward and supporting
individuals more than anything else it's
that
you know it's that other arm of
government essentially which is the
media
and someone like bunny greenhouse who
has devoted her life to serving this
country you know deserves our support
and
she's getting it there are people who
are writing in all the time who really
appreciate what she's done
she's given up her career
just because she saw what was going was
going on was wrong and it's been a
lifelong struggle for her she when she
first got in she objected to the
bundling of contracts where they get all
this money stick it all together one big
contract so only a large contractor
could bid on it she made them take it
apart smaller contracts for smaller
businesses minority women-owned small
businesses and she took the power from
the commanders and said no we're going
to do it right according to the law and
there was a the extreme backlash against
bunny as a result of that ending up with
her removal and her objection to the
iraq contract which was at the pinnacle
of of the opposition and as a result of
that there was also another issue about
issuing waivers to halliburton so they
didn't have to account for their costs
either in fairness to the other side of
that let me just ask you what are the
what have they claimed that your client
did wrong i know there's the government
accounting office issued a report saying
the re that the contract was properly
awarded and then there were these as i
mentioned earlier in money that you
responded to these notions of job
performance what is the case that
they've made
the the gao never interviewed her and
none of her allegations were known when
they did their investigation so it's
that's sort of irrelevant uh the only
thing they claim that bunny greenhouse
did is she did her job too well yes and
she wouldn't listen to her management
when they said stop complaining and do
and and
when you hear in the field what they
want
you're interpreting the rules too
strictly
is that what they were saying to you
well they may have uh have thought that
but i always gave them the justification
as to why we had to do things and no one
would ever contest those justifications
yeah and i just want to say a couple
things one is they clearly objected
vigorously to her writing on the
contracts and the re and
the reason they did that from my point
of view was to prevent the public from
ever knowing
of the contract disputes if she did a
separate memo maybe they could have
classified it but by writing on the
contracts
and she may not even have intended it
but the army didn't like it because when
they produced the contracts the public
would learn of the objections the second
thing i want to say is and which is a
big problem for every whistleblower
anyone who has the courage to step
forward and say there's been wrongdoing
here
will get a backlash
their credibility will be attacked their
performance will be attacked nobody sits
back and says oh yeah
i did something illegal high five
it just is never going to happen when a
whistleblower steps forward in every
single case there is a backlash now
sometimes it's just the immediate
supervisor or the wrong doer and the
system catches it
and
the person keeps their job and the in
the corporation or the institution
protects you
but as in bunny's case and in many other
cases if who you're blowing the whistle
on is high up on the food chain
is in a senior position they're going to
use those resources and clobber you and
that's why the whistleblower center
exists
whistleblowers need a more even playing
field a civil servant can't afford the
lawyers
can't afford the costs
of fighting the pentagon or halliburton
it's just
the differential is so radical so that's
why what's one of the main reasons the
whistleblower center exists we've
established a defense fund for bunny at
whistleblowers with an s.org and try to
even that playing field so her voice can
be heard in her career can be defended
if it isn't
it has a chilling effect
i believe every procurement officer in
washington dc around the country be they
with the pentagon or in fema
at the at the
at all the money that's going to be
poured into new orleans or
anywhere they're looking at her case can
a procurement officer
follow the law to the t
stand up for what is right and survive
if she gets knocked down it will have
such a chilling effect it will cost the
taxpayers in my view tens if not
hundreds of billions of dollars in
long-term rip-offs because unless the
procurement officers have the backbone
to do their job
it's the the system will not work that's
why her case is not just the iraq
contracts not just the courage of one
individual but when we looked at this
case it's the integrity of the
contracting process and mark my word
they're all watching management is
watching federal contractors are
watching and the procurement officers
are watching there is so much at stake
in this case and procurement officers
are writing in to bunny
and
i think the hallmark as to
bunny's case is she raises allegations
before the election the presidential
last presidential election concerning uh
favoritism towards halliburton
essentially
with everything that's happened there
has been no investigation of any of her
allegations as we sit here to date
the the secretary of the army promising
investigation none has happened it's
been years why don't they want to do it
in a simple investigation if she was had
if she was not telling the truth or
there was not
so obvious there would have been a full
investigation and she would have been
shown to have had no meritorious claims
the fact that no one will has the
integrity in our current government to
do an investigation speaks volumes and i
think
some congressional committee owes the
american people a hearing with bunny
greenhouse so she can go over and
explain exactly what happened how this
iraq contract's rewarded and whether let
the american people judge for themselves
whether it was proper okay let's go to
your questions hi
hi my name is nura jabed i'm from akron
ohio and i attend tiffany university
my question for you today is should
whistleblowers be immune from
prosecution if they were involved in the
crime
just so you know they're not
they never will be if a whistleblower
steps forward
and the the institution that they blew
the whistle on can get some dirt on them
they're gonna clobber them hard now
sometimes uh what's known as a snitch or
an informant gets immunity to turn
state's evidence but that's really not
whistleblowing
whistleblowing is is someone who is not
part of the criminal network and cutting
a deal
a whistleblower is someone who sees the
wrong doing and steps forward
but i've never i just don't think it
will ever happen in reality that a
whistleblower will somehow get more
immunity than anyone else are you were
you thinking in terms of if they're
involved in the potential illegality
that they're exposing exactly that may
get some kind of immunity deal is that
right yeah and that again that's more in
the criminal process will be up to a u.s
attorney but it's that's really not
whistleblowing
thank you okay thank you hi hello my
name is brianna burke and i'm from
boston massachusetts i attend worcester
state college i'm curious we often hear
about the consequences whistleblowers
face after they have you know blown the
top off an issue and i was wondering is
there ever been a situation where maybe
in the end after things have settled
where whistleblower has been praised for
doing so
uh praise for doing so i i represented
someone at the federal reserve who was
responsible for alan greenspan uh
personal safety he exposed the fact that
it was completely uh he was totally
vulnerable they removed him from his
position uh we then did a major
presentation they realized everything he
said was true
they would not give him his job back
they they insisted that he leave but
they did give him a letter recogni
recognition and personally praised him
for actually probably
doing the right thing so that was one
situation um typically
a whistleblower who goes forward career
ends in the
environment they are in and that career
path um and if you're a lawyer you'll
never be you're never gonna get into a
big law firm or any other law firm again
if you're in procurement you're not
going to have any job related to
procurement and some can find some
similar
job paths and the higher up you are in
the management chain the more difficult
it is because you're subject to
greater background checks and now with
google and things of that nature you put
someone's name in if they have filed a
lawsuit it's going to pop right out and
it's much more difficult essentially
for whistleblowers to protect their
identity as being a whistleblower when
they're trying to transfer over so it's
it's a hard road now for whistleblowers
always has been i can tell you i have
one client who who succeeded
he was
being groomed to be the president of the
largest utility in the united states
blew the whistle on a nuclear power
plant issues he got removed the
department of labor wrote a decision
saying the only reason they removed him
was because he was a whistleblower the
only reason he ordered reinstated it
took 14 years to get his to get the
final reinstatement order
approved by the courts
in the meantime
high level executive was making minimum
wage on hands and needs as a file clerk
uh at another corporation where some
vice president keeps on seeing this guy
in the hallway who's dressed you know
like an executive say who is this guy oh
he's a he's a temp worker making minimum
wage and
today he worked his way up and is now i
believe a senior vice president of
another corporation of a fortune 100
corporation
but that was his personal skills and
people saw him and worked with him and i
saw what he could do he could never get
an entry level position in again and no
one would return his call so so that
tells you that you're not going to
really integrate very quickly this is a
guy who had every skill set you could
imagine i had every friend in
in in the universe
but when he was identified as a
whistleblower his career ended
bunny
no one can go into this type of endeavor
without considering the consequences and
uh you have a family so the family's
involved as well is the family
supportive of what you're doing
of course the family he hates to see
that i have to endure you know what i
have to endure and
they were encouraging me to do uh
otherwise to just let it go or whatever
but
remember this is not just about bunny
greenhouse
this is about the procurement process
that
congress is responsible for and that
congress has laid out the laws for
the kinds of things that i i did and
enforced were not laws that i made
you know they were ones that we were
supposed to adhere to
and so uh the only wrong doing and this
is why i just can't run away i can't
quit
because i've done nothing wrong i've
done the things that are in the highest
caliber of what it is that we're
supposed to be doing and doing those
things for the right reason so i have to
stay here you know for that because it's
all about the contracting officer
their independence it's all about the
checks and balances that must be in the
system
all of the poor performance that i may
be accused of is the poor performance of
not being controlled to do the wrong
thing are there members of congress who
have stepped forward to support you
yes they are they are i've
i've testified before congress on two
occasions
and they have done a press conference
with me to say that
as far as that federal law that says
that there will be preferential
treatment toward none that they were
there to back up the actions that i have
performed to try to to make sure that
the integrity of the process is
preserved now this was a democratic
committee with no oversight authority is
that correct
so the majority party has not chosen but
to me i was not looking at anything of
of any partisan nation nature i was
simply looking at the fact that this is
congress calling me to testify but i'm
just trying to make clear the authority
issue the partisan issue sure
and i just want to stress that point
whistle blowing
should never be a partisan issue
and
when the democrats see a whistleblower
they think they hurt the republicans or
the republicans see a whistleblower they
think may hurt the democrats well that
all can happen but ultimately it's up to
members of congress with integrity
to go beyond the party label and to say
we're into good government
integrity and honesty and supporting our
federal employees who are doing what we
the congress told them to do and that
does happen it has not happened yet with
bunny i hope some republicans stepped to
the mantle yeah but in other
whistleblower cases it has
and then there has been strong
bipartisan support that can often be the
the difference between winning or losing
a case if the if a sitting
administration thinks they're going to
get a pass
because they were able to politicize a
whistleblower
it's just going to be continuing
retaliation
i want to remind you that you're
watching close up at the newseum hi i'm
john moleski of the close-up foundation
this week we're talking about
whistleblowing and the first amendment
our guests are michael and stephen cohen
from the whistleblower center the
national whistleblower center also this
is bunny greenhouse a former procurement
officer for the army corps of engineers
who objected to bid contracts awarded to
a halliburton subsidiary we are speaking
with students from the washington center
they are here in washington dc from a
variety of universities and colleges
participating in internships i want to
let you know if you'd like more
information on close-up or the freedom
forum and museum you can visit our
websites at closeup.org or newseum.org
and right now we're going to return to
questions from our friends from the
washington center you are next sir go
ahead please hi my name is chase conrad
i'm from pasadena california and i
attend san diego state university um
your situation is on a more national
national scale it's a large but i'm sure
that there are smaller organizations and
businesses throughout the country that
deal with the same situation
i would assume fairly often
why do you think that the whistleblower
issues aren't better known to the public
do you believe that maybe the media is
scared of a political or corporate
backlash
that's basically
the
uh i and others can take a shot at this
as a very good question i think the term
whistleblower is is still a new term
you know almost every day we experience
people who've never heard of it even
people who contact the whistleblower
center are first learning about it
it's an old concept
of people standing up and exposing
wrongdoing
very old but the word whistleblower is
new and and i really appreciate you know
this forum and others where we can try
to get the word out but you're 100 right
and what's fascinating is you know how
many cases we've done where managers
didn't even know they couldn't fire a
whistleblower you sit him down a
deposition well they they went out to
that government agency and of course
i've fired them i've even been before
judges
who've told me to my face well
if
if if one of my if i knew an employee
went to the us attorney's office and
blew the whistle i'd fire him too
i mean that's what's out there let's
hope the culture can change what are the
limits of first amendment protections in
this regard and is there a difference
between the public and private sector
protections
yeah the the the private and public
sector have the one of the biggest
problems with whistleblowing is there's
no
whistleblower protection act one law
that protects all whistleblowers you
have about
40 federal laws
and every state has their own approach
and it makes it almost impossible to
figure out who's protected or not
unfortunately federal employees are
among the worst protected class of
whistleblowers corporate america did not
get whistleblower protection until
sarbanes-oxley in 2002.
truck drivers got whistleblower
protection in 1980 airline pilots didn't
get it until 2000. there's no
whistleblower protection in the
pharmaceutical industry no surprise
you're seeing all those problems with
the drug companies no federal law
protecting a drug whistleblower
no federal law protecting food safety
if someone sees contamination in food
blows the whistle no federal protection
so it's it's a mess out there bunny and
following up on the last question i how
do you feel about your press coverage do
you feel you've been treated fairly
uh i think there's been interest you
know lots of interest in my story and
have reporters gotten the story correct
from your perspective
much yes very much so in in the instance
but i i don't want uh
we often talk about how bad the world is
but then we have to remember that the
world is made of each of us
we can't let a term like whistleblower
uh override the fact that when we take
oaths of office when we become public
servants that we have responsibility and
accountability for the jobs that we are
supposed to do
and that should not be
sacrificed for anything regardless of
the consequences regardless of the fact
that people may not like you usually
it's not going to be that they don't
like me as a person but they may not
like the job that i have to do and i'm
not going to sacrifice that job i have
to first live with my self i came to
that job with values
and i have to look in the mirror every
day to determine if any of those values
are going to be compromised just to get
along
and it's not about just getting along if
you give me an oath of office if you
give me at the senior executive level
a job to do
my life depends upon it and i'm going to
give every fiber of my being to do that
job and i'm not going to stand with a
term like whistleblower a brand of that
and say that i am going to
uh
overlook my responsibility and
accountability because of that
i have to take the brand
okay hi go ahead please hi my name is
jamie sander and i'm from el paso texas
i go to school at texas christian
university in fort worth
and i was just wondering that as far as
i know um whistleblowers used to be just
protected under the first amendment and
i was wondering at if
you know now having the term
whistleblower and being protected under
the whistleblower act if that can
actually um hurt them by taking away
some of the first amendment rights
you think that it could work in the
opposite direction right
unfortunately for federal employees it
has that the law that congress did for
federal employees actually took away
some first amendment rights
however it is our position at the
whistleblower center is that the first
amendment trumps all laws
period the rights that our founding
fathers gave us after the american
revolution
are intact
i don't care about judicial decisions i
don't care about adverse rulings
in our cases
we
stare at that first amendment and follow
it similar to what bunny does when she
says this is the law
these are my what i'm supposed to do
we
demand adherence to the first amendment
as the bottom line
thanks hi
hi my name is andrea lobenko i'm from
dyer indiana i go to university of
illinois and my question is this from
where does most of the opposition for
whistleblowing in general and more
specifically the act and its pending
amendment in congress come from do you
see it more from the federal government
or from the private sector
it's pretty evenly divided
every people in power do not like
whistleblower protection and so
uh
the problem is
both parties come into power at various
times so neither one sees it in their
ultimate interest it's the
it's only when it comes on the american
uh
on the radar of the voters that things
are going to happen and when you get
some very principled members of congress
who push for legislation and there are
some out there and they should really be
applauded who are they could you name
names who are the the leaders well
senator grassley is probably uh
the biggest leader and he's a republican
so it's not uh
you gotta remove the labels but when the
legislation goes forward i can tell you
that the tendencies to gut it and weaken
it are coming typically from the
republican side more often than not
and the
private sector
definitely objects to any legislation
that's going to affect them and so you
end up with compromises like in most of
the federal whistleblower protection
legislation they give you a 30-day
statute of limitations which means you
have to figure out that you've been
discriminated against and got to find a
lawyer and figure out what's going on
and file your case within 30 days which
means most people lose their cases
before they even get started
and that was a compromise made to get
the majority support of both houses so i
think what you have to look at is if
members constituents
call up their congressmen
congresswomen and say hey this is
important issue this is
the root of american strength and power
and freedom
push it for me
if they start getting those calls the
laws will get passed
because
there is no member of congress who
really doesn't want to protect
whistleblowers and wouldn't like to and
i can't tell you how many back room
meetings i've been in where they said i
wish i could but x y and z i can't i'm
sorry
they want to they need help being able
to do it and you people who are sitting
out here are the ammunition needed to
get strong whistleblower protection yeah
the other side of the point of your
question of who who is in opposition who
supports you where do you get your money
well
unfortunately whistleblowing is not
on the
philathropic radar screen
or the public giving radar screen like
other causes
uh you know it's just not up there and
if you look at annual giving
for the whistleblower issue for every
single organization that might be
supporting whistleblowers out there it
is such a tiny fraction
of
many of the other issues it just has not
been out there again it's still a new
issue
what kind of operating budget do you
have to cover say 10 cases out of a
thousand inquiries in a year the
whistleblower center's operating budget
is extremely small it's in the it's in
the lower hundreds of thousands tiny the
whistleblower center's
main power is through the volunteer
attorneys
and staff that assistant which is in the
hundreds and hundreds and millions of
dollars where lawyers contribute their
time
on these cases or take referrals
and work with them
the philathrampa community just has not
is not there and i hope it changes but i
want to say something about
the opposition i just i'll just give you
a tragic example
i started with
actively being involved in
whistleblowing in 1984
and at that time the airline pilots
and the airlines stewardesses and
workers were pushing for whistleblower
protection in the airlines truck drivers
had gone if you drive a truck you're
protected if you blow the whistle you're
in an airplane you're not and for
16 years
they pushed for whistleblower protection
and did not get it
and then one plane crashes
and they realized that maybe some of the
mechanics and people had concerns they
didn't get whistleblower protection and
then a second plane crashes
and lo and behold it's inserted into law
and now we have airline employee
whistleblower protections that was the
two crash law
that's been the history
they've waited for example enron in the
collapse
how many investors lost how many
billions and billions of dollars when
wall street collapsed and everyone
realized my god there's no protection we
had a wall street whistleblower two
years before and it broke my heart
this guy had complained about churning
ripping off investors and who are these
investors you know kids education funds
pension funds retirement funds
and he pointed it all out and we
couldn't get his case to step one there
was nothing out there
enron collapses
billions of dollars lost and now we have
a good corporate whistleblower law but
that's a tragedy it should not have to
be that way
hi go ahead please hi my name is deanna
cole and i attend dillard university in
new orleans louisiana and my question is
how long does a whistleblowing case of
course like this one generally lasts and
how does a person like ms green house go
forward after the case
you may want to answer she's from your
state
yeah i'm from louisiana
yes and um uh
well i expect
i expect that the right things are going
to be done
uh
this was brought this it was unfortunate
that my case was brought out the corps
did the things that they had to do and
mr cohen had to write a letter outlining
all of the uh improprieties had gone on
at the time of the election you know
which put it on a different
um front you know than what it should
have been but the fact remains is that
this is all about
procurement this is all about
competition and effective competition
this is all about things being done for
the right reason it probably is going to
go on too long than what i expect it to
do but i would i would love it to be
that someone even though this is not
about this administration this is about
procurement and contracting and that it
be done in the best and i would expect
that
a lot in the administration someone
would say
what bunny greenhouse is saying
regardless of the fact that it may be
involving country companies that may be
uh said to be attached to uh anyone in
the administration or whatever
no we want to stop this train here and
we want to do the right thing do the the
for the right reasons here
you had like bunny greenhouse who uh is
a civilian was the civilian equivalent
of a brigadier general yes uh she raises
very serious concerns and then files but
no one does anything she files a formal
complaint it's almost like two years
before her whistle blowing became known
claiming that they were interfering with
her her job
a formal complaint filed under title vii
the
army didn't even set it for an
investigation for two years they just
let it
sit there and so they could churn and
and figure out how they're going to come
up with bad performance evaluations in
the meantime so that's two years down
the road already it'll take us probably
to get the resources together another
year or two to get into federal court
and then from there
with the appeal process could be a few
more years
so
that's it's a long haul and
whistleblower and i'll tell you that
bunny greenhouse is
got the integrity and the courage of of
very few people i've ever come across in
my
uh experience of representing
whistleblowers which has been 20 years
she has
uh
i've never seen someone so unflappable
and i know she's there for the long haul
and i just only wish there was someone
in government would say hey there's
something wrong here pick up the phone
give me a call figure out how to fix a
problem never happened
will
you're describing a process that could
easily take a decade
what is the next step though what
happens what is the very next step
uh you exhaust your administrative
remedies um and from there go into
federal court or they or the merit
systems protection board or the two
remedies that are offered next i just
want to mention one thing about the
timing
we have been able to resolve cases
within a year or less
often if the wrong doer is a little
smart and realizes
that a fix as painful as it may be in
the short term
has many long-term benefits you say a
fix you mean a settlement yeah
yeah but the settlement and resolving
the issues in other words looking at it
taking the bumps in the road and moving
on right some do that others don't but
just so you know that case that mike
mentioned before it's gone on for 14
years
it's also and one thing that we want to
be able to do in the whistleblower
center is if they want to drag it out
we'll drag it out don't think that your
superior resources will mean we're going
to put up a white flag
we want to be in a position
to fight as long and as hard as they do
when the headlines are over
when
no one remembers who this person was we
want to be there to fight it out
because
the next time they'll know
well i think that this is totally
intolerable you know to continue on
because remember i do not make the laws
for procurement
the commands don't make the laws
congress makes those laws
what is it that the government wants
you know do they want us to abide by the
laws do they choose procurement
executives and principal assistants
responsible for contracting to make sure
that effective competition goes on
that there is fairness that there's a
level playing field that there is
integrity of the process
now that is not anything to look at any
values in bunny greenhouse
that is something to look at what were
the values that were set in our nation
as to the checks and balances that was
going to go on in this process
i am just there i took it seriously when
i took my oath of office
and i meant to make sure
that regardless you know of the
microscope that i was under i was going
to do the right things for the right
reasons and i was going to prepare a
contracting and acquisition workforce
that was second to none in government
where industry could not sit across and
say those dumb government people
that's why the writing on the documents
that's why because what we do in the
documents we form is only by word
processing i tell them to give me a
clean document back
after they have seen what i have written
specifically that they've got a change
in order to avoid protests in order to
ensure the fairness of all of the people
that are involved in our process
i have to look through all those lenses
and i make sure that my people grow to
that point and say like one has told me
uh now that this trouble trouble has
started that we ask ourselves the
question what is it that bunny would do
when it comes to a crossroads of making
the right decision i want our leadership
i want our congress to hear that
is that what that is what our
contracting people out there are looking
for is the strength of leadership and
it's all about leadership
and i believe leadership is about making
a difference
hi go ahead please um my name is katie
stahl i'm from gettysburg pennsylvania
and i attend shippensburg university and
my question is slightly similar to the
last question but
basically bunny with your case what
exactly are you hoping to accomplish
whether it takes 14 years or a year
what exactly is it that you want to okay
i'm glad you asked me that
because it's not about benny greenhouse
it's all about when i came to the corps
of engineers in 97 i took all of my
contracting officers to dallas and they
stood up and they told me
i said what is the culture what is the
health of this organization in
contracting
bunny
we feel like we are in the kitchen
cleaning up after all the messes made
but we are never invited to the table
that was wrenching to my heart
to get them the courage to be able to
stand up because contracting officers
are the only one to obligate the
government
i had something like 23 billion dollars
responsible for throughout the corps to
make sure that was spent properly
those people had to understand that they
didn't need to be invited to the table
they needed to be at the table since all
of the
work in the corps of engineers is not
done organically it's done by contract
and you've got to have strong people who
have the fortitude
not to have
superficiality of teamwork but to get in
and lay the issues on the table early so
that at the very end of the day we are
going to have success in every action
acquisition that we uh
release and that also that we're not
going to spend any more money we're
going to have the highest quality
product and it's going to be on time and
those war fighters that are in
afghanistan in in iraq are going to be
taken care of in the best sense that we
can that is what that is what we wake up
for every morning that is what we feel
like we add to that war zone out there
that we are somewhat removed from but we
are out there on that battlefield too
making sure that those soldiers when
they look up
they are getting the type of service
that they need in order to be
able-bodied and for us to go out and
engage and and to win
buddy i have a question for you yes of
the
the chiefs of contracting that you have
supported and put into
their position since you've been there
can you tell me what's happened to the
ones who followed your message the
strongest well i tell you they are gone
we have uh two chiefs of contracting now
uh one in louisville district and one in
kansas city district have been fired
you know for for reasons that are
certainly were never brought to me as
the procurement executive there you know
to try to find out if there was any kind
of relevance you know to those but they
were removed
and that's the chill that has been put
over the whole contracting force that if
you don't get under the control and you
don't do it the way that some people who
are not even accountable to the process
then you're going to lose your job and
you're gone
hi go ahead please
hello my name is nicole mcneill and i'm
from virginia beach virginia and i
attend xavier university of louisiana
i've heard a lot about your courage and
i applaud you for your courage um have
you met people
um that might have said okay
i might have had problems at or with
their institution or wherever they work
but they're afraid to step up or
because they know that there will be
backlash and consequences or if people
come to you saying you know what do i do
how do i start absolutely that that's
what makes me continue and and continue
on each day are the letters that i get
from industry as well as from
other government agencies saying thanks
thanks for giving me the courage i see
things going on every day and i've been
fearing you know these black backlashes
every last one of us in our jobs we have
a purpose in our lives are we going to
let fear override that purpose
and not allow us as we walk through this
world do what it is that we're supposed
to do and then walk out of this world
and know that we've done it well
fear cannot be what is that and that's
what i stand as a symbol to them
that she is not fearful she's going on
in doing what she has to do for the
right reasons and that's the bottom line
hi go ahead please hi bethany william
from herndon pennsylvania and i attend
clark university bunny how has your view
of the government changed being such a
strong civil servant do you feel like
you have more doubt in the government as
a whole
well i i feel that the the government is
doing a little bit of failing me right
now you know because it's not about
bunny's rules
you know it's about their rules
and either you change the rules or you
decide that
there is going to be a standard or there
is going to be a benchmark and if i
uh personify that standard
then let's not stand in the background
and be fearful for whatever reason and
not speak up for what is right because
it's more than money that is in the
balance it's all of those folks out
there that you're saying that a
contracting officer are the only ones
who have the uh responsibility
uh and the obligation to obligate the
government as far as the monies are
concerned do you do you mean that
or do you not uh can it be like general
griffin who was my raider
who was not in the contracting process
at all not in the lineage of authority
but he can tell me don't write on
contracts don't do this and don't do
that and then he has no he cannot be
accountable he can't go to jail for this
you know but still i'm gonna have to try
to advise him educate him and let him
know but he then has the pen on the
other hand to say well if you don't do
what i say do you know then i can give
you performance and every time i would
ask him why are you doing this to me
i'm just following a process
and the process was
given scs to performance ratings that
are
below successful and you can do what you
want to do so he uses the phrase now i
got it done
and everybody around the court let's get
it done get it get it done and they're
getting it done with those contracting
officers out there who are not abiding
and whatever and
that should not be anything to stop
you from doing the right thing for the
right reason time for one more quick
question hi hi my name is rudy berry i'm
from cleveland ohio i go to st
bonaventure university um you talked
about the damage that could be done in
one's career with the whistleblower
label put on you what reparations are
you two gentlemen specifically looking
for in this case for her to move on with
her career successfully well well bonnie
has there's limited uh
options for for whistleblowers
should be able to get her job back
and that's what she and her enter cost
of litigation and and that's essentially
what the law offers
uh
and that's certainly very modest it's
not whistleblowing law is not a law
where you make money you see someone you
make make a big fortune it's just
returning you to back to where you
should be
but i want to say just one exception
to that and and everyone here or out in
the audience should know
is there's one
really good whistleblower law out there
it was written by abe lincoln
and passed by his congress during the
civil war
when they saw procurement fraud that was
killing union soldiers
during that war and it's called the
false claims act
and senator charles grassley mentioned
before from iowa strengthened that law
in 1986 and it's the only whistleblower
law that rewards whistleblowers it gives
you the right when you're ripping off
the federal government and you work for
a contractor you see the government
getting ripped off to get a percentage
of what the government is saved and
since that law was strengthened the
united states has saved billions of
dollars and collected billions of
dollars from fraudulent contractors and
if you want more information as i say
whistleblowers with an ass.org and and
we're actively engaged in that law also
that'll um unfortunately have to be the
final word terrific discussion thank you
for your questions and comments thanks
to the washington center another fine
crop of students with great questions
and comments uh again for also
additional information this book is
available whistleblower law co-authored
with a with a third party uh by our two
guests stephen and michael cohen of the
national whistleblower center and also
especially want to thank bunny
greenhouse for joining us today i really
appreciate you being here and sharing
your tale with us
next week another first amendment
last month federal auditors found that
the private contractor that botched
construction of a 75 million dollar
police academy in iraq has also produced
substandard work in 13 of 14 other
reconstruction projects
next t christian miller argues that
private interests in iraq have wasted
billions of dollars and created security
risks for both iraqis and u.s troops
his new book is blood money this talk is
50 minutes
i'm really um
as i as i told uh the author t christian
miller who goes by the nickname of t
um i
was at a meeting in philadelphia
and i raced back today because i was
very
um interested in hearing the
presentation
um i feel very committed to the topic
that
t has uncovered in this book
and
i'm looking forward to getting an um
above the tree line view
and i hope and i because i haven't had a
chance to read it yet it wasn't
available when i was preparing for
the announcement that he was coming and
the books come in rather recently
so um
i had a chance to talk
ahead of ahead of this
with
mr miller and um
i found out that
he's done mostly investigative reporting
since he has been a reporter
for
started with
the in saint petersburg
for the paper there which
has a wonderful reputation and then he
moved to
los angeles and he did political
reporting in the 2000 campaign
and he's also worked in colombia
on how american drug policies are
fairing
vis-a-vis colombia
and i guess that prepared him
to go to
back and forth from iraq to
uh
our own country to figure out how
our procurement policies are
um supporting or not supporting war
efforts in iraq
and
it is to the los angeles times credit
that
mr miller was assigned this story it's
the only paper in the united states
that has
put a full-time reporter
on the story of
the pentagon's procurement
policies and how they're whether they're
successful or not
and
t will tell us something about
how
how he did the research and what he
found
um i'm sorry i should have
um introduced myself i'm carla cohen i'm
one of the owners of politics and prose
and thank you all for coming today and
i'm really look forward to hearing t
christian miller talk about blood money
[Applause]
thanks so much carl i appreciate that
and thanks to all of you for coming out
on such a beautiful evening i really do
appreciate it uh what carla said was um
that i would i was one of the only
reporters who was over in iraq covering
specifically on the reconstruction and
so what i was hoping to do here today
was to kind of explain to you a little
bit to give you some of the back story
uh behind what eventually became blood
money to tell you kind of how i got that
information and to share with you some
of the stories that i found most
revealing about what's going on over
there in iraq
so
what i wanted to start with is kind of
start how i got into this beat and like
so many things it begins with a phone
call at the time i was working in
colombia covering the drug war in
colombia and my editor called this was
in 2000 late 2003 and said we need you
to cover the reconstruction of iraq
there's a lot of contractors out there
there's a lot of money and we have no
idea what's going on and i kind of
rolled my eyes and i thought to myself
oh this is going to be boring because at
that point in time the u.s procurement
contracting system as it were
was in pretty good shape there had been
no big scandals there had been no 800
toilet seats so i thought this is going
to be a case where the well-regulated
well-governed western system of
contracting was going to meet up with
the wild west of iraq and surely
the western system would win
well i was wrong i was very very wrong
and that's what eventually becomes blood
money is the story of how
the reconstruction of iraq just becomes
a complete disaster and a waste of money
so how did i do what i did uh i came
here to washington and i'm based here in
washington for the la times and what i
would do is i would spend several months
here in washington reporting going to
press conferences talking to the
pentagon talking to the state department
and they would i would be regaled with
stories of how great everything was and
how many projects had been completed and
then i would go over to iraq i would
spend about two three months here and i
would go over to iraq for a month two
months and i would try and ground see
the ground truth what was really
happening in iraq at that time and every
time i went over it was always
another lesson in frustration another
lesson in how much money was being
wasted
uh the first clue i had to this is when
the very first time i went over and i
said well i'll just go and drive around
and and look at some of these
reconstruction projects at the time this
would have been early in 2004 it's still
the violence was still not so serious
that reporters american reporters could
still get out and go to places we there
was there was bodyguards would be
trailed by bodyguards and there was
always the threat of violence but it
wasn't uh as serious as it was now
and so my colleagues who are covering
the military situation and the political
situation could go to places
and i the first time i went over there i
simply said well i'll just go to some
reconstruction sites where are they and
the answer i got back from the
reconstruction folks is well we can't
tell you
well why not because it was just too
dangerous if we told you where there was
a hospital or a health clinic or a water
treatment plant
it would get targeted for attack
so
i was thinking to myself well that says
a lot about our pacification efforts if
we're trying to win hearts and minds we
can't even say to the iraqis i mean
there's no signs posted these places
that say this is a
a gift from the us government
uh
i sort of then had a clue that things
probably aren't going so well so what i
had to do was i had to place myself in
their hands and i would say okay take me
to a water plant that's being built with
our money
and i was very nervous about that
because i'm putting myself in their
hands i was i was assuming i would be
taken to the best possible example and
that would be held out as being how
everything was going just perfect
except they couldn't do that
i would say take me to the water site
and they would take me to a water plant
or a hospital and invariably it would be
a disaster zone i remember one time
going up to uh to kirkuk which was in
northern iraq and it's one of the most
peaceful places in iraq
it was one of the peaceful places of
iraq and going to a water facility which
had just been fixed
and the within minutes of arriving at
this nice new water facility we were
told there was no chlorine to clean the
water
uh there was a big pile of burned
pipes and tubing in the middle because
there'd been some fire
none of the generators were working and
there's no workers to plant because
there was any electricity and finally
and worst of all even if all these
things had worked and there was clean
water no one had thought to actually fix
the pipes which carried the water from
the plant to people's houses and so the
second it left the plant it quickly
became poisoned and contaminated and it
was as bad as it had ever been
and
after this display of how what our money
had gone to pay for we were we were
leaving and i remember the water
engineer turning to me and saying
uh that's it it's their baby now
and they were and they took off and that
was it we had we had
basically done nothing for anybody in
iraq
uh on the second time or the third time
i went over to iraq is when i realized
just how
how bad things were
um i was in sauder city which is a slum
on in eastern eastern uh part of baghdad
and it gives new meaning to the word
slum this is a place where there's no
water uh very few very little
electricity
um
uh there's raw sewage running through
the streets it's as it's as bad as as
bad as an existence as one can imagine
and i was standing uh with a gentleman
by the name of ahmed khamed
who should have been the poster child
for what the bush administration
imagined would happen in iraq this was a
guy who was a shiite
his whole family had been oppressed by
the saddam hussein regime he was
thrilled when u.s soldiers overthrew
saddam hussein he was excited by the the
idea there being a democracy coming to
his country for the first time
he was an educated man a public school
teacher but he had spent the whole two
years since the
since the invasion two years of the
occupation
basically trapped inside his house with
his family
it's 140 degrees there's no electricity
there's a huge pool of raw sewage
literally right in front of his house
his children are sick all the time and
he said to me you people you could put a
man on the moon but you can't get rid of
this puddle of sewage in front of my
house
and i realized i'd heard some version of
that many times before but for some
reason on that day
sun beating down
just looking at this guy and the tragedy
of his life i thought to myself this is
right
america is the wealthiest most
technologically advanced country in the
world
why can't we make the toilets flush on
one corner of
one city in iraq
and that's when i realized we had
completely botched this reconstruction
and the reconstruction was supposed to
be the bridge which kind of united the
the military campaign and the political
campaign
the reconstruction was going to show the
iraqis
what was in store for them if they had a
functioning democracy it was going to
convince the iraqis of the utility of
cooperating with us
it was going to be a way to win hearts
and minds to build a stable society and
none of those things happened because
frankly nobody was ever paying attention
this was not on anybody's radar screen
at all this was there's no one agency
that ever took control of this there was
never any uh real attention paid to how
the money was being spent
congress never appointed any one
committee to look over what's going on
what was happening with how the money
was being spent and so three years later
it was basically
very little had been done there was some
schools were painted but hiring bechtel
an engineering company to paint schools
as i say is like hiring frank gehry to
design your tool shed just doesn't make
a lot of sense there's not a lot of
utility in it there's not a lot of
usefulness in it and it costs a lot of
money
on my
my final trip to iraq
and there was lots of reasons for this
my final trip to iraq was the one where
i finally kind of feel like i got an
insight into at least one of the most
important reasons
you you're familiar with many of them
you've heard them before there was no
real planning
that went into the building for iraq
the post had a big story today about um
the political appointees that was a very
known issue that there was mostly
political appointees hacks who had no
real experience in international
development
the violence uh cannot be uh cannot be
overestimated it's just fundamentally
what sense does it make to rebuild a
country when it's the middle of this
violent
war how can you possibly expect
any company or any government to build
large
projects in the middle of a war zone
instead of building small things
but it was a story of colonel ted west
using which is became kind of my
my
keystone
in the understanding what had happened
in iraq
colonel west husing was uh
one of the one of the finest products of
the military system that you could ask
for he had graduated third in his class
from west point
uh he had come out of west point he had
gone on to lead soldiers in hot spots
like honduras
and north korea he decided though that
for him it was most important to teach
the next generation of officers
so he returned to emory and he'd become
a philosopher he actually got a phd in
philosophy one of 12
i believe or 14 uh u.s military officers
with a phd in philosophy
and he'd returned to west point to teach
ethics
and he was
at the time of the war one of the
leading ethicists for the entire u.s
military
when you had a question about when to
release a bomb or what should be the
rules of war you would go to colonel ted
west using
he believed very much in the war in iraq
he believed that it was a chance to turn
iraq into a democracy and he believed
that deeply and fully and so he wanted
to go over there
so in the fall of
2004 he finally got his chance
he was given the mission of going over
to iraq and training the iraqi police
force which is one of the most important
missions the whole idea of handing over
security to the iraqi police and that
was his job
only when he got over there what he
discovered is that it really wasn't his
job it had been contracted out to a
company in virginia called usis which is
a security company and they were the
ones were actually doing the training
and so at first in in january and
february uh that 2005 he and the
contractor got along quite well but as
time went on and questions about money
kept cropping up again and again and
about well we don't really want to do
this because it costs too much money and
we don't want to we don't want we don't
want to go this direction because it's
going to change our contract and he got
more and more upset
until by june of that year
he was sending home messages saying i
don't know if i can do this anymore i
didn't come here to do this
so one june day he
goes out to
the camp where usis has doing all this
training
and he gives the presentation to
general david petraeus who is one of the
one of the leading
military figures in iraq petraeus lee is
extremely impressed with what's gone on
so far
he
colonel west using decides to stay the
night at this camp
the next day he has an argument that
evening with the contractors again about
money
the next day he wakes up and the next
day uh he's scheduled to go back to the
green zone and instead he doesn't answer
his phone
so the contractor goes out and they
knock on his shed
no answer
15 minutes later another contractor goes
out peers to the blinds and sees colonel
west using
lying on the floor in a pool of his own
blood and he's dead
at the time he was the highest ranking
military officer to die in iraq the army
concluded that his death was a suicide
and he left a note um
that i think kind of said a lot for for
sort of what were the underpinnings of
this reconstruction effort and
what it led to and i want to read that
that final note from colonel west using
to you
i included in the book because i thought
it was so telling
so investigators found it lying on
westfusing's bed the note was four pages
long choppy and filled with
abbreviations and underlined words
the handwriting matched colonel west
heusings
parts of the letter lashed out at his
commanders but most of it was a
wrenching account of a struggle for
honor in a strange land
it read
i cannot support a mission that leads to
corruption human rights abuse and liars
i am sullied
no more i didn't volunteer to support
corrupt money hungry contractors nor
worked for commanders only interested in
themselves
i came to serve honorably and i feel
dishonored i trust no iraqi i cannot
live this way
death before being dishonored anymore
trust is essential i don't know whom to
trust anymore
why serve when you cannot accomplish the
mission when you no longer believe in
the cause when your every breath and
effort to succeed meets with lies lack
of support and selfishness
life needs trust and trust is no more
for me here in iraq
now
several of colonel west using family
members don't believe he committed
suicide they believed that there was
something else involved but for me what
was important about his death was not
whether or not
there was a whistleblower a contractor
who killed the colonel in an effort to
silence a whistleblower or whether or
not he committed suicide
what was important
was that he was an example of how we had
told american soldiers
for generation after generation that
wars must be fought
uh with men of purpose men who believe
in duty honor and country and then in
iraq we paid people to fight it for us
and war turns out to be this dirty dime
store business after all and for people
like colonel west using that was a clash
that he just couldn't overcome
and so the reconstruction of iraq what
happened there more fundamentally than
anything else was that you had you had a
lack of people who had purpose and
passion and patriotism and instead it
was replaced by profit that was the main
motive that sapped all the energy out of
whatever chance there was for success in
iraq in the reconstruction
thanks
i know you have a lot of questions the
mike is in the center of the room this
time
um and i we would ask you please to use
the mic because our friends from c-span
are here and we're also recording these
uh sessions so we we can make cds
available to people who haven't been
able to attend and i'm sure that this
will be one that will be highly sought
after
i think that um
that t has shown
he he won the livingston award which is
the
um he calls it the junior pulitzer
uh
for his investigative reporting was that
that was colombia right
that was for his investigative reporter
reporting in the columbia drug trade and
i i think that this book will um
is
it will be equally well received and
and
and will win as many awards
it's very very important
information
uh we have a question
hi good evening thank you for your talk
i enjoyed hearing you um
i'm just curious if you found how high
in the bush administration the war
profiteering went in other words was it
just uh individual contractors who've
made a lot of money off the war or were
there administration officials who
profited and if so how high did you find
that that went
sure well there's both
actually um i will say that one of the
things that surprised me most
was
that
or one of the reasons the reconstruction
didn't work was because it didn't go
to the top it's not president bush
didn't speak about the reconstruction of
iraq until this last december uh it was
completely under his radar and there was
no top level attention really paid so
the program drifted to a bunch of sort
of second and third hand cronies of the
administration
certainly there was lots of
ex-administration officials who profited
within the administration i tell one one
story about uh
several stories but i think the mo the
highest ranking i saw was in in
rumsfeld's office an individual name of
jack shaw
who um has since left the pentagon but
he was a deputy under secretary of
defense who tried to steer a contract to
a company that had a friend of his on
the board for cell phone service
that was a market worth up to a billion
dollars a year in iraq
and that was as high as i saw in terms
of direct
issues
interestingly enough shaw was never
prosecuted for that and
has the fbi has since dropped that
particular case
one person told me i was putting it too
hard to do pile
but that was the highest in the
administration but certainly there was
lots of contractors who had uh
connections to the administration the
most famous of course which is
halliburton
i had kind of a different take on
halliburton which is halliburton had two
big jobs in iraq one was to house and
feed the soldiers and the second to
restart the oil industry both of which
were incredibly important if you think
about it's amazing that we put that much
importance
into the contracts of that importance in
the hands of a single company
on the feeding and housing of soldiers
there's been a lot about how much
they've wasted money and that's true
certainly but at the same time every
time i went to iraq they delivered those
soldiers were well fed they were well
housed and so
to my estimation they get a little bit
of a pass because it is
a it is a war zone it is a desert
environment and but
they may have wasted money but they did
deliver
on the oil side of the sector uh the
reason that you and i are still paying
the bills and the reconstruction is
because the oil flow over there is still
less than it was under saddam hussein
and so uh that was their job to get the
oil working again and they didn't do
that and so that's certainly we can
blame them for that
would you please speak about the
problems of information gathering
and assessing the accuracy of the
information in a world where everything
is topsy-turvy and you can't really
trust sources and the language
difficulties as well as the problems
here
with um documents not being accessible
thank you that's a great question it's a
really good question uh
this was the hardest investigative job
i've ever had to do by far
for a lot of different reasons one one
is because it was complete chaos there
was no one agency involved so just a
simple act of following the money which
is still really is the fundamental rule
in investigative reporting was
impossible it was just impossible three
years later i still have yet to get a
single contract from any foia anywhere
because they will tell you well we don't
know where they are they're
they were hand written and they're in a
drawer they're in a cabinet we don't
know and so just to find out well who is
who's the ultimate signature on this
contract and who's getting the money
where's the money coming from
just was an impossible thing you had
like the
the michigan automotive command was
running the equipping of ak-47s to iraqi
police forces you had the department of
interior
in in arizona was running the contract
for interrogators at abu ghraib
you know smokey the bear overlooking the
cia it was just it was such a joke and a
mix of contracts because they were in
such a panic and such a rush to get this
going they would whatever free body was
available would literally be the one who
ended up with the job this particular
job even colonel west using he's a
military ethicist who teaches philosophy
and he ends up in charge of training
iraqi cops so just the whole thing was
always difficult to find out where
the money was going to
the other big issue was security like i
said it would be
i would say take me to a site well okay
we will but you can't interview anybody
at the site
no iraqis because we can't give you
their names you can't interview any of
the contract companies because they
don't want their names used
you can't say where this actual plant is
because then it might be bombed and you
can't say really what it does
well so what am i going to you know what
i'm going to talk about and these long
arguments back and forth like i remember
uh
trying to do a story on a electrical
generator which was coming to a
particular site it was going to be a
good news story they finally got this
generator there i just couldn't do it i
couldn't say what it was i couldn't see
what company was doing it i couldn't see
where it was it was a story with no
information there so i just i couldn't
do it
and it really became a question of
getting on the ground and getting out to
these
sites where you would talk to the people
on the ground who would give a much
different perspective than what you were
hearing
back here in washington
other than the colonel whose story you
gave us what effect has this had
on the morale of the troops in the area
and also their view of their mission
there
that's another good question uh two two
points to that on the morale uh one of
the biggest factors
is the private security forces which i
didn't talk very much about but there's
nobody knows how many 30 to 50 000 uh
private security contractors in iraq
these are guys who are armed just like a
soldier would be armed uh but who gets
paid about a hundred to a hundred
thousand dollars a year versus the
soldiers getting paid 25 to 30 000 a
year they all know that all the soldiers
know that and so they only need to look
left or right to know really
uh what they could be doing they could
be making a hundred thousand dollars
that makes the private security
contractor not particularly popular and
it also is demoralizing the troops in
terms of what kind of value you place on
their lives what they're doing
um so that's one
that's one of the big effects on morale
and the other big effect is that
you took the responsibility of the
reconstruction out of the hands of the
people who would most benefit from it
that is the soldiers i mean you're a
soldier you're out there every day
you're talking to the shakes you're
talking to the average iraqis you know
they need a well here
or they want their hospital fixed they
want this building painted but they're
not you can't do anything about that
because it's been contracted out to some
other company so you end up not being
able to uh to basically protect yourself
and your troops and that's an enormously
frustrating
painful thing for not only ground level
troops but for a lot of senior military
commanders as well
it's uh eric gustafson with the
education for peace and rec center it's
great to see you
um first of all i want to thank you for
your investigative reporting because
it's extremely valuable and i know the
risks that you often have to take to get
to the story
what i'd like to ask is in terms of
where do we go from here
what are you seeing in the changes that
have been made since things a lot of it
the reconstruction program has been
passed on to the state department to
usaid are you seeing any success stories
even if it's the smallest of programs
like the community action program
and um
and then uh are
based on what you've learned so far
um
do you feel that
we best just abandon it all together or
do you feel that there's still a moral
imperative to continue to find ways to
succeed in iraq certainly and eric's uh
not mentioning his group had some of the
best on the ground knowledge uh they had
worked off the sanctions period
in iraq and eric helped me quite a bit
on the health sector part of the story
sort of showing me just what had gone
wrong in the health sector there again
with hiring political hacks and not some
of the experts in the international
development uh the answer to your
question is i think that the biggest
tragedy of the reconstruction is that
we're about to completely give up on it
september 30th is the last day for
signing contracts the money's out as of
that day
uh there's no more new money the bush
administration talks about this being a
war for right about ideas but we're not
paying anybody to fight that war for
ideas anymore we're not putting any
money to do that anymore we're just
putting money to fight the war of uh the
war of killing people so um
i think it's a great tragedy that we're
we're giving up we have kind of gotten
better there are there's a community
action programs there's a focus now on
hiring local iraqis and bringing them
into the process there's a focus on
getting out to the provinces and finding
out what it is the provinces want to do
and there has been the command has been
centralized under the u.s army corps of
engineers so just when we've almost got
it right
we're gonna we're gonna give up
and to me that would be the greatest
tragedy of all because in my opinion
we've got a fundamental
moral political strategic imperative
to at the very very least return that
country to some functioning semblance in
the basic infrastructure of water power
sewer treatment things like that and we
haven't done that yet
and what would the role of congressional
oversight be
is there
a committee
no there's not the republicans as i'm
sure you're aware have been in control
of congress during this whole process
the democrats have many times have
suggested for instance a truman
commission appointing a war profiteering
commission and just this book for me was
not this is not neither a a a left-wing
book or a right-wing book because
everybody should be concerned about
greed this is about greed and war
profiteering it's really not
it's not a political thing nobody wants
to see
money wasted and effort wasted
but the republicans have shown no
interest whatsoever and taking the
democrats up on that offer to have a
truman commission which could have
uh been there been cracking the whip to
say uh no we need to continue this
program we can we can give up on this
program we need to do this or not do
this uh and a congressional committee
could have filled that role
of being a voice a leader to get this
program right
and the truman commission was in a
democratic administration
the truman led the commission while
roosevelt was president
so it's right
in the entire world i point out in the
book the entire marshall plan the world
war ii reconstruction
historical parallels were always
dangerous but was essentially one of the
points in the book is it was a much more
bipartisan effort than this ever was
this is a fabulous book
i'm al ripskis and i did 13 years of
investigative reporting at hud you
outdid me here and then the conditions
that you had to do it you know here's
this name but my question is
accountability
how do you see any in terms of you
mentioned one about the cell phone thing
but broadly this whole book
how do you see
accountability playing into this thing i
mean are these people being held
accountable for overall or not
now one of the points i make in the book
is
we've spent 30 billion dollars now and
for the past three and a half years
we've had 70 000 contractors running
around in iraq and in this time we've
had exactly two criminal prosecutions so
we either sent angels over there or
somebody has been paying attention and i
think the answer is nobody's been paying
attention uh there has been
there hasn't been any accountability
answer your question quickly
i'd just like to get your
comments
um the whole middle east situation
you know we may not have known all the
details and everything you know most of
us but i think
for the most part we had an idea that
the place was a mess i mean it's been a
mess for however long there's
the the problems that they've had so uh
my question or what i'd like you to
comment on is
um
you know we expect that
our politicians our leaders um are
intelligent people
who have some
recognition of history and
and those kind of things and
with what you're talking about here even
with contracting
how could
uh we have not been prepared
for this kind of thing
well that's a whole other book isn't it
a couple been written on that uh there's
a lot of a lot of reasons for that out
to my i'll stick to my little narrow
area in terms of the war planning is
that fundamentally nobody expected
us to be in iraq for that long it was
going to be a quick short occupation
um
doug feith who was the the pentagon
official was in charge of the planning
told me as much that they were hoping to
turn over command
relatively quickly
within a matter of months
to the rebuilding effort when that
didn't happen
they had nobody and they had to scramble
to fill every single position and to
come up with a whole plan and so they
gave
for the first two years or about year
and a half the reconstruction was given
to a good guy
an army retired vice admiral
who had never done any reconstruction at
all ever and he was the guy we gave 18
billion dollars to and
hope you get right
dave
thank you for doing this and thank you
in general for the class of
investigative journalists i want to go
in two directions one is the policy and
institutional government accountability
there's an inspector general
why did that office
come into the situation late and what
happens to its recommendations and then
i want to ask you something about the
press
okay okay i'll answer that question with
the inspector general
yes there is a special inspector general
for the reconstruction of iraq he wasn't
appointed until january of 2004
so
he wasn't there for the first year when
a lot of this
really went off the rails
why wasn't he appointed i would go back
to the same answers before as nobody
really expected there to be
an occupation to last this long
now while there is a special inspector
general over there i want to point this
out he's only looking at
the the little slice the pie about 30
billion dollars which is reconstruction
the pentagon inspector general the the
military is spending 1 billion dollars a
week
they've got nobody over there there's
not a single inspector general on the
ground in iraq the inspector general are
the guys who do watch dog work for for
the government the ones who are supposed
to catch uh waste fraud and abuse
that's stunning to me there's not it's
stunning that pentagon has not for two
and a half years nobody on the ground
than iraq so uh the special inspector
general has done i think an admirable
job
um i have a whole chapter in the book
about stuart bowen he was a bush
political appointee he was actually a
lawyer for bush in the florida recount
nobody thought he was going to be
anything other than a whitewash they
turned out to be pretty aggressive and
he's taken on the administration the
contractors etc and he's done quite an
amazing job and released numerous
critical audits and reports
um
he is also one of the ones who's the
only one have a prosecution under his
belt in terms of uh criminal prosecution
against
uh contractors in iraq so he has had
some effect certainly it did take him
almost almost a year to get him
appointed and you lost a lot of ground
in that year so i hope that answers that
question your comment you did in your
comment on the pentagon's
failure which it has a statutory
responsibility to have someone over
there to have
some capacity over there
points out the whole point about the
absence of oversight and therefore this
is where investigative journalists come
in because you become our
you're really our people's
representatives in terms of
of doing oversight
now to do oversight this is a huge cost
in terms of investigative journalism in
terms of the media and the press and we
read every day about how the press is
cutting back in
different different institutions
share with us a little bit about why the
los angeles times decided to put such an
emphasis on investigative journalism
here and in other areas
the la times has traditionally been a
paper which favors longer journalism
like the larger papers in this country
do our current editor is a guy named
dean mckay
the managing understanding doug franz
both those guys cut their teeth on
investigative reporting
in the chicago tribune and the new york
times and so they've now made it a focus
a priority the los angeles times is
investigative reporting so it was dean
mckay the editor who
[Music]
gave me this job and said you will
follow the money on this one case and
that laser-like focus i think is what
what produced some of the successes we
had in terms of revealing what was going
wrong over there
the cost question is not to be
downplayed there's only
three or four news organizations now
which can really maintain a big presence
over there
just to um
you know have bodyguards going around
with you for a day is five thousand
dollars a day it's
not enough quarters to put in the
machine to make up for that um so it's
definitely uh
definitely it's it's a money losing
proposition but the papers feel that's
important and the la time specifically
felt that this watchdogging was of
critical importance
so that really raises the whole question
of the media's responsibility in civil
society thank you yeah thank you i
appreciate that
with respect to
i guess particularly future financing of
reconstruction and also the past how
have
the bilateral and multilateral donors
fit into it and i guess specifically now
that wolfowitz is heading up the world
bank can we expect to see them pulling
out their wallets yeah you really think
he would really feel a
certain certain duty right to step up um
but they haven't uh the both and on
we're the only ones pulling this wagon
at the stage of the game there are
agreements in place for both bilateral
funding and japan in particular has
stepped up to the plate but no other
country has and most disappointingly
none of the surrounding
uh
gulf countries or arab countries have
done done anything to speak up except
for iran which is funneling money into
iraq right now in hospitals and things
like that so um there are agreements in
place but most of these countries look
over there and they think to themselves
why am i going to send money
uh to help rebuild that country when
it's still a disaster zone
again i would point out the difference
with lebanon which quickly not only had
met all of its pledges it has been as
though arab countries have stepped up
and actually have gone over what lebanon
is asking for iraq has just been
abandoned it's not their problem it's
our problem
i guess there are there are all kinds of
books coming out now fiasco we've had
here hubris has come out
i mean it's just one
long litany of institutional almost
institutional collapse and incompetence
well i it's it's at some point it's hard
it's hard to know what to make of this
and it's hard to know at which point the
american people say
enough of this this is this is uh
exposing us to
international ridicule i mean it's it's
it's just unbelievable stuff
it doesn't seem to be a debate anymore
it just seems to be one long accepted
list of
disasters after another
i mean i'm not quite sure what my
question is but
what
what what is the point when all this is
too much um well i can't answer that i
will we'll see in november right
when the elections happen
uh i know that in the the in and against
in my little corner of the world which
is the reconstruction of iraq
i don't know if it's salvageable
but i think it is
shameful that we would give up
right now on specifically the issue
of trying to
improve basic
human
uh and health services for people in
iraq
we can argue and debate endlessly about
the politics the military and these kind
of things but i think every all side
should be able to agree
there's some fundamental standard of
care issue here
that we can actually have an impact on
we can make a difference on
and to give up now is just uh
well i don't think it's right but you've
said that it's very difficult to operate
in the uh yes well i i do i don't think
we should give big multinational
contractors gazillion dollar contracts
to build white elephants i don't think
that i do think that the the military
and specifically the military has done
quite a good job in recent years
some military commanders get it people
like general pete corelli is over there
now gets the value
of building a well
and walking through a town
without a tank
not every commander does but more and
more have and to
cut off the flow of those funds to the
military guys to our troops who really
do need that money
that's just it doesn't make any sense to
me
you mentioned uh halliburton's uh
botching of the
the oil infrastructure job and the us
spent something like 20 billion dollars
of the development fund of iraq iraq's
own money yes and at this point
they don't have enough money
and need to go to international
creditors i imagine or are being urged
to do that right no right
isn't it isn't the imf putting
conditionalities on iraq as we speak
yeah sure that's the whole thing about
why is the world bank a little more uh
hasn't been shamed more into to helping
out in iraq the uh with the oil contract
the whole idea is that the bush
administration's belief was that private
sector companies would step in
and gleefully invest in 117 billion
billion barrels of oil they were in iraq
so they kind of they only spent only i
put that in quotes two or three billion
dollars on fixing the oil system when i
needed 50. and so three and a half years
later
you don't you have you don't have any
and you have less oil than under saddam
hussein you have no real legal
infrastructure in place to entice the
company to come in so the only people
who are playing in the in the in the oil
market in iraq or iraqis
and some iranian and turkish firms
there's a sort of a counter-argument a
group called platform put out a a report
called crude designs
which talks about the bremer orders and
the
pending oil law that the u.s with the
help of consultants like bearingpoint
have used to essentially force iraq to
privatize the untapped oil through the
use of production share agreements that
would lock them into a
multi-decade arrangement that would
favor these multinationals and that
group estimates estimates that they
would lose 200 billion dollars of
revenue
that could have gone to them if they had
developed their own autonomous oil
infrastructure this is something the
unions in iraq are pushing for right
so
i mean isn't that the the issue now
going forward and it is going forward
just point out you're absolutely right
your description of what the the fantasy
was is absolutely right and that and
bremer did try to put in to play
something like basically a free market
oil system
it didn't ever materialize there's not a
single
major
oil company even even remotely
interested in going into iraq right now
there's not very many minor ones either
so the theory certainly well that was
the idea but that's changed uh
dramatically since then there's a lot of
iraqis who
in the assembly who are not going to let
that happen i don't think anytime soon
that's not the information i'm hearing
but uh you may be you know more when i
mean because uh recently i heard that
that chevron and shell and bp
are all getting personnel in there to
train iraqis
a few years a few years ago they had
training contracts which that was going
to eventually hopefully lead to
long-term contracts once again that's
never materialized and i can tell you
talking to iraqis
uh iraqis are very much aware of the
value of their natural their national
resource there there may be some form of
upstream downstream uh
contracts with with oil companies but
the iraqis are pretty clever and pretty
smart about what the oil entry means to
them and that's essentially what a lot
of the fighting is going on about is
southern iraq has its oil northern iraq
has oil the sunnis don't so that's a
subtext to all the conflicts that's
going on right now is how do we split up
and how do we make the best use of this
oil revenue so oil is always at the
center of the iraq question
um you mentioned at the beginning of
your presentation a i think it was a
prominent chia shia family or the
gentleman that you interviewed with
early in your tenure in iraq and how at
the beginning he was you know all
jubilant that you know this was the dawn
of a new day and
um and how now he's sort of seen the
reality and i guess he's less jubilant
than he was three years ago so i'm based
on your reporting and talking to
people in iraq i think you mentioned
your kirk you know where the kurds i
think were also largely supportive of
our effort when we first went in um so
based on um you're reporting now and
talking to the people that you've talked
to in different areas of the country now
the sunni i would imagine we're probably
against us obviously invasion from the
start but to the extent that we had
initial going goodwill going in with the
she and the kurds
are is there any good will left are they
you know at all supportive of our
efforts to to try and rebuild is there
any recognition that you know
what what do they think of us now
basically well i'll caveat this i
haven't been reporting in iraq for
almost a year now so my information is
sort of dated uh and it's based on what
i know now sort of based on conversation
with my colleagues who are reporting
there which i keep in contact with
certainly the kurds are still uh the
most pro-american of all the groups i
mean the kurds have always been that way
and they haven't completely lost faith
um the sunnis i think are are perplexed
they don't understand why there is more
of a
bond with the americans because i think
they should be they don't understand why
and i think the shia are
in their very own internecine conflicts
that are very very complex and murky in
between people like uh maktar sauter and
um hakeem and these guys and uh
i can't i can't begin to shed light on
what the shia believe and i don't think
there's a monolithic belief but i would
say that um
in general i would say the general
general answer your question is over
time all groups and polls show this and
people will tell you this
uh
the belief
in the promise of the u.s has
evaporated this will be the last
question
i was wondering how you would um
evaluate how the insurgency and sabotage
fits into the reconstruction story
because or is it totally our
incompetence or how would you balance
those oh that's a good question because
a lot of times they'll tell you that the
violence has impeded uh the
reconstruction
but the point of fact it does in two two
very important ways one is oil
oil pipelines get attacked all the time
and that's impeded the oil production
that's only in the north not in the
south which is where most oil is made
and then electricity they knock down
electrical lines power lines all the
time but in every other area when they
talk about the violence impacting uh the
reconstruction
it was more a question of money
it took up 25 of every dollar just to
protect people going out and fixing
these plants the actual
hospitals and schools and clinics and
things like that were actually very
rarely attacked partially i think
because nobody knew they were being
built by the americans because they had
no signs um but also partially because i
think that the the local people weren't
particularly interested in seeing these
things attacked and so they would keep
people away from keep the insurgents
away from those those targets
but the insurgency certainly did really
affect two of the most important which
was electricity and oil and
again that's the problem that should
have been addressed
why did people like douglas fight think
it would be a quick in and out and if we
and if we'd put more troops in may have
may have been right
may he have been right well that's a
question i'm sure he also i hope he asks
himself um i hope everybody asks
themselves uh i feith and a lot of the
other people who were bought into the
belief of a quick and easy occupation
um
thought that there was an iraqi
infrastructure in place a leadership in
place a bureaucracy in place
that would stand up and take control
once saddam hussein had been overthrown
that didn't happen of course there was
saddam hussein
was basically the entire iraqi
government there was nobody after him
there was nobody with initiative or
intelligence or the education to replace
uh the the whip he cracked and so once
they were once he was gone there was
nobody to replace him and i think that
was a fundamental miscalculation
if there have been more troops in place
um
yeah sure it would have been a different
a different scenario you would have been
able to prevent a lot of the looting for
instance that occurred and looting set
back the reconstruction effort by we
were 10 billion dollars in the hole
starting
because so much got loaded in iraq so
yeah certainly it would have
given us more of a foundation to build
on what we had
thank you so much
[Applause]
one additional thing i wanted to point
out is that for those of you who are
interested in the topic uh tomorrow
there's going to be a
a documentary called iraq for sale by
robert greenwald and he'll be at the
wooly mammoth theater and i have some
flyers and information about that and
i'll put up a poster downstairs and
that's a real good documentary too on on
the contracting the reconstruction in
iraq iraq for sale it's called
l.a times investigative reporter t
christian miller on his book blood money
for more information visit his blog on
the huffington post's website at
huffingtonpost.com
christian dash miller
see this program again monday at 5 30
a.m eastern here on
uh plus shipping and handling and then
you're required to buy just uh four more
books over the next two years
and certainly if you are somebody who
cares about the conservative movement
and conservative ideas and just
generally wants great books
for instance one of our main selections
back in august was the afghan by
frederick forsyth the novel
and an extraordinary brilliant and
terrifying novel about jihad
and we offer again the the widest
possible range of books so
americancompass.com is the place to go
brad meiner editor-in-chief of the
american compass thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
president bush pledged bipartisan
cooperation this week after democrats
won a majority in both houses of
congress
next lew dubose and jake bernstein argue
that vice president dick cheney has made
the bush administration unpopular
this talk from politics and pro's
bookstore in washington dc is just under
an hour
good evening i'm barbara mead i'm one of
the owners here at politics and pros and
i'm delighted to see we got as many
people as we did tonight first of all it
being a rainy day
but second of all of the astounding news
that came over the newswires today which
i think a lot of people have gone home
to
watch all those pundits figure out what
it all means but we we've got our own
we've got our own two pundits right here
so they they can help us and they may
help us better okay i'm here to welcome
lou dubose and jake bernstein on the
occasion of the publication
of vice
which is a
investigation of the political years of
vice president cheney
it's just an extraordinary book and
these are two guys who really knew what
they were doing and writing it louder
bose
has
two previous biographies of bush that he
has written with molly ivan's
shrub and bushwhacked he has also
written a biography of karl rove and
he's also been written a biography of
tom delay
he has a lot of political research under
his belt
so and with of uh lou this evening is
jake bernstein
he is the executive editor
of the texas
observer he spent a long time as an
investigative reporter in texas and one
of the things that came out of that was
a series of a series of articles
about tom delay that won him
many awards for his investigative
journalism
so between the two of them they've come
out with just a wonderful
overview
of uh what the cheney years
in the bush administration have meant
i can't help but tell you in closing
that i think i was counting up that it
is this
cheney rumsfeld affiliation started back
in 1974
so uh as of today we're
um
22
30 32 years later
um at least one person has left the
equation and we'll find out more about
that tonight but i'm delighted to have
jake bernstein and lou dubose here
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you barbara and thank you all for
coming i'm
delighted to be here again uh the last
time i was here i was prophetically
explaining that tom delay had told me
and that there would be a permanent
republican majority in the in the house
of representatives
i was late getting here on the way over
i realized that the traffic was held up
because of the shifting of the tectonic
plates
in the uh in the american electoral
political system
an amazing night it's a different
morning we all wake up to this morning
uh before i i start i guess not before i
start because i've already started uh i
would like to uh recognize our colleague
and researcher peter lindstrom uh who is
sitting in the back uh peter has worked
with us on this book but there's another
uh a side of it peter peter is both a a
literary and political researcher not
that the work we do is literary but i'd
like to sort of give it that little
cachet uh he peter worked on uh has
worked on on three political campaigns
that i've known of one involved tom
delay
and most recently uh it was he he was
the opposite he did opposition research
for on the rick santorum santorum
campaign for casey and also on the pmbok
uh richard pombo campaign so if you're
uh predisposed to applaud
go ahead he's
he is a man
he's a man on a roll uh
and uh and we were pr
you can afford them peter
you know uh it is a different morning
that we wake up to uh we were speaking
last week in austin and uh i i said it
was the 30th anniversary the precise
date and j corrected me it was the 20th
anniversary of iran contra
by which uh dick cheney rose to another
another level of pro of prominence in in
an american in in the american political
pantheon uh where he finds himself as
mourning um
i'm you know i started out uh
as as a texas reporter texas following
george bush and uh watching him uh
run a gubernatorial campaign that was
essentially a campaign for the uh a
gubernatorial six years as governor that
was what was essentially a campaign for
the presidency
and uh
and
there was
so you know those of us from texas who
believe in the state and it's a state in
which people believe uh you know looked
at this iron triangle of of karl rove
uh
and uh karen hughes
and joe alba and and we're we're very
much in awe of the fact that these that
these these these these three were
coming to washington and we're going to
actually take over and run the country
and i think they believe that too for a
long time uh you know karl rove is is
without doubt one of the one of the
great uh political minds of modern
political history in this country but
you know karen hughes was okay i mean
she was an adequate press secretary for
george bush in washington
in austin and and joe alba was kind of a
business guy and a hustler and and what
they encountered in washington
i think established when they arrived
here was was a team of of uh seasoned
political insiders
uh
you know
don rumsfeld and dick cheney started out
together in the nixon administration uh
don don rumsfeld
uh gay uh other than being a a lineman
in in in his home state
not a football type lineman but but you
know like a lineman for a glenn campbell
type of lineman alignment
diction his first paying job his first
government job his first what was dick
cheney got was from from don rumsfeld is
when don rumsfeld was working in the in
the uh
in the nixon administration so you know
you go all the way back to nixon with
cheney and rumsfeld uh david eddington
uh you know the the legal mind behind uh
the uh the unitary presidency and and
dick cheney's longtime advisor was at
the cia
and in working uh in in the eight in in
in the early eighties moved over to the
intelligence house intelligence
committee where he he joined up with
dick cheney uh
paul wolfowitz was was moving back and
forth between yale and between uh the uh
the policy shop of of uh senator scoop
jackson
and uh who else who am i missing
in that group uh
scooter libby was was was in 81 went to
work at the state department well in 81
george bush was was still hanging out at
chateau de jean playing basketball at
the downtown houston y and and really
trying to find himself
so
you i think what happened with with uh
the uh the the the iron triangle and the
end were they really were and and i
don't want to diminish karl rove's uh uh
brilliance as a political tactician
because i think that up until up until
last this morning at about two o'clock
that was proven
but i i think that that that he kind of
ran out of tricks but but the the iron
triangle really was not an iron triangle
they they really in the end i think were
they were they were three three people
from texas and they were very much uh
the mayberry machiavellians
that that uh joseph diolio called this
as he described them
and what they encountered was was
a well-oiled seasoned political machine
that had been working together in
washington since since since the 70s and
i i think that that's where
what happens with the presidency and why
the war becomes why it was why dick
cheney was able and and what wolfowitz
and and and rumsfeld were able to sell
the war to to to george bush was because
they were so vastly some so far vastly
more experienced than he was
and
it all goes back to and this is this is
a a bit of a dog and pony show and we
take times turns being the dog in the
pony uh it all goes back to the to the
to the ford administration and and and
it was jake who uh had the privilege of
flying to dearborn in winter uh to look
at that to look at what dick cheney had
done in the ford administration and i
think i'll step aside and we'll sort of
talk back and forth for a while but this
is the this is a crowd that probably
knows as much as we do so maybe we can
have a conversation about this in 15
minutes or so or we can go on for an
hour and a half
am i the dog or the pony
actually it's ann arbor michigan where
the ford library is but there there's an
incredible irony uh to to yesterday's
revolt results uh involving dick cheney
well and revolt yes indeed um
and that and and that is is directly
related to the ford administration and
so much of what's happened uh in the
past six years is actually directly
related to the ford administration um
when when when cheney joined uh ford uh
rumsfeld was chief of staff and cheney
was deputy chief of staff in the
beginning uh in 74 after the nixon
pardon there was a huge democratic wave
the democrats picked up uh more than 40
seats
and this incredible reform congress
started and their main goal was to
dismantle the imperial presidency that
richard nixon had constructed and they
went about doing that quite aggressively
particularly in the area of intelligence
uh the church committee and and the pike
committee
were starting to to do their business
and all kinds of awful skeletons were
coming tumbling out of the closet and so
there was a big battle
as jack marsh said to us um
dealing with congress on intelligence
during that period was like opening the
door and having a tsunami come through
every day and so this really traumatized
cheney uh i think traumatized rumsfeld
as well but particularly cheney and he
has really spent the past 30 years
trying to reconstruct the imperial
presidency
that was dismantled under ford and a few
years before and a few years after um
the irony of course is that in the
process of doing this uh in sort of
being more
authoritarian and uh and less concealed
conciliatory and and certainly less
willing to discuss
and and work with congress um he
engendered to some degree the backlash
that created the very same dynamic that
happened in in 74 except this time in
2006. so i
i tend to doubt that that he's in south
dakota right now hunting uh that he's
really savoring this irony but uh but
it's certainly out there um some of the
other areas that that that have echoes
to to ford that are happening now um
in addition to intelligence is
environmental stuff nixon actually has a
fairly decent environmental record uh
ford was not so so good and and there's
certainly a lot of uh
there's some indications that the part
of that was cheney um energy was an
issue in ford uh that as it is now and
cheney again was was right at the center
of that and cheney really picked up his
his uh his political style in the ford
administration cheney was the guy who
went into the oval office and had the
last word with the president he was the
person who never wrote anything down
that was one of the things he learned
from rumsfeld but instead uh had uh you
know was whispering in the president's
ear and had influence in that way and
that's really carried over uh to the
bush administration
one other aspect that's particularly
kind of ironic and revealing about
cheney's time at ford is uh is nelson
rockefeller
nelson rockefeller was ford's vice
president and uh he was a major player
in the republican party from the
moderate wing successful new york
governor and uh and ford wanted
rockefeller to have a real role in in
the ford administration and so he he put
him in charge of the domestic uh policy
council and the idea was that
rockefeller would be the one who would
drive domestic policy to a large degree
in the ford administration now rumsfeld
and cheney really didn't like
rockefeller they didn't like his
politics they didn't like him personally
i don't think uh and uh and there was a
immediate conflict there and since they
kind of controlled the bureaucratic
levers to some degree they managed to
kind of isolate and marginalize
uh rockefeller and in the end uh uh ford
asked him not to to put his name in
again um when they ran for
when ford ran for reelection
or elections since he hadn't really been
elected but uh but what's the ironic
part of it is that uh shortly after the
ford administration cheney gave an
interview and talked about how
what ford had tried with rockefeller was
exactly wrong that a vice president
shouldn't have that kind of power
shouldn't be involved in policy because
in fact you know it wasn't going to be
equal there was no way that staffers
could relate to the vice president as a
staffer uh he
he had a more powerful position and that
it was just in an imbalance that
couldn't be corrected and it would sort
of throw off the whole
the whole shebang and and so you know
ironically that's exactly what uh what
what cheney sort of constructed for
himself
um after uh
we can talk a little bit about congress
but uh
after after ford uh cheney took
a a a little time off but not much
and ran for congress in wyoming and and
became a congressman and was was
instantly sort of a player in congress
because he had been chief of staff the
youngest chief of staff in the history
of our country and uh and and
lou will talk a little bit more about
what uh some of the things that he did
in in in congress but one of the things
that's particularly revealing for for
where we are now is is cheney's role in
iran contra which which a lot of people
don't really uh understand he was a
ranking minority uh uh person on in on
the intelligence committee and also on
the iran contra committee and and he
really worked to um
to limit the the extent of iran contra
and uh and coordinated it see it seems
clear now that uh that he coordinated if
not personally his staff coordinated
oliver north on their testimony and on
the uh the stuff that went on as as far
as the investigation into iran contra
this was really an example for cheney of
how to um
of what the president should be allowed
to do i mean it was
illegal they were circumventing congress
but but cheney kind of thought that that
they didn't you know congress didn't
have a role in foreign policy and and so
in fact the the president hadn't really
broken any laws uh errors of judgment he
said but but certainly uh no law
breaking
so um but the there's a rise uh uh
of of the republican right in congress
that cheney was very much part of and
and lou can certainly talk on that i
think we should interview each other
there we go we should we should actually
be interviewing each other back and
forth because this is an odd dynamic but
we will proceed with it nonetheless
uh you know there are missed
opportunities in life and just as i
think uh george w bush would have made a
great
commissioner of baseball
dick cheney given the opportunity would
have made a great majority leader in the
house
and and perhaps for a while uh speaker
of the house because uh dick cheney
arrived at the hou in the house same
year george bush uh lost his election in
midland uh
and and and sort of set out again to
find himself uh as he has done on
occasion uh
dick cheney was elected to the house 78
78 he's elected to the house um and he
he of course arrives not as a
just a guy who's run for the house of
representatives but as a former staffer
in the white house with it with this
enormous celebrity status
and uh and and was was for a while
a real institutionalist in the house of
representatives sort of following the
same track that that the leadership
path that lyndon johnson had followed
before him and that uh then another uh
interesting footnote in american
political history tom delay had followed
after um
you know sort of committee by committee
positioned by position the you know the
republicans had been out of power
for uh 25 years at the time
about 25 years i think and and uh and
dick cheney found insinuated himself
into into various uh committees and
paths to power and was really entirely
on his way to becoming uh to becoming
the majority leader and replacing bob
michael who was then uh was then on his
way out
uh or at least was contemplating
retirement because the republican
republicans in the house had been out
for so long um
probably would have been a majority
leader had had not he been appointed by
uh the senior george bush as secretary
of defense but um
you know along the way he compiled one
of the most
extremist records uh voting records in
in in
in the history of the house modern house
he was to the right of newt gingrich he
was he was sort of out there between
newt and bob dornan uh you know he went
off the cliff on a number of issues uh
with eight 10 12 38 26 members uh
yet no one ever uh you know i sat down
and and talked with with a mickey
edwards a congressional scholar and a
former congressman from oklahoma and we
were talking about cheney and and he
said uh well you know had the same sort
of
moderately conservative record that i
have and when i started reading the
votes off he said you know i forgot that
and his demeanor always covered much of
that uh he was also never you know he
was i think he was
i think he's a terrifically uh uh
smart guy and it's all in the book i
mean you could you know get it all out
of the book uh he's uh you know he's one
of the most
one of the most brilliant process
politicians of our time
he he never he never joined uh newt
gingrich and vinn weber and and and the
the
conservative opportunity society and
and the the bomb throwers who who sort
of seized the night and did the and and
and and took
control of the special orders what
speeches are they special order speeches
at night uh he was he was a he
he he behaved very much like a moderate
until the moment that he saw that they
had that they had taken over and then he
invited he invited them into the
uh and the name of the group that he led
the house republican
the
leadership one of the big leadership
conferences though
and i'm i'm stumped but i was i was
watching alexa i was watching election
returns at 1 45 in the morning and
haven't slept a lot since uh but but he
he never he he was very smart and never
and never taking a great risk and
identifying with newt and and the bomb
throwers until until uh and who took
over in 94 until it was evident they
were going to take over 94 by which time
he was on to the
to uh to serve as secretary of defense
should i just keep talking you want to
tell about the negotiating his
negotiating uh postures particularly in
the soviet uh
there was there yeah there was um
and now i've got my foley's confused
there's mark there's mark
there's tom
and there's a democrat
tom foley no no
no from new york
audience participation moment uh
downey that's why tom downey
it was a long night of watching
elections uh in in uh in in 84 uh uh
dick cheney was was a real a genuine
cold warrior and and really believed in
in almost uh
every every missile system that was that
was proposed and and you know ultimately
had a part in in the dissolution of the
collapse of the soviet union i think but
but there was an interesting moment when
he was not with not when he was with
neither mark foley nor tom foley but he
was with tom downey in 1984 and they it
was the first code the first
congressional delegation trip to moscow
and um
and
because of because since 79 because of
tensions involving afghanistan so they
were invited to speak to the to the to
the number three uh uh leader in the
soviet union at the time whose name i
won't dare because it's it's russian uh
uh martial acromerev and uh and he
made a remarkable offer to them he said
that he would like to see uh
uh he would like to see arms
negotiations begin he would like the u.s
to to consider to consider
discussions of stopping testing of the
amex for which the soviets in return
would would would stop testing a weapon
system and they were they wouldn't they
wanted to consider deploy weapons
deployment in
in um
in in in
in eastern europe and western europe
uh they stepped out together into the
into the sunlight in moscow and and uh
tom downey told his story and dick
cheney said it never happened
he said that there was no such offer
made
that that tom downey had had uh who's a
a clear-headed seasoned
congressman at this time tom downey had
misinterpreted what had been offered and
there was no offer on behalf of the
soviets to to reopen arms negotiations
and and in fact it was all a mistake
uh tom told me they had a discussion
later and in which he said well it was
all said and he said
he tom sort of went through it there was
a junior state department person with
him as there would be with any codel to
a a a
to a russian a a soviet leader
uh
and uh and he said well there's there
are no there's dick cheney said there is
no negotiation with these people
and and tom downey said arnold doesn't
are negotiations by negotiations do you
mean imposing your will on them do you
expect them to surrender and he said
that's what i expect they'll surrender
and there was so there was going to be
no negotiation he was not going to be a
party to it
later that night
the two of them walked out onto red
square together just the two of them and
and despite their ideological
differences they became they had become
good friends they walked out under red
square together and and and he describes
it
a former congressman down he describes
it as a spectacular clear cool night in
moscow and he said that he said dick
what are you thinking what are you
thinking and dick cheney said i think
we're standing on ground zero and uh
even as a casual comment you know here
here was uh the future vice president
united states who didn't believe in in
negotiations who believed that
negotiation was imposing your will on on
your on your adversary
and uh and who who you know who had
bombs going off on his head in 1984
uh so now it's i suppose time for jake
to interview me or me to interview jake
and we'll continue uh and then we'll
we'll we'll quit soon and we'll take
questions and and argument
[Music]
yeah i just want to follow up on what he
was saying about the new negotiation
posture because it fast forward to today
and uh and we have iran and actually
right after uh
the invasion of iraq when we've torn
through the country and and routed
saddam and and actually it looked like
we had done pretty well there for about
five seconds um but the iranians were
sufficiently disturbed by how fast we
had moved uh that they went to the swiss
ambassador uh
as a as an intermediary to approach the
united states and say we want to
negotiate and not only do we want to
negotiate but everything is on the table
we'll we'll talk about our nuclear
program we'll talk about uh al qaeda uh
and and prisoner exchanges uh we'll talk
about everything and um
cheney uh from from our sources told us
uh not only put the kibosh on
negotiating with iran at that time even
though they were they were
approaching us in a posture that was was
less than belligerent uh it was it was
almost uh
as a supplicant to some degree um
cheney said not only uh will we not do
that but then they they reprimanded the
swiss ambassador for getting involved
so it it's uh
the same thing uh pretty much happened
uh with korea we we heard that uh when
there was a negotiating in uh with korea
north korea that we would um
that the the principals would agree
powell and and and dr rice and and
cheney and and bush would all agree on a
negotiating posture and then cheney
would come in at the end and talk
directly to the negotiator and say no in
fact you can't uh say any of these
things uh really there's not much that
that we're willing to negotiate at all
so it's he's been very consistent in
that respect and and unfortunately i
think we see the results of that but
here you have a guy who has been uh
you know he was in congress he was in
the white house as a young man uh he's a
a masterful bureaucratic warrior and he
really uh before he accepted the the
vice presidency or officially accepted
the vice presidency uh i think he gave
it a lot of thought and and how it would
work and uh and one sort of tiny example
of that and and i think david addington
was part of that dating david addington
had run his uh his uh presidential
exploratory committee uh when he was
thinking about running for president in
96 so they had been thinking about the
way that you would run a white house uh
for some time dreaming about it in fact
and and he had
he had thought about the office of the
vice president
which is a very interesting office
because it's not
um it's not technically a part of the
executive uh in the constitution it's
it's actually the ceremonial uh uh
president of the of the senate and uh
and and more a part of the congress in a
lot of ways than it is a part of the
white house and cheney and addington
have exploited that
unbelievably and some of you probably
remember
al gore's famous statement no
controlling legal authority and and
cheney and addington have uh have really
taken that to heart um
as as since they're not technically
members of the executive they're they're
not subject to foia because they're
members of congress and and congress is
not subject to foia
but because he's ceremonial head of the
president of the senate uh the senate
doesn't really have any rules that
govern the vice president's office so
he's not really under the control of the
senate either
and so you have this kind of
liminal
no man's land of an office and so they
have been unwilling to release the most
basic information about how the office
of the vice president actually works
you know what how many staffers they
have what their budget is how many
documents they've classified sort of
information that you would think the
american people would have a right to
know but but chaney has has figured out
this sort of loophole uh involving his
office and and refuses to to release
this information
and part of it is just as a man who has
tremendous knowledge really knows how
the system works believes that there
should be a strong executive has uh i
think uh an authoritarian bent
and uh and so all of that sort of came
uh to a climax uh in his vice presidency
and and created what we believe to be
the most powerful vice president in the
history of our country
so maybe we could uh what do you think
about opening up to some questions here
we could take questions we could go on
for another couple of hours
we could do another we could do more to
stump the audience by giving long last
names of memories of the house and
having you answered why don't we do the
questions
come on
you got any questions none
i i have a question
how much do you think that cheney was
involved in the
uh resignation or uh removal from office
of russia today
boy that's a good one
uh you know uh
how much was dick cheney involved in the
in the resignation of of uh or of donald
rumsfeld today
you know he was he was i think i think
rumsfeld i think to answer that question
is to not answer the question
don remsfield was was in office in part
for as long as he was because the bush's
astounding sense of loyalty but also
because uh
he was he was he was dick cheney's rabbi
he was his godfather he was to be to be
ecumenical uh he was uh you know he was
his patron from the very beginning uh
they're the fam they're close friends
they dine together they've bought uh
compounds together out on the eastern
shore uh you know i i think that that
that uh that it must have been uh in
many ways today must have been a
difficult day for dick cheney because i
don't think that he wanted
uh that you know they share the same
mind and the same philosophy
i don't think i certainly don't think he
would he would have gone in and said to
the president it's time for don rumsfeld
to go so if you're hunting with him
today beware
a cheap shot
he did he did come to texas and shoot
the finest republican in our state harry
whittington who is a a man without peer
and in in public public services service
in
could you just texas a little bit about
the current administration and what he's
uh done uh uh recently do you want to
repeat the question
sure
i mean there's
the question was can we talk about the
the current administration what he's
done uh recently uh there's there's so
much to talk about i mean we could just
take torture for example which has been
a a a an issue close to cheney's heart
he's been uh
he's
he's been um in several ways yes i'm
sorry about that he's he's he's been a
big proponent of of
of of of allowing the the president to
to order uh coercive uh interrogation uh
techniques
um
there was a a legislative battle over
that uh one that john mccain and and
lindsey graham
had thought they had won um and then uh
cheney uh well through addington
the president issued a a
a signing statement that that seemed to
minimize that and then of course we have
the military commissions act cheney has
been incredibly influential uh in in the
torture debate and what's interesting
about that is that if you talk to uh
professional interrogators
they will tell you that torture is
really not the best way to get
information um that they're the it's
much better to to try uh to use a sort
of good cop bad cop
befriend uh the person you're
interrogating and bring them over to
your side um
so why the emphasis on the ability to
torture is especially when people will
say uh that it it endangers our troops
in the field because if if we're doing
uh if we're if we're using interrogation
techniques uh like waterboarding and
things like that uh then certainly those
could be used on our soldiers if they're
captured
um and it comes down again to uh to the
executive authority you know and and and
what happened in the ford administration
to some degree cheney believes uh it
doesn't matter i think so much whether
torture is an effective means of
interrogation or not cheney believes
that the the the executives should have
that authority
and that's something that the president
should be able to order if he believes
it's necessary and that there shouldn't
be any oversight over that so i think
that's really what that's about and so
much of what has happened in the past
six years uh is along those lines
whether it's the energy task force and
lou can can speak uh
quite a bit about that um or or any
number of of issues that are going on
right now freedom of information act and
whether documents should be released
comes down to cheney's conception of
what
a wartime president should be allowed to
do
what explains
um
what explains that the the uh cheney's
uh
influence with the president uh i think
a lot of it has really has to do with
experience i i mean uh george bush for
all of his personal political talents
and his enormous seductive ability in
sort of a one-on-one relationship with
with members of the texas legislature
although there hasn't been much
seduction going on with with with a
congress for which he hold that he holds
in very low regard the institution uh i
just think that i think that there was
just an enormous experience
that that not just cheney but the entire
staff in the office the vice presidency
had
that that it was it was almost
inevitable that they were going to suck
all the oxygen out of the out of the
west wing
i mean these are guys you know this dick
cheney was was was uh uh kneecapping
henry kissinger and ending the career of
of
of nelson rockefeller when george bush
was was playing pickup basketball to
downtown hawaii and houston because i
was there and he couldn't go to the
right uh
believe it or not uh i mean so so you
have uh
i mean you have you have this you have
this team this incredibly experienced
team
and you have these you have a team that
comes in from from
from texas and a president who's
determined it seems to to of skew all
advice from his and and assistance from
his from adult adult supervision from
his father's administration i just think
it was natural that they were going to
take over
and and also i think
bush puts a premium on on on loyalty
and and one thing that that cheyney is
is he's loyal he he's you you have a
conversation with cheney in the oval
office you will not be reading about it
in the newspapers which bush has said
repeatedly is something that he really
values and and i think that that was
very important
for bush
he felt that he could count on cheney
that cheney wasn't going to go
off the reservation and and and sort of
have these back alley fights uh that
were gonna spill out into the press and
make uh bush look bad cheney would never
say anything uh directly that would make
bush look bad and i think uh for bush
that was really important
yeah of course there's um
who's who's leading who here who's been
loyal to who i mean is cheyney actually
the one with the reigns but um the other
question is is uh the profiteering from
the war and anyone who's seen this um
movie lately uh iraq for sale i mean it
is just gut wrenching to see what is
going on and and halliburton is very
much one of the
you know the ones that is accused of
profiteering and of course you think
halliburton you think cheney so
what about the connection there i think
there's a clear connection uh
you know uh the i mean beyond beyond the
profits at halliburton it was in his
final act as one of his final acts as
secretary of defense and and uh to give
him credit if you if you talk to
active or retired brass at the pentagon
everyone considers him perhaps the
finest modern secretary of defense uh
not so anymore because the same people
will tell you that he's also left the
army badly broken it will take a number
of reconstitution bills and generations
to fix it that's not the answer to the
question uh the answer to the question
is that he he created the mechanism with
halliburton as secretary defense by
which these contracts are left uh as he
was at the end of the bush administ with
the first bush administration the one we
in texas consider the good bush
administration um uh uh he um
dick cheney uh secretary of defense
cheney uh commissioned halliburton uh to
write a report it's i think it started
at 3.9 million and then there was an
additional five million to write a
report and a contingency plan that would
basically establish how uh
what we consider the quartermaster
function of the army could be outsourced
so uh halliburton uh got the co
wrote the contingency report and then in
in in in a violation at least of this
the spirit of protocols of contracting
protocols then they bid on the contract
and it is the contract is known as the
log cap contract uh an acronym but it's
logistics contract that they that they
still have in iraq today so there is a
direct link and and you know did he do
it because he was going to halliburton
well i don't know but halliburton hired
him shortly thereafter uh in part for
his rolodex and i don't think they hired
him to thank him i just think that it
was a it was a good a nice coincidence
and then michael mobs
yeah uh
what kind of role cheyney had in in the
awarding of of subsequent uh halliburton
contracts uh
really big ones you know billions of
dollars uh is an open question and one
that that uh maybe henry waxman will
have a better uh luck in ferreting out
the answer to but uh he did say on meet
the press uh cheney did that uh that he
had absolutely no role whatsoever in in
the awarding of those iraqi contracts to
halliburton his former company um
well we we we discovered uh that in fact
uh uh scooter libby had been consulted
before those contracts were awarded and
had been apprised of negotiations and
what was going on
so it it sort of defies
uh belief that uh that that libby who
wrote to work with cheney every day
they and their wives dined together they
were very very close they had known each
other for decades uh would not have
mentioned to the vice president that uh
they were seriously considering giving
a huge sort of unprecedented contract to
his former company
i have a question about the energy task
force that you mentioned in full
disclosure i work for a nuclear
information and resource service which
is a anti-nuclear group here in dc
but the secrecy that you mentioned
before that none of the meetings of the
task force are knowable
and like you said the executive branch
is
foia ebola and natural resources defense
council foia the energy secretary
on who he met with in the lead up to the
cheney energy task force the nuclear
power industry was the biggest
number of meetings it was 19 meetings
with the energy secretary in a matter of
january february march april may of 01
and then after that was big oil at about
10. so i'm just curious about you know
the role of nuclear energy institute on
the energy task force ken lay on the
energy task force and
what do you think about all that
well i think it was unprecedented
secrecy uh for for a
uh for what should have been the make
what was the making of of of lasting
public policy it started uh you know 20
days into the bush administration
the uh the
the meetings were arranged so
there's the fact that the federal
advisory committee's
commissions act thank you carolyn the
federal advisory commissions act
would generally require a group when a
group of lobbyists it does require by
law when a group of lobbyists sits down
with with a met with a member of
administration
that should there's it requires
transparency
they by by by including one or two
members of uh of the administration in
every meeting they created they they
circumvented that law uh that what we do
know from it we know because of of
judicial watch and the nrdc who who
first did foia's and and then when they
couldn't get for us
from the executive agencies went to
court starting in gladys kessler's court
judge kessler's court and litigated it
until that some of those names were
finally released uh what do we know i
guess in in dick cheney's memoirs we'll
get the whole story uh
and and and you know ultimately or and
and congressman henry waxman's uh
subpoena uh request will get more of
that information because it was
congressman waxman who first who first
uh asked for those names and for the
meeting notes and and he never got them
uh i think
an aside there and in ken lay kendall
showed up on one day in april cheney
cleared his calendar he knew ken lay
from uh from texas we all know we all
know now can lay from texas the lake can
lay from texas uh
he cleared his calendar they met they
talked about price caps in california
the next day the very next day
the vice president a vice president who
is known to be averse to talking to the
press
calls the uh
the la times sacramento bureau out of
the blue uh this this beef reporter gets
uh and columnist gets a call and says
would you like to speak to the vice
president of the united states
he says yes and he and he and he and
dick cheney gets on the phone and he
beats this guy on the head with ken
lay's talking points which were no price
caps in california
uh no no regulation of the california
market the california legislature had
made their own mess but but enron was
was making four to four to six hundred
percent increase in profits while while
california while people were going
without lights whether brownouts uh
electricity rates were up three to five
to fifteen hundred percent and and the
vice president of the united states on
the day after he met with ken lay did
his bidding and only was saved by by by
by the fed by ferc who who ruled in
favor of
which ruled ultimately favor prize camps
yes well speaking of beating people over
the head um
dick cheney i although i haven't read it
yet john dean in his book uh
conservatives without conscience talks
about the authoritarian personality
and you know from everything that you're
describing you know beating people on
the head torture
ground zero rejecting iran's offers
letting
death and suffering you know i guess we
would say
that he's uh sadistic sociopathic uh
ruthless
um
i mean mean cruel
and so
i mean it's not really yeah i guess
there's a question of how we get people
like this to lead us and maybe now
hopefully we're
less vulnerable to that but my question
is how did he get to be that like what
about his life his childhood um what do
you know about
how he got to be like that
you know sometimes you wonder if it
didn't have something to do with a
little league
uh you know he was a star football
player he was a star football player it
it is a puzzlement uh i mean um
he uh
you know i've written about bush before
but dick cheney is a much more
interesting character because he has a
much more interesting character arc
uh he was he he was
you know a hardened conservative by by
sort of a congenital conservative i
think because he was born in wyoming of
conservative parents but you know i
think he he showed up in madison uh when
when in this in the 60s when uh when
campus unrest was was was really scary
for a guy who believed in conservative
american values and was from wyoming he
was disturbed by that i i just i i don't
i don't know i i mean we didn't try to
get uh too much inside his head
um
but his family of origin his parents and
you know he had
a normal upbringing
can you say and they were new dealers
they weren't yeah his parents were
democrats his his dad was his dad was a
bureaucrat and and and and and a
democrat who who ultimately like much of
the west gradually flipped and not
flipped but converted to to
republicanism and and which was a better
fit for the conservative west i think
that might be changing too uh but uh
it's it's it's a bewilderment uh maybe
jake is uh has a few more ideas but
maybe not
can you tell us anything about the
relationship between cheney and gates
and what cheney may be
looking for in his secretary of defense
and who his choice might have been i
don't i'm
unfortunately it's it's a little bit too
early to tell what went into the gates
decision uh gates is certainly someone
who who they would be comfortable with i
would think he's got a lot of texas
connections um you know he has a the
intelligent stuff he he worked with uh
with with bush's father he's someone who
might be able to bridge the two
uh you know those two worlds the world
of cheney
and the world
of of george bush senior um
i don't know i mean i i think that that
that cheney was probably sorry to see
rumsfeld go
um and and how much he was a factor in
the gates decision uh is something that
the reporters are really going to have
to fare it out
uh i i i don't know even more than jake
doesn't know but but i have a friend in
the audience who's pointing me in in the
right direction
i mean we're looking at the return of of
the adults from the first bush
administration we're looking at james
you know james baker is is back and he's
going to have to he's going to have to
paper over the the disaster and it
really is nothing less than a public
policy and a foreign policy disaster in
iraq and and brent scowcroft is always
is always pushing the right the right
candidates and and people who are are
capable of really serious adult
supervision into the white house and and
and it seems like perhaps they they
finally uh with with today's decision
uh succeeded what's interesting is how
how it was just a vertical collapse i
mean they could have waited a couple of
days to save face but the day after the
election
uh
you know it was remarkable it was just
it was it was a it's it's one of those i
mean we really this is this this is one
of these remarkable moments in american
political history that really see has
the feel of of a tectonic
shift of the place now what happens over
the next year with this place grinding
uh remains to be seen but it's it's a
different morning we woke up to today in
washington well i was awake with it at
three in the morning anyway but it is a
different more morning which probably
shows but uh there we go
stepping backward could you give us any
insight into what cheney's role might
have been in preparing
america
uh before 9 11 and preparing america for
9 11.
well he was briefed bush wasn't uh you
know in in in in you know
and richard clark's book you you have uh
you know you have cheney in in the in
the in the presidential emergency uh
center at the bunker under the under the
east wing and you feel like the right
guy is there uh george bush's is is
reading to a class in in florida
elementary school class in florida you
know he did that a lot when he was
governor
he did i'm serious he did those reading
circles again and again and again i mean
i went to so many of them and he and
laura were reading to kids and i thought
well that was good but we got a state to
run here you know we got an
environmental crisis but but you had the
sense that the right guy was there he
had he had been briefed on both the
clinton plan and he had been briefed on
the the clinton back
plan on on on al qaeda and he had been
briefed on on uh the richard clark's
clark's current plan
and and you had um uh condi rice had
been briefed uh colin powell had been
briefed yet the yet the president of the
united states who was who was reading to
a group of children in california had
not so i think he was he was the man he
was florida i'm sorry uh one of those
long states uh he was uh
he was um
he was the right guy in the right place
i think and he was he was there at that
moment and i i feel a little better
knowing that he was there rather than
rather than my former governor
okay let's take the two questions too
many lines of last few questions okay we
brief i'm just wondering if you could
talk more about the relationship between
cheney and uh kissinger because there
seems to be something in terms of
cheney's reaction to the real politique
that kissinger was putting out and then
cheney's conversion to a more neocon
perspective and i wonder if that'll give
us some insight as to how cheyney may
react or what his relationship was with
baker in uh bush 1.
i'll start and we'll
kick it over to luke uh that's a a meaty
question from frank smythe again why
could i just add sure sure
gristle to it as well um uh what about
the relationship between cheney and bush
senior i'd be interested to if you could
fold that into your answer as well i'd
be interested in that
that was
adding to that as well i mean one of the
defining interim scene political battles
in the 70s was the antipathy between
cheney and rumsfeld on the one hand and
hw
bush on the other and even in the first
bush administration
when cheney was selected as sec-def
there was some murmurings about that and
that came up so i guess i guess all i
think all of us are sort of asking the
same thing which is
when you look at the relationship
between hw w cheney and rumsfeld
uh
when you guys
were researching the book i mean what
were you able to glean any new insights
as to how these people how all of them
have related
to and with one another at various
points in time in the context the
kissinger one is is a very interesting
one because
there was not a lot of love between uh
rumsfeld and cheney and kissinger in the
ford administration i mean uh they
cheney and rumsfeld felt that kissinger
was too soft on the soviets uh and they
they were not big fans of ditant and and
they didn't uh they were they were
constantly i mean there was a an orgy of
leaking going on in the ford
administration which is
another irony that relates to today but
a lot of them were leaks against
kissinger and there was a lot of
suspicion within the white house that
they were coming from rumsfeld and
cheney
um
as a way to sort of undercut him and in
fact with the halloween massacre when
when when they named bush
to head the c.i.a and rumsfeld was moved
up to secretary of defense for the first
time kissinger uh had his dual role he
was secretary of state and national
security adviser and they stripped the
national security adviser away from him
and named scotchroft instead um
in his stead so it it there there was a
lot of there wasn't a lot of good
feelings about that but then you have uh
woodward's book which just came out that
says that they have been consulting with
kissinger uh which in and of itself is
is kind of interesting and and some of
that i think uh does go back to
to to to vietnam
kissinger kind of escaped vietnam uh
relatively clean uh it ended up being
other people's faults at fault and not
really kissingers
and so i think that as as we're mired in
in a war that's not going particularly
well um that is starting to create an
iraqi syndrome uh to displace the
vietnam syndrome um that they might be
looking to kissinger for for his insight
and and and my guess is that that's
probably been uh difficult for cheney uh
to stomach to some degree because uh he
at least when he was a young man in his
thirties he felt that he knew better
than kissinger um at least when it came
to uh to foreign policy vis-a-vis the
soviets um the relationship with
with george bush senior is is a complex
one as well i mean there's certainly
been a
you know the people around uh poppy bush
have have been very critical of of
foreign policy and have said that
they're very disappointed with cheney uh
when he was secretary of defense he was
a great as as lou said uh a fine
secretary of defense but he was on a
short leash
and i think that was part of the uh
why people were so surprised when he had
a long leash sort of absolute power to
some degree operating out of the vice
president's office
that
that he went in the directions that that
he ended up going and i think it was a
surprise to a lot of people um including
uh george bush george h bush and his
conclusion in conclusion
can i conclude uh not not to not to
agree too much with my esteemed
colleague the nobel prize peace prize is
not an exoneration
i think he
i mean
he does bear some considerable
responsibility for for for vietnam i do
think that jake touched upon what is the
the the the real irony that a a man who
started out
who who stood outside his west wing
office as nixon ordered troops out of
as forward order troops out of out of uh
out of of vietnam and and and watched
the presidency collapse with a promise
to someday rebuild it was really they
when you get into the personal
psychological stuff that's what scar
dick cheney not not little league uh you
know watch watch the uh watch the
presidency collapse under the weight of
of watergate and resolving then to to
build rebuild this imperial presidency
has if the one one particular general i
talked to said the army is broken the
troops are broke the equipment is broke
i talked to someone at the cia's who
said he went out there 13 times and he
beat up on our third eight to 15 times
and beat up on our analysts the agency
is a fragile bureaucracy it's also broke
so the imperial presidency that he set
out to to to to of restore seem to have
uh it seemed to have come to a
completely opposite end and with that i
should thank you and turn uh the
microphone over to barbara who is
gracious enough to have diana of an
investigation into the april 20th
deepwater horizon oil rig explosion that
incident led to the deaths of 11 workers
and triggered the ongoing oil spill in
the gulf of mexico we've been hearing
today from several workers who were
aboard the rig when it exploded live
coverage on c-span 3. last name
h-a-i-r-e
and by whom are you employed sir
halliburton
and what position do you hold with
halliburton service supervisor i'm sorry
what was that service supervisor
and how long have you held that position
for two years two years yes sir
had you had any previous oil and gas
experience prior to that
no sir
can you what is your educational
background
high school graduate and two years of
college
can you please just briefly describe
your day-to-day operations on deepwater
horizon what you're responsible for
uh we do uh high pressure monitoring
fluid pumping cement
and um
you know
just
various pumping operations
have you had any uh did you actually do
the cement job on the 97 978 production
casino no sir i was not out on the right
have you had any uh special c-man
training are you are you responsible for
any cement of any production case is
there any casing in the well no sir oh
i'm sorry i'm sorry could you repeat the
question are you responsible for any
cementing of any casing within the well
yes sir i did do a couple of cement jobs
for the well which ones were those
um
i did the
13 and 5 8
eleven and seven eighths
and the nine seven eighths
do you know who did the uh production
case in cement job
uh yes that was my co-worker vince
tabler vince haywood tabler
what time how long have you been on your
hitch at the deepwater horizon at the
time day of the incident
that was my first day
all right can you what time did you
arrive sir
um around 11. okay can you briefly take
me through your day up to the time of
the incident
see i arrived on the rig around 11 00
a.m
at the time they were finishing up a
positive test
i uh
i made my way
to the uh cement room
and helped finish cleaning up
from the uh
from the casing test
and see
after that we
[Music]
probably around two o'clock that
afternoon we
displaced the
the semen and the choke line with sea
water just to clean it out
and tested our lines for the negative
test to
3000 psi
around
five o'clock we were
requested on our cma unit for
the negative test to monitor the well
um
after the
first attempt we were we were
unsatisfied with it
um
we were still getting flow we
were i was directed to shut in from the
well
at that point
pressure increased to 1400 psi
around five minutes later i was
instructed to
by the driller to open up from the well
[Music]
i've got about
15 barrels back
and was instructed to shut in from the
well again
pressure what time was that around just
to give me a time here
probably
around seven o'clock
um
after after shutting in from the second
time
some 45 minutes had passed
at this point i
i made my way up to the rig floor
just to bring some equipment for the
cement job that would be needed up there
it was the next operation that would
take place
at that point i was instructed by the
driller and tool pusher that they had
achieved a successful negative test on
the rig floor
and to go ahead and get our uh our job
procedure ready for the surface plug
uh at that point we we made our way down
to the uh to our office in the living
quarters
and um
started the revision on the the cement
job procedure
during the process of printing that out
we
we lost power
from the first explosion
a fire alarm went off
at that point i grabbed my boots and
hard hat started my way out the door
when the
second bigger explosion occurred
and
you know
just
got
knocked uh
down the hallway into the uh into the
galley
um you know at that point
it's a little fuzzy but you know i don't
remember much but
we uh
we made our way out to the uh muster
station
and just um i waited for further
instructions from there
all right
we uh
i'm sorry did someone say something
you know we then boarded the lifeboats
okay
um
were you uh
on board when they actually did the uh
production case and cement job no sir i
was not
but vince was yes sir
had he discussed anything about that
casing job cement job on that casing
with you
no sir he had not um
we
in your day-to-day operations did the bp
company man and uh was venture boss i'm
sorry or is it yes sir did they have any
uh day-to-day communication with each
other to your recollection
between the bp well site leader and the
yeah not just the date of 20th in your
duration at the well site
yes sir
they did
who is that person that met with the uh
your boss
from bp
i'm sorry who is the company
representative from bp that dealt with
the cementing procedures
um
i i do not know that uh
[Music]
were you aware of any changes uh that
might have happened during the duration
of the well on any cement jobs
no sir
[Music]
were you aware of any issues with the
well during the duration of your time
out of water horizon
lost returns
yes sir there were a um
a couple of a couple of sections there
where we lost returns was there any
sections where they had gas cut mud
i do not know
you said you were working on procedure i
guess to set the surface plug did you
normally
review the procedure or did you just
implement the procedure
that was given to you we would we would
review the procedure double check
calculations and then go over it with
the bp well site leader
and that procedure was solely for the
surface plug yes sir
in that procedure um
was there any mention of displacing the
riser
no sir so you were just solely going to
be set in the cemetery that's correct
i have no further questions
i just want to ask you a couple
questions about the cement strings you
did set the nine and seven eights which
is a line or right eleven yes sir seven
eights thirteen five eighths were
they're all liners
yes sir okay
uh
and i assume they all had the uh
check valves on the bottom
you know where you're running the cement
yes sir they did do you run them in with
those
valves pinned open so that you can feel
the liners
uh it i do not know i mean that that
varies uh do you have to pump something
before you start seeming to share those
pins
oh yes sir they do okay
and the ones you have experience with
these three different liners when you
drop the ball or dart whatever it is you
used to share those pins
did you have any difficulty sharing the
pins
uh no sir i i do not care about those
operations i'm not
you weren't aware of the operations on
sharing the pins
no sir okay thank you
good afternoon sir i just have a couple
of questions and in particular i'd like
to ask you a little bit about uh when
you
went through and started to prepare for
abandon ship um now you indicated you
just gotten on board that morning is
that correct yes sir how many hitches
prior to that edge you had
on the horizon
i'd been out there for
about 18 months so
and during the course of those 18 months
did you participate in fire and abandon
ship drills yes sir okay
on the day in question here as you
proceeded to your um your lifeboat
station which one was that
um lifeboat number one okay could you
describe for us you know what you saw
what you experienced was there confusion
what was going on
uh when i got out to the lifeboats there
was panic uh a little bit of confusion
some people wanted to just get on the
boats and go others wanted to collect a
muster and find out if a search and
rescue would be needed
i mean it was i mean just panic really
uh
you know but we got 115 people off the
rig safely so i mean
in your opinion uh lifeboat girls were
typically conducted pretty much the same
time all the time
yes sir based on your experience same
time of day same day yes sir okay do you
think that helped you in preparing for
this particular evacuation or do you
think it would have been better to
possibly vary it and have unannounced
times for lifeboat drills
i believe maybe some uh
some unannounced times for the lifeboat
drills
but i felt that you know that that
training did contribute to getting
everybody off the rig safely or as many
people as we did
during the course in which you uh had
that training did you ever participate
in actually loading the lifeboats at all
uh yes sir we did you did
do you recall how many times possibly
i believe just once and i can recall did
you practice lowering the lifeboats
i i personally did not know sir
did you witness them actually being
lowered yes sir okay did you feel
comfortable with the procedures and and
your responsibilities as far as getting
the lifeboat station and getting on
board the boat yes sir i did
in this particular occasion do you
recall who was in charge of your
lifeboat on that day
um
i do not recall
now according to your statement here you
indicated that uh the lifeboat was in
the water at approximately 1 or excuse
me 10 15.
most of the testimony we have indicates
that the explosion or the first
explosion likely took place roughly at
21 30 45 so approximately within 30
minutes the lifeboat was launched is
that you know your recollection as well
i don't believe it took that long um
you know it was we were maybe out there
for for 10 minutes
maybe 15 at the most would you describe
it as proceeding despite the chaos
somewhat orderly
uh
i wouldn't call it orderly but
close to
thank you i have no further questions
good afternoon
the uh in the statement that mr wheeler
is referring to you also mentioned in
there and i think you just said just a
few minutes ago that you went back to
your you're up on the rig floor and what
what exactly were you doing on the rig
floor there
yeah i think you mentioned some uh
you were you were instructed to do some
things that's correct we were um
we were checking on the status of a
negative test that the rig floor had
performed and at that point they
instructed us to go
down to our room to to revise our semen
procedures
and and get those ready for the um
okay operation meeting and uh so you
were in your state room printing off the
procedures is that the procedures that
comes from the uh the cement plan
or is that something different that's
that's a that's the procedure that comes
from a cement plan okay
and and what's your knowledge of the
cement plan i mean do you know the
details of it prior to hitting print and
then reviewing it is that something
that's given to you well in advance yes
i mean i realize you were just there
that day so right
for that particular job we you know we
double check calculations and uh volumes
uh go back and revise our procedure as
needed um
print it out let the bp well site leader
double check it and if they're okay with
it we'll use that but if they want to
make any revisions that's where we go
back and
make our corrections okay so you'll
print out will you you get together as a
group then have some type of
safety meeting or something is that
where you go through that review yes sir
that's correct okay can you um
have you participated in one of those
reviews before
yes sir can you just kind of generally
tell us what it's like i mean do you
lead that discussion
yes sir i do leave that discussion just
generally how how's that go
basically we we meet in the bp well site
leader office where we discuss
the sequence of steps in between fluids
that we're going to pump rates that
we'll be pumping
and um and then volumes okay
and and these um when you're
when you're going through that is this
almost like a presentation you're making
it to the well site leader yes sir and
then he or she can then say no no no
let's let's go this way let's do this
this is what the well this is what we've
changed it to or we're altering it to or
adding to it yes sir that's correct okay
and then do you go back to
uh your supervisors and and let them
know hey the company man or someone's
changing this or wanting to change to it
if it's a big change yes we go back to
our supervisor but if it's just
something small
we just make that correction on our own
okay and when you are discussing these
with
the well site leader is that a bp
employee yes sir that's a bb employee
okay do they honor that
work process change
guidelines that transocean has in place
i think it is
or do
does the bp employee just simply
this is what we want and if it's not too
far off then you guys
give it the the blessing and just go
with it
i
you know i really i'm not really sure
about the the transition methods just if
they
if if they
agree with it we go with it okay
all right good enough uh before you came
up i mentioned i wanted to show you a
chart or a diagram of the the rig i'm
going to get that up and kind of like to
have you just identify where you're at
so thank you sir
uh level two
i was in uh
this is our room right here
i'm sorry
let me just
yes please
thank you
what what room number are you in
um 231 okay
now um
231
[Music]
so
again this is where you came down you
were printing off the well or excuse me
the cement procedures that you were
hoping to go into a meeting here shortly
with the well site leader is that right
yes sir okay
now i'm curious just to let you know
where i'm going with this you know
there's there's a few of you that were
on board the rig that can actually tell
us what type of damage was done to the
accommodations you know i'm interested
in finding out the condition of the
accommodations as you were leaving you
know when you heard these explosions can
you tell me
what you saw what you heard
uh what you felt things of that nature
um after the explosion i was right i was
about right here in the hallway okay and
um
you know that knocked me and i went
through this wall
and into the galley now did something
hit you or was it a percussion that came
through it was a
percussion okay
so there wasn't anything that physically
you know like a a
piece of a bulkhead or a chair
or a locker okay
when i stood up and you know got my
bearings and looked back this way
there were walls beds i could see
into the sac room so it
blew everything okay
all right
okay and then uh
when you got up what did you do then
um there are a bunch of people coming
out of these rooms here we helped get
them over the uh over the debris
and then the uh the sprinklers are also
a bit slippery
and uh let's see we came around
around this way down the hallway and out
to the monster station okay tell me
about that sprinkler system so the
sprinkler system is firefighting uh
is that right yes sir okay was there
fire in the accommodations um not to my
knowledge there's a lot of smoke but i
didn't i didn't see any fire black smoke
white smoke grey smoke
it was pitch black i i really couldn't
tell what color smoke was okay did you
have flashlight with you
no sir was
any of the emergency lighting that's
usually up on the bulkheads the top
bulkheads were any of those on
no sir okay was there any low level
lighting along the
deck that would help direct you to the
lifeboat station
uh no sir how about any
fluorescent tape or anything like that
kind of
pointing you to a direction yeah there
was some fluorescent tape did it work
yes sir i could see it okay and
did you know how to get there because of
your training and running through the
drills or was that just where people
were going and you were following
from from the drills i knew where to go
do you have your life jacket
uh no sir where'd you get that at
outside okay so you proceeded through um
now did you see uh what the galley
looked like as you're going by
yes sir how was that what did it look
like
the galley was pretty intact actually i
just just the walls right here
the the integrity was gone i mean i
went through there but you know what i
got up and i could see in the galley it
wasn't
it didn't
you know get that bad okay what about
the deck that you were walking on was it
damaged in any way buckled or
um you know i really don't recall
there's so much debris over it i mean it
was just hopping over beds and
walls could you identify what the debris
was on the floor
just just walls and beds and desks did
it look like any of the ceiling tiles or
insulation
uh a little bit yeah there's some
ceiling down too okay so
all right so you made it out to the
lifeboat station which one were you
assigned to i think you said the number
one yes sir the number one okay
when you got there um
did you who was in charge do you know
i think you you asked that before sorry
about that asking the answer uh yes i i
i don't remember who was in charge okay
i'm sorry
the uh
who gave the command to go ahead and get
inside the lifeboats do you remember
or again was it just everyone just kind
of started filtering in
i think for the most part people just
kind of started piling in okay
and when you got him in the lifeboat do
you know how many people were in there
no sir i don't okay was it full
yes sir okay so everyone was sitting
down uh and it was full as far as you
could see and tell yes sir okay
do you remember
was there anyone
uh
telling the person driving the the
vessel or operating the vessel what to
do or was the cox and the person behind
the steering wheel in charge
um
he needed a little bit of assistance but
he uh he got his bearings and was able
to get everything under control okay
um how close
were you in location to the coxswain
were you right next to him or in the
front of the lifeboat
um
i was in the in the back okay is that
near the coxswain yes sir okay what kind
of assistance was being provided to him
and
if you know who that person was
providing him assistance could you tell
us that too i i don't you know i i
really couldn't even tell you what
assistance was being provided to him
i know that he needed help seeing he
couldn't
see out okay was that still up on the
the rig then or was that down once you
guys were launched the way he was
needing assistance that was once we were
in the water okay
prior to the the boat actually lowing
away from uh the rig
was anybody providing him any assistance
at all
um no sir okay nothing i recall good
enough
when you got in uh the lifeboat
did you notice
any other difficult difficulties with
releasing it from the actual pendants
that are holding it down into the water
uh no sir i don't recall okay good
enough and uh then that's where you were
saying the the gentleman the coxswain
was needing assistance just seeing the
head yes sir
did anybody say why he needed assistance
or was everyone just kind of helping out
i think everybody's just kind of helping
out okay good enough all right thank you
very much
i have one further question sir
how long have you been on the deepwater
horizon location at mississippi canyon
252.
how many hitches
uh since february okay
were you uh aware of any other uh
cement jobs uh
that would require any type of uh
advanced uh
person on the rig to do anything to see
many
with nitrogen
yes sir how many were there uh just one
and do you know which
casing that was run on
that was on the uh
nine and seven eight by seven inch
and that do you know who that was
performed by
are you talking company or
person individual uh vincent taylor
vince did that one okay and that was the
only one that you're aware of and that
whole well yes sir thank you
to follow on that question there by mr
matthews
none of the cement jobs up the hole
in any of the shallow portions of the
hole required a nitrogen
uh nitrified cement no sir
thank you
can i can i follow up one brief question
did you test anything else while you're
there like the bops
anything of that nature during that
hitch yeah uh or prior hitches
yes sir we test um we test the vops okay
uh
were you aware of any irregularities
with the bops when you perform the test
no sir everything went fine you weren't
asked to retest any components
no sir
thank you
a question for me um
do you supervise mr stapler vince
stapler
no sir he supervises me okay so
do you have any experience with
nitrogenated uh c-band
work
uh i have i've done one job one job sir
is that is that requires special
knowledge on how to uh
uh perform that uh particular um
activity
i i i wouldn't call it special knowledge
but
you know yes sir um
some experience okay
can you explain how um without going
through proprietary information is that
most most complex uh method
um technique i don't i don't know
anything about cementing can you explain
is it
more complex than any other uh regular
job that you did on
uh for the rest of the um
casing on uh on our end it we actually
do it the exact same we just have a
nitrogen specialist out there
just to monitor rates
of the nitrogen injection
so
i mean
i guess from his perspective yes
okay
and what's it why why is it needed
with the nitrogen uh additive
uh that foams the cement okay is that
because it's way down there
the clearance is small or why is it used
usually for uh when hydrostatic pressure
is a concern
when um
you know you don't want to exceed a flat
gradient
just
you don't want to put too much um
too much weight too much too heavy of
fluid
does it have the same reliability
reliability as
data type cementing yes sir
okay
just one question
you said you were been in the position
for two years sir
yes sir as a super service supervisor
one in a nine and seven agents whole
hole is it easier i mean is it
trying to think do you have a higher
success rate as a cementer to
do a proper cement job on a seven inch
casing or a five inch casing
i would say a five inch casing thank you
state
no questions thank you kevin thank you
sir
hello bernie do you have any questions
for your witness no questions
okay thank you sir
am i swako
[Music]
douglas brown
thank you
bp
thank you sir translation no questions
thank you sir
cameron
thank you
all right
mr hair are there any questions that we
didn't ask you or any information that
you think we should know that relevance
to our investigation that you would like
to tell us this time
no sir
thanks if we need your assistance in the
future would you uh be available to
testify affordable
yes sir okay thank you very much you are
dismissed thank you
the boy we now call mr mouse as a with
transocean
hmm
okay
he's on his way captain
hmm
let's see here
so
[Music]
so
so
um
uh
stay yourself
thank you for being here uh other place
to place you on the old please raise
your right hand yes
a false statement to an agency of the
united states is punishable by fine and
or imprisonment under 18 usc 1001
knowing this you solemnly swear that the
testimony you're about to give this will
be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth of god
thank yourself please
mr ezil for the record could you please
state your name and spell your last
miles randall ezil
and my last name is e-z-e-l-l
sir uh this was reminded um mr conkey is
uh representing transocean uh is that
okay with you yes sir
by whom you're employed
transocean
can you move up to the mic i don't know
if you're yeah
thank you
and what position do you hold with
transocean sir i'm gonna send your tool
pusher
and how long have you had that position
uh approximately four years
and prior to becoming a senior tool
pusher what experience did you have with
transocean or any other oil and gas
company
i've had a total of 33 years offshore
and 23 of those have been with
transocean
can you
briefly describe your responsibilities
as a senior tool pusher at the deepwater
horizon sir
a lot of my responsibilities are
administrative
but
a portion of that is to
support operations wherever needed
and what type of operations are those
like that would be drilling operations
how long have you been assigned to that
rig
um
eight plus years not quite nine
i was one of the original crew members
in 2001.
on the hitch that you were on at the
time of the incident what day did you
arrive on the deepwater horizon
i don't remember the exact day but it
was
approximately a week prior to that
up to the time of the incident were you
made aware of any uh issues with the
well possible loss returns stuck pipe or
anything that you may be aware of
well yes sir i was aware of
lost circulation areas that we had these
what was the last loss circulation that
you were familiar with
um
well during the during the
last week that i was on the right
the well was actually stable we didn't
have any any losses in
was there any stuck pipe in that last
week
no sir not in the last week
how about cement in that production
casino was there any problems that came
in to mine
none that i was
made aware of do you have communication
with the halliburton reps on that rig
yes we talked to him quite frequently
did they have any problems with any test
or any type of sharing the pins of that
production casing
i think we had a
a little bit higher pressure on the shoe
track
than normal but not excessive
can you just uh in the next few minutes
just give me
from the day of the incident up to the
time of the incident which you can
recall
okay starting from that morning right
yes sir please
well we typically um
have a
6 30 meeting
first thing in the morning
that's for the transocean management
and then
after that meeting is over we rose into
a bp
meeting that they have with houston
their morning meeting
and that would have been
approximately 7 30 when that started
and
after that we have a
transition
supervisor meeting that's all the
department has and we have that daily
and that would have started about 8 30.
and
it was pretty extended because we had
talked about
some of the
the issues uh like one program we had
was called a drops program
it was meant to control dropped objects
we went over that
to some degree
but it probably would have lasted
somewhere neighborhood of
an hour hour and 15 minutes
then of course
i made a round
a round deck observed several operations
um
made a trip to the rig floor
came back down and what time was that
right after the 8 30 meeting uh that
would have been
when i was out on deck it could have
been somewhere around
10 15 to
10 45 something like that
and then um
of course we had lunch
i talked to jimmy harold oh i am
ex pretty extensively we were
going over our 2010 rig goals and making
sure that we were updated on that
uh
we had a vip group that that came out
from bp and transocean
um
we were going to have a
general tour of the rig with those
individuals and several of the
department heads
and
we did conduct that tour
um
we went to several different areas on
the rig
one of the last areas that we went to
was
the rig floor
where they were already conducting the
negative test
and
the first of the second
the first negative test the first
negative test
and uh
tour group left
and left
jimmy harrell
and myself there
because they were having
a little bit of a problem
um who
the drill crew
conducting that test
and
we observed that
they had lost some mud in the
riser
and
i witnessed jimmy
tell the subsea engineer the senior
subsidy engineer
to increase the pressure on the annual
and
when he did increase that pressure
it became static
they
of course filled the riser up
we monitored and made sure everything
was 100 percent
and it was like i say static
um
the other uh
tool pusher that would was coming on at
at uh 5 30
jason anderson had came on at that time
and he and his relief
wyman wheeler were
discussing you know the events of the
day wyman was briefing him on what was
going on
and
of course the bp company man
bob coluzza and don bidring were there
and they were doing the same thing they
were
relieving and handing over so to speak
um
i went outside
of the rig floor and uh i talked to the
system driller steve curtis for a few
minutes
i was going to let them go ahead and
have their discussion you know have
their formal handover
and uh when they did that i
i came back in
and
after talking to jason anderson the tool
pusher
it was my
expectation
that they was going to
stop the job at that point
they was going to have a a meeting
that would have been don the dream and
it would have been
jason
subsidy engineer it would have been
mud engineer gordon jones
and they would discuss about
you know what had
gone wrong and what they was going to do
on their second negative test
well at this time it got to where it was
a little after
1800 hours
uh our meeting was at 1900.
jason told me he said why don't you go
eat and i said well i can go eat and
come back
and he said man you ain't got to do that
i've got this don't worry about it if i
have any problem at all with this test
i'll give you a call
and
i knew jason well
uh i've worked with him for all those
years eight nine years
and i know y'all know that when you know
somebody that well you can even tell by
their body language if something's wrong
he was just like a brother
and so i had no doubt that if he had any
indication of any problem or had any
difficulty at all he would have called
me
well
i went ahead and ate
i did attend the uh the meeting with the
dignitaries
that lasted until
shortly after nine
or right around nine
um from there i went to the galley and
got something to drink and i spoke to
someone i can't remember who it was in
the galley now but
i made my way back down to my office
and
when i got to the office
i looked at at my watch of course
everybody has different
time pieces but
it was 9 20 by my watch
i called the rig floor
and i talked to jason anderson
and i said well how did you negative
tesco and he said it went good he said
we bled it off
we watched it for 30 minutes
and we had no flow
and i said what about your displacement
how's it going
he said it's going fine he said it won't
be much longer and we already have our
spacer back
i said okay
i said do you need any help from me
and he told me no man just like you told
me before he said i've got this
he said go to bed i've got it he was
that confident that everything was fine
i said okay so i went to my
cabin which is
a short distance probably five feet away
from the tool pusher's office
went in there and closed the door and
prepared for bed and
um
i think i yeah i called my wife and
talked to her for a few minutes
and
wasn't long 15-20 minutes
and
i had laid there and i turned my
overhead light off in the bunk and i was
still watching a little tv
and
my room phone
rang
well
i hit my little alarm clock light
and according to that alarm clock it was
uh 10 minutes till 10.
and the person at the other end of the
line there was uh the assistant driller
steve
curtis
um
steve opened up by saying we have a
situation
he said the well is blowing out he said
we have mud going to the crown
and
i said well
i was just horrified i said well do
y'all have it shut in
he said jason is shutting it in
now
and he said randy we need your help and
i'll never forget that
and i said steve i'll be i'll be right
there
so
it took only minutes for me to put my
coveralls on
they were hanging on the hook put my
socks on
my boots and my hard hat
were right across that hall i was
telling you in the tool pusher's office
so open my door
and i remember
a couple of people standing in the
hallway but i kind of had tunnel vision
i looked straight ahead
and i don't didn't even remember who
those people were
and about the time i i made it to the
doorway of the till pushers
office
was when
a tremendous explosion
occurred
it it blew me probably
20 feet against a bulkhead against the
wall in that office
and i remember then that the lights went
out
power went out i could hear everything
deathly calm
my next
recollection
was
that i had a lot of debris on top of me
i tried two different times to get up
but whatever it was it was a substantial
weight
the third time it was something like
adrenaline that kicked in and
and i told myself either you get up or
you're gonna lay here and die
so
my
right leg was hung on something i don't
know what still
but i i pulled it as hard as i could and
it came free
i attempted to stand up
that was a wrong thing to do because i
immediately stuck my head into smoke
and with a training that we've all had
on a rig i knew to stay low
so i felt i dropped back down
um i got on my hands and knees
and for a few moments i was totally
disoriented i mean i'd lost
uh
orientation on which way the doorway was
and i remember just sitting there and
just
just trying to think which way is it
and
then i felt something that felt like air
and i said to myself well that's got to
be the hallway so that's the direction i
need to go that leaves out
so
i had to crawl very slowly because it
was that end of the living quarters was
pretty well demolished
debris everywhere
but i made it to the doorway
and what i thought was
uh air
was actually methane
and i could actually feel like droplets
it was moist on the side of my face
i continued to um
to crawl down the hallway slowly
and i put my hand on the body and it was
wyman wheeler
i mean i didn't didn't know that at the
time because there was no light i
couldn't see
the next thing i recollect is
i saw
like a beam of light like a flashlight
bouncing
and i guess it was because this
individual was coming down the hallway
and it had all the debris hanging from
different places so he was the light was
going up and down as he ducked and
went through different things
he came around the corner there and and
i saw that to be our electrical
supervisor
stan cardin
um
along about that time
jimmy harold the oim came out of his
room
he had managed to
find a pair of coveralls and put
put those on
he told me he was in the shower
when explosion happened
and
he was gritting his eyes real hard and
he said he couldn't hardly see
and he said i think i've got something
in my eyes
and
i looked down
and he didn't have any shoes either
and
i said jimmy i've got i've got wyman
down right here
and he said yeah okay i gotta see if i
can find me some shoes
so
stan and i
were
in the process
of trying to remove some of the debris
off of wyman
and at that time or along
and
as soon as he got
uh to where we could see him we asked
him to go to the bow
and get a stretcher
so we continued to remove this debris
off of wyman
uh i
i helped him up and i was in my mind
i was going to try to help walk him out
thinking that it might be quicker to
walk him out
well he made a couple of steps with his
arm around my shoulder and
he was in pain and he said
set me down set me down
so we set him back down
and
he said
y'all go on save yourself
you know and i said no we're not gonna
leave you we're not gonna leave you in
here
and
along about that time i heard another
boy saying
god help me somebody please help me
and i looked to where our maintenance
office had been
and
all i could see was feet
a pair of feet sticking out from
underneath a bunch of wreckage and
debris
we uh
we worked to get that off of this
individual we didn't know exactly who it
was
but when we got the debris off of this
person we saw it was buddy trahan
who was one of the visiting transocean
dignitaries that came out for that that
trip
uh
looking at him
we saw that the extent of his injuries
were greater than that of wyman's
so
naturally he got the first stretcher
so we load him on the stretcher
and then
it took three of us because we had to
remove debris it was hanging from the
ceiling and the walls were
jetted out the floor was jetted up i
mean it was just total chaos in that
area
of the living quarters
but uh
when we got him loaded on the stretcher
stan
and chad
conveyed him all the way out the
the front of the rig the bow of the rig
to the lifeboat station
i stayed
right there with wyman wheeler because i
told him i wasn't going to leave him and
and i didn't
and it seemed like an eternity but it
was only a couple of minutes
they came back
with a second stretcher
we were able to
get wyman on that stretcher
and we took him
to the bow of the rig
when we got
outside of the living quarters
the first thing i observed was
both of the main lipos had had already
been deployed and they had left
uh i also
looked to my left and i saw
captain curt uh and a few of his marine
crew
starting to deploy a life raft
and we continued down the walkway till
we got to that life raft and we set the
stretcher down
and um
after several minutes so we had
everything deployed and the chief mate
david young and myself
got in the life raft
and we were able to
catch the head part of the stretcher and
and assist getting wyman into the life
raft
which i don't know if any of y'all ever
been in a life raft but it's hard to
keep your balance and especially if
you've got any type of weight
and i i think we actually fell
trying to you know get him into the life
raft but
the main thing is wyman was there you
know he didn't get left behind
um
from that point we were lowered down
and
i believe that was by captain kirk the
best of my recollection
made it to the water
i remember intense heat
i remember
fuel or
oil or some type of hydrocarbon burning
on the water
extremely close to where our life raft
was
and
the painter was still attached to the
rig
well
we didn't have a whole lot of light
we were looking through the provisions
trying to find a knife
um i was pulling tension on the painter
thinking by chance maybe
it might part
when it did part
okay unbeknown to me at that exact
moment
it didn't part it was cut
uh the the captain of our rig
was able to get a knife and and cut the
painter
and from that point
i remember being thrown a rope
um
i think it was from the fast rescue
craft from the damon bankston
and
from there
they were able to tow us
to the bankston and
safely away from the rig
thank you
when you had the communication with mr
curtis on the rig floor did he mention
anything about possibly lining up to the
gas buster or diverter no sir he didn't
basically all he said to you is that you
were having a well control situation
yes sir
to your knowledge is there any policy
within transocean to lock out any
portion of the bop stack at any time
during the well
no sir i'm not aware of the policy as
was stated
are you aware of any time during the
duration of the well that any portion or
function of the bop stack was uh
functioned out no sir i'm not aware of
that
were you aware of any uh bop stack
issues prior um
to the incident uh whether from being
splashed or once it was on the rig floor
i'm sorry seafloor
no sir
were you ever aware of any leaks on the
accumulator system
no sir i wouldn't
do you know who's authorized to activate
the emergency disconnect system
yes sir it would be
the captain it would be the oim
the senior tool pusher myself
tool pushers drillers
[Music]
subsea engineers
i'm sorry did you say the captain
yes sir i did
do you know who activated the eds
no sir i do not because i was not on the
bridge
had you had any communication after um
the incident with anyone that said they
tried to activate the eds
yes sir i have and who was that
chris pleasant
as your background as a tool pusher are
you familiar with the
eds system
pretty well um is there any way to uh
delay uh activation of the yes within
the logic of the system
delay it they say if you accidentally
function the eds
by hitting the control panel and hitting
eds is there any way that it's a delay
function
to have your lower marine riser package
come off
i know of no way to delay that
are you familiar with the auto shear
system
the auto shear yes sir
yes sir is there any way for that to be
disabled
that would that would be a question that
would have to be directed to the subsea
engineer i'm not aware okay thank you
do you know if um at the time of the
incident when they were displacing the
riser who is monitoring the volume
coming in and volume going out
well
as far as real-time data
now to the best of my recollection that
would have been
our sperry sun
sample
not south catch um
it's sperry's son
person who
uh would be man in the unit and his name
is joseph
and joseph
you know
i think
do you know if joseph keith was taken
off the job for monitoring the flow of
the returns
no sir i had i have no knowledge of that
do you know anybody who would have
knowledge of that outside of mr keith
not that would be alive
how was the uh mud being displaced
what was the flow path
well they were they were pumping down
the drill pipe with sea water right and
returns were coming back up the annulus
okay and we're going back to the
shakers
which that was returning to the pits
is it possible
to offload to the offshore supply vessel
through the mini trip tank
offload
from the supply vessel no from the rig
through the mini trip tank to the
offshore supply vessel of damon bankston
no sir
not to my knowledge that's not
not an option
earlier he had mentioned that you had
some vips from uh i guess bp and
transocean
i think i wrote down it
you had a meeting with them at nine
o'clock
that's that's when it ended okay so from
seven to about nine
did y'all discuss the issues with the
negative test
that they no sir we didn't know we had a
whole different format for the meeting
okay what was discussed in that meeting
sir
uh we talked about uh
the the work that we were going to do in
the shipyard in
2011
we talked about our drops
campaign
we talked about our
2010
goals for the year
um
the the bp guys elaborated on on how
good a job we had done in seven years
without a lost time incident
and how proud they were of the rig
um
it was just a lengthy meeting with all
those main topics there okay so and
correct me if i'm wrong was one of those
gentlemen mr o'brien
from bp pat o'brien
um he's the drilling and completions
manager of bp correct
uh yes sir i believe that's right and he
actually was on the rig floor when mr um
the oil mr herrell
said
took them off and they went somewhere
else well he stayed behind
on the first negative test when they
were having a problem on the roof um pat
o'brien did not stay behind i know but
mister they would they actually know
that something was going on on the rig
floor
about the negative test
yes sir i'm sure that that they they
were aware that something wasn't 100
in no time during that meeting the
drillings and completions manager of bp
mentioned anything about the negative
test that had a problem
no sir there was no mention of it
whatsoever
did they bring up anything of where the
rig was going i know you said about the
2011 shipyard visit but did they bring
up anything about uh by asking an old
914 by chance
would you repeat that please did anybody
from bp bring up the
where the deepwater horizon was
scheduled to go next did i ask an
vyasanolo 914
not that particular group no sir
how
and your experience on the deepwater
horizon
how often did bp come to the rig with
vips
how often yes sir
three or four times a year i'm just
guessing there was it normally the
drilling and completions manager
mr o'brien
um
that's actually the first time i've seen
that that that man okay
are you aware of any type of uh
transocean policies that have been
implemented since the incident i'm not
sure if you i doubt you've been back to
work but have you have you been brought
aware of any type of policies no sir i
have not
and you're right i haven't had any
communication really have you talked to
people involved with the trans ocean
investigation
no sir i have not yeah
quick question um just when i said by
asking an old 914
just from a cursory thing that we've
done with inside the mms we uh
identified that that rig was supposed to
be another location 43 days prior to the
day of the incident
how do you as a tool pusher uh
balance rig efficiency and
safety
well safety is always paramount in
everything we do
and
as far as efficiency goes
the horizon had a had a record for being
one of the most efficient rigs
that
transocean had plus
it was
it was uh
probably the the best rig that bp had
too
so you never felt any pressure from
anyone at any time to be more efficient
or operate quick or get off to another
location any quicker
no sir i didn't feel that that pressure
no further question sir thank you
sir mr easel
uh that was quite a series of events you
detail there and um
i'm not going to take you back through
that but could i could we go back over
the uh earlier events say from
10 or 11 to up to the meeting starts at
7.
were you on the rig 4 when wyman wheeler
was up there discussing the negative
test
uh
i would have been up there
now this is a time estimate yeah just
right i would have been up there
somewhere around 1730
okay and and that was real close to the
time that he and jason were doing their
relieving and handing over information
so they were leaving at six
six in the afternoon um
well they you know they
we call it working from six to six but
they typically do 30 minutes you know
earlier okay
did you hear
any specific conversations about the
negative tests that was going on
um
any discussions about uh
they wanted to repeat it or anything
wrong
anything about nature
well
i'm relatively sure that all parties bp
and transocean was not happy with the
first one and if they did want to repeat
the test
but you were present when it was
discussed or or someone just told you
that later
no i was present there and that's
because like i
said just a little while ago
they were going to stop the job and and
have a
a meeting
and talk about a forward plan as far as
having a second negative test
and from what you could tell who was in
charge as far as telling them how to
conduct the test
well that would have been
the well site later
um
and he was the one that was
not happy with the way the test was
conducted or i don't want to lead you
but just trying to find out what
happened there
no sir he wasn't happy with the results
of the first test and that he is
that would have been uh don the dream
don vader
yes sir do you remember any exact
remarks he made
or anything no sir i i had a break
right there when they were there was
people talking throughout the room
and
they were having
the bp guys were having their discussion
and then our two tool pushers were
having their discussion
so i ended up going outside and talking
to the
assistant driller steve curtis for a few
minutes and did steve have anything to
say to you about the way the test was
run no sir no he didn't
thank you
good afternoon sir
oh i'm sorry where you going
okay
it sounds like there is there's a busy
day on the rig
lots of meetings is that typical to have
meetings
most of the morning before lunch well
kind of typical but actually a little
bit more meetings on this day
than we typically have
yes sir because of the vip visit
that and going over our
2010 budget and then talking about this
drop campaign you know it took us some
additional time that
that we didn't
normally you know have to worry about we
were outside or doing something sure
during the morning meeting um was there
a discussion on
the day's events what was going to
happen
um
yes sir they were they they talked about
the last uh 24 hours and they talked
about the
the the next tower or the plan forward
plan and and we had heard that there was
some discussion at the end of that
meeting
mr jimmy wanted to talk on the side
asked a couple people to stay back about
what was actually going to happen that
day were you en engaged in those
conversations i was engaged in a portion
of that okay um
jimmy was uh
was adamant about conducting this
negative test
yes sir and just to give you a little
background on that please um
in our transition manual
i don't believe you can find a negative
test
okay
um this was something
that jimmy harrell as the oim always
insisted on that's what he said
that's what it was he was that adamant
about doing it and we knew that he was
not going to deviate from that
and
he had some bad experiences on another
rig another time years back i'm not 100
sure but
it taught him a lesson and
he said he said that day that he would
always do a negative test
so
maybe
in some people's mind that could have
been overkill but it it was standard
procedure for us to do that
it was something that we felt
more comfortable with
by doing it
and and i guess he had a difference of
opinion than someone else in the in the
meeting then
yes sir he did um with the well side
later yes sir all right
and um
again it sounded like kind of busy day
there was crew change going on we heard
some testimony that there was a short
change what's a short change
short changes when you have a crew come
out and then
the crew that's out there has to work a
partial day and then they get off and
rest and they come back for their next
tower they're trying to rotate and get
on the right
schedule or the right tower okay
all right and and it sounds like
during this negative test when uh
um
the drill crew was coming on it was kind
of during this negative test or this is
it the second negative test okay can i
can i stop you just like you can
um
the drill crew was not changing out well
i thought you said mr uh anderson was
coming on yes sir but it was just a tool
pusher handover okay and it was a well
site leader handover gotcha
yeah those two changed out and then also
it would have been the senior subsidy
engineer mark k swapping out with chris
pleasant
okay
now that would have been the change out
and i think even the mud engineers would
have changed out during that time frame
okay and would you the those three folks
that you just described there were they
the senior people on the floor
um
well i mean chris pleasant wasn't a
senior mark haye was in in that
particular case
mark was knocking off so to speak
okay
uh
don vader
yes he would have been the senior person
um and i see bob had only been there for
two or three days and he was not really
familiar with the riggs operations you
know yes sir um and jason would
definitely been the senior
okay um so yes in a lot of cases yeah
they were senior people okay coming on
all right and they were the people that
were making the decisions of what was
going on at the time
they would would have made those
decisions yes sir thank you
now you had mentioned as the
the tour
uh was going through the drill floor um
seems like it was shortly after the the
time where the
and i'll call them the senior people
that were there on the floor mr jason
included
uh it was they were going through you
had come through
there was discussion about a way forward
it seems like on this negative test
procedure you said it was uh you had
actually had to take someone outside
uh the assistant driller i think you
said to kind of talk to him on the side
about what was going on yeah i was going
to see if he had any extra input but he
didn't have anything of any value okay
and then you went ahead and left shortly
after i talked to uh jason the knight
tool pusher it came on and and
you know i
i told him i would come back yes sir
and he said no i've got this don't don't
worry about it he said if i need
anything i will call you and he would
have called me i i believe you now i'm
i'd
if the tour wasn't going on if there
wasn't any visitors would you have
stayed
yes sir and i wouldn't be here talking
to you
and i don't mean to put you in that spot
but i just wanted to ask you uh you know
what was going on and if the vip tour
wasn't going on i probably would have
expect as you were talking about it you
would have stayed there yes sir and not
only that if the explosion had happened
at a different time i would have been on
the rig floor i was i was heading that
direction yeah i was just unable to get
there yes sir and and i understand the
intent of the vip visit but it seems to
me that that probably just that timing
of it was uh was kind of critical so
yes sir
thank you very much
welcome
we've had a lot of discussion with the
negative test uh the first test wasn't
up to
the oim's standards what was the
difference between the first and second
test
well i can't tell you
anything about the second test other
than the tool pusher told me it was okay
and then also
don vitrine told jimmy
that it was a good test so i have no
knowledge of that second test
was the testing procedure being
questioned by the oim
um an initial test
yeah it was a question but it wasn't
that big a deal
i think
i think there was a desire from bp to
have the
kill line open
to where they could
use it for another way to monitor
our standard procedure did not call for
that this would have been out of the
normal procedure that that we we do for
a negative test okay
and in my mind that's why they had
chose to stop at that point when we
tightened the angular up and everything
held rock steady
they decided to
stop everybody relieve each other get
all the data all the information they
need
reassemble and and start the negative
test
and
there have been no uh negative test
number two
and just in closing um were you familiar
with any of the changes in the casing uh
program at that well
uh no sir i would not that's bp's
decision uh the casing
so but as it's bp's decision but you're
the one putting it in the hole correct
well we convey it in the hole
with the help of weatherford making the
case enough okay
but i mean that is all their decision as
far as the casing program the design of
the casing right everything i'm aware
that
the thing i'm questioning is though is
at any point in transocean or on the rig
is there anybody that says uh hold up
there's a issue of change in casing
program here we're running out of hole
uh what should we do
or is that only up to bp
well if they just subtle changes to the
the cayson program that would be all in
bp's court
okay thank you sir
mr hazel
a couple questions for you yes sir um
over the last month or so i learned a
little bit more about module operation
and working relationship out there
my understanding is that operational
decision making involve
the oim the company man and the two
pushers are correct
oh yes sir and and sometimes it could be
even the captain involved in that it's
according what the situation is but this
has to do with drilling yes
yes you're right three individual yeah
and you are the senior two pusher yes
sir i am and
from your testimony
it appears to me
and you can correct me if i'm wrong but
you didn't have
full visibility of what's going on
during that afternoon did you no sir i
did not okay
[Music]
since you didn't have food visibility
part of it is that you rely on
jason anderson because he's a tool
pusher
you have
personal relationship you have
confidence in your ability yes sir could
i explain why
yes sir please
um
well jason
he probably had
more experience as far as shutting in
for kicks than any individual on the
deepwater horizon
he also was offered a position with
transitions
of well control department he was going
to be the instructor
of the well control and department
he had just been recently
promoted to senior tool pusher
he did carry a oim's license as i did
uh
jason was very acute on what he did
and
then that made me feel comfortable that
when he said if i have any problem i'll
call you because i knew him that well
and that's why i was able to
kind of rest at ease because i i knew
that they were going to do another
negative test and if they had any kind
of result that wasn't what was expected
that he would call me
yes sir i understand that and that's my
understanding
however
you are the senior tool pusher right you
are in that layers of of the safety net
in terms of decision-making right
because of your confidence in mr
anderson you did not have full
visibility of what's going on and you
rely on him to make the proper judgment
is that correct
that's correct okay sir thank you
flex there any question
no questions thank you kevin thank you
translation any question for your
witness
no questions yes i
have a couple questions at least one
question
mr zell
during these hearings it has been
brought out that
the transocean horizon deepwater horizon
was being
congratulated
by bp for a no loss time accident record
over a seven year period and i think
you've testified that you were aware of
that is that correct yes sir that is
correct during this hearing an accident
a lost time accident was
brought out
with in questioning with several
witnesses by
members of the board
and it involved
an mms record showing an accident date
of
march 6 2008.
thank you
and i have that accident record here
would you take a look at it please and
tell me if you have any personal
knowledge about that accident
yes sir matter of fact i was on the rig
when that happened that was a third
party
hand on the boat
was that an employee of transocean
uh no sir it wasn't it was both hands
and and and so the accident happened
where did it happen on a boat or on the
rig it was on the vessel he removed a
chalk and a tool rolled on his foot i
think all right so this would have been
a member of the crew of a vessel of a
supply boat yes sir that's exactly what
it was and the accident would have
happened on the supply boat but because
it was on the bp lease and bp reports
all accidents to mms then this accident
report would have emanated from that
lease is that correct you're exactly
right okay and in fact it shows the
reporting person is bp yes sir okay
thank you sir quick follow-up quick
follow-up on that mr congressman if you
don't mind okay um
this was occurring during a lifting
operation correct
yeah but i don't think the crane had
even uh even hooked to anything yet
i think that they were
the boat hands were prepping the deck
for the removal of these tools
and can i read a sentence for you sure
the crew was unloading the motor vessel
fast bullet using the port crane who is
responsible for the lifting with the
port crane
well of course if it was actually being
hoisted with a crane
that would be transition and what is
trans ocean's health and policy
statement that says each employee has
the obligation to interrupt an operation
to prevent an incident from occurring
that's correct
and who is who is the sole
responsibility in the transocean lift
plan
who manages the lift
the sole responsibility yes sir
is it not the crane operator should be
the crane operator excuse me mr matthews
you're suggesting that the crane
operator caused this and i'm telling you
that this witness has personal
information that was a removal of a
chalk causing the load to move he
removed the child i'm not arguing with
the witness i'm arguing what was
reported to the mms i understand you're
you're making a statement for the record
and i'm pointing out for the record that
the fact that a crane may have been used
does not
indicate from this report that the crane
was the cause of the accident
and i understand what your point is but
i hope you also understand mine
yes sir i understand your point but but
he actually removed that shock and it
rolled on his foot prior to the crane
being hooked to it
why would he move the chalk
and ask this witness why a deckhand on a
boat remove the chalk
do you think it was in preparation of
the crane operations
i can only assume
the boat was at the at the rig correct
yes it was that was beginning operations
of lifting
and it is also note it's also noted in
the report contributing cause high seas
okay
i don't think that's trans ocean's fault
either does trans ocean not concern
themselves with the injuries of people
does trans ocean not concern themselves
with individuals performing operations
at the side of the deepwater horizon oh
yeah they do
well concerning yourself with operations
does that mean you're responsible for a
lost time accident
and what does this have to do with what
we're investigating please you brought
it up sir no you brought it up i brought
it up in conjunction to a discussion
when there was the vp uh
show that there was seven years of no
loss time accidents may not have been
technically correct
that's why you brought it up
well according to us it's not
technically correct well that doesn't
have any bearing on this accident
it has a barren in effect when we're
told what's going what happened
when we had three discussions going on
with the vips
lost time accidents
nothing to do with the duration of when
the well was being drilled when they
were 43 days behind and that's all it
was brought up for well i hope this
investigation proceeds in a more
relevant way it will and and i
appreciate you questioning it but
from the mms standpoints this is a lost
time accident and that's the way we look
at it and for the record before this i
offered this to you to try to explain it
and offer to let you do the same line of
questioning that i did not try and
embarrass the board i just wanted the
facts to be accurate
sir
i assure you that they are accurate
they're just being questioned
all right hardest interest am i sparkle
no thank you
krill quipped no
what offer no question
and a taco no questions
douglas
brown's turning right here
i'm jeff seeley how are you doing good i
want to take you very briefly back to
those meetings that occurred in the
early morning hours of the 20th okay
does i understand that the first one was
around i think oh 6 30 or something like
that that's correct
and what was the purpose of that meeting
that is our morning call with the asset
and performance rig managers that's done
daily
and are those asset and rig performance
managers on shore
they are
what are their names
well that would have been james kent and
paul
johnson
and what what was communicated to them
or what did they communicate to you
well it was a whole
array of different topics that that we
just i mean it wasn't any particular
focus on anything but it other than
just uh
jimmy the oam usually tells them what
happens you know what happened during
the last uh
24 hours
and uh
from there you know
the captain if he has anything to to
speak on well he does and
you know in
maintenance supervisor he's in the in
the room and if he has anything to say
or like having to do with maintenance of
the equipment
of course you know he has his turn to
talk to the rig managers you know the
asset manager you know they
when he talks uh he he typically tells
us about projects and different things
that we're going to do you know
maybe at the end of the whale projects
or it could be the
the next well projects or it could be
the 2011 shipyard you know
those are the kinds of discussions we
have with the performance and the asset
marketers daily
so it was one of the topics the
operations that were underway the day
prior to the accident
um
did you keep them informed about what
was going on on the rig
they were they were informed on what was
going on on the rig did you did you tell
them what operations were going to take
place on the day of the 20th
yes sir they were aware of the
operations
okay
and was it when you
were in your bunk
watching tv getting ready to go to bed
was it i don't have my notes was it
stephen curtis that called you
that is correct and what did he tell you
he told me that
we have a situation
he said the the
will is is coming in and we have mud
blowing to the crown
since that time has anybody told you why
why the well came in at that point
no sir i can only assume what do you
assume no dude
he's not going to make any assumptions
under oath yeah well do you have any
we've had a lot of opinions here over
the last couple days do you have an
opinion about what happened no this will
not be one of those opinions i wouldn't
care to share it you don't want to share
that with us no sir with the board
thank you okay
thank you
appreciate
thank you sir
cameron
howdy buddy
yeah for sure
just one more question
okay uh you admitted a while ago that
you didn't have full visibility of
what's going on in the drilling
operation yes sir
now
mr harold yesterday the oim
uh from his testimony
my um
understanding that he didn't he wasn't
aware of certain activities going on
uh also
do you believe that he had full
visibility of what's going on during
that drilling operation do i believe
jimmy did yes sir no sir i i don't i
don't think he had full visibility
either okay so here we have a
three-legged stool
you don't have full visibility if the
herald doesn't have full visibility and
so then the third guy is a company man
so if he doesn't have full visibility
also what's going on
we have a problem you think
what the question
reaches the conclusion and i didn't hear
the conclusion what is the conclusion
well the conclusion is that there's
three people three senior people on the
word this module
that are
in the decision making pro here
but you guys mr eazo doesn't have full
visibility mr mr issue say that mr
harold om doesn't have full visibility
of what's going on
and if and my thing is
if the company man whoever that is
galooza or for drain or
didn't have full visibility what's going
on
my conclusion or based on that
is that nobody have full visibility of
what's going on in the senior leadership
keep in mind let me let me know my
objection i want you to answer but i
want to know my
captain captain of the ship
sleeps sometimes i'm sure he showers
sometimes and he doesn't have full
visibility sometimes but there's a hand
off to an appropriate person i believe
this witness has described how
appropriate that person was secondly
there was an operation you're saying
drilling operation there was no drilling
going on this was a static well it had
been tested
so when you say there's full visibility
or there's a lack of full visibility
there are a lot of pertinent facts that
aren't built into your question and
therefore i object but with that
objection i want the witness to answer
that's exactly what i was going to say
that we have
a roundabout
we we've got two tool pushers
that uh provide 100
coverage as far as supervision
and
both of them are highly capable or were
highly capable of taking
charge of something of that nature
and they're also
to the point if they have any kind of
problem they will cause and that they
will move to the next level if i have a
problem i'll tell jimmy
everybody will be in the loop
i understand sir okay
well thank you for your testimony
um
are there any questions that we have not
asked any information that you think we
should be aware of that's relevance to
the investigation that you would like to
tell us at this time
maybe just a couple of
things i could add yes sir uh
lord i don't know how to tell you guys
this but that was one of the most
painful things we could have ever done
is stay on location
and
watch the rig burn
those guys that were on there were our
family it would be like seeing your
children or your
or your brothers or sisters uh
perish in that manner
and that
that puts some mental scarring in a lot
of people's heads that will never go
away
i wish that
we could have bare minimum moved away
from the location or something
or we didn't have to just sit there and
review that
that many hours that was extremely
painful
i guess the only other thing
is
got to keep in mind uh the horizon
i don't i don't care what anybody says
it's in my mind the horizon was
exemplary rig with excellent personnel
it won all kinds of records
from mms awards to our own company
excellence
award uh
those peoples were not
they were not losers by any means
they paid the ultimate price
they gave their life
to try to minimize the damage
that was done to people property
environment
and and i i hope at least that message
is clear
that they pay the ultimate price yes sir
we
we acknowledge that we
we believe that the heroic actions uh
contribute to the seven of the 115 uh
survivors of the horizon
uh at the same time those we didn't know
what the fate of the 11 missing
members was and the bankstone was the
only one that was unseen that had the
capability to
conduct a session rescue
during that time until um
appropriate uh
resources from coast guard another
entity was on scene that's when the
bankster was relief what i understand so
there was a reason why the bankston has
to be there to to provide that kind of
assistance in searching for the 11
missing members so i just want you to
understand that
that was testify uh
earlier well we
we knew that it was a coast guard
protocol so to speak is what we were
told on the bankston
i just want to let you know how painful
it was yes i understand
i thank you for your testimony and if we
need
for you to appear before the board again
uh we have additional question for you
will you make yourself available yes sir
thank you very much your dismisser okay
uh the board will take a 15 minute break
and we'll reconvene at 3 o'clock
now
um
is continuing with our live coverage of
a hearing on the explosion aboard the
deepwater horizon oil rig all day
a panel has been hearing from survivors
and some of those who have served on the
rig during the incident live coverage
expected to continue in about 15 minutes
here on c-span 3.
until then a segment from today's
washington journal with the radio talk
show host from louisiana he talks about
the gulf oil spill
41st president george h.w bush
that all happens next but first up on
book tv in prime time here's anthony
lowenstein
hi everyone good evening
welcome to housing works bookstore cafe
my name is molly quinn i'm the director
of public programming here at the
bookstore
welcome welcome to tonight's event for
disaster capitalism we're so excited to
have all of you here
can i get a round of applause from
anyone who has never been in this
bookstore before
awesome well welcome
so that gives me the opportunity to take
this moment to tell you a little bit
about this bookstore and the things that
we do here
housing works is a healing community of
people living with and affected by hiv
and aids our mission is to end the dual
crises of homelessness and aids the
relentless advocacy the provision of
life-saving services and entrepreneurial
services entrepreneurial businesses that
sustain those efforts so that's what
this bookstore is as long as in addition
to all of our thrift stores that you may
have seen around the city it's one of
those entrepreneurial businesses that
means that every single thing here in
this store all of the books and lps and
dvds are donated to us and our team of
booksellers and bartenders and baristas
is made up of volunteers
that way all of the money that we raise
here in the store goes directly to job
training advocacy housing health care
and other services for homeless and
formerly homeless new yorkers living
with hiv and aids
so housing works is one of the largest
aid service organizations in the world
and every single event that we host here
at the bookstore is a key part of the
fundraising for that event we are
incredibly grateful to all of the people
and all of the organizations that
participate in our events program
tonight we want to make special special
special thanks to verso books who made
this event possible by donating books to
us which are here for sale to my left
you can grab a book here and you can
purchase it up at our register we also
have some free wine and some free beer
from verso tonight
which is really awesome the way that
that works is that they give us books
and they buy from our cafe that way you
get to buy books and you get to have
free beer and we get to fundraise which
is really amazing so we encourage you to
buy a book tonight to enjoy a free drink
on verso and then after that to purchase
a second drink or housing works and to
buy a million books while you're here
tonight which is a really important part
of our fundraising and obviously come
back and see us as well
you can also help out housing works by
volunteering your time donating your old
stuff hosting an event with us just like
this one or by renting out our space for
private function we have really
beautiful weddings and private parties
here almost every single weekend so if
you're in the market for a wedding or if
you meet someone cute tonight you should
come and get my card after the show and
you can learn all about our private
events as well you can also stay in
touch with housing by subscribing to our
newsletter which comes just two times a
month and is filled with free readings
and concerts and parties and great
events just like this one we have a
really really busy fall and we encourage
you to come back and see us soon you can
also stay in touch with us on social
media if you're going to tweet or
instagram about tonight's event we are
housing works books that's bks housing
works bks
and you can find the rest of our
calendar at housingworks.org
events
all right so without any further ado i'm
gonna get this show started tonight i'm
gonna bring up our two
intelligent and amazing gentlemen
tonight so uh these guys are gonna come
up here we're gonna have a short video
and they're gonna talk and then after
that we're gonna open up the questions
to the audience and the microphone that
i'm currently speaking in is the
microphone that you can ask a question
so once we get to that portion just
remember where i am and that you can
come here to ask a question
all right so first i'm going to
introduce our moderator and interviewer
for tonight jeremy scahill jeremy is an
investigative reporter war correspondent
and author of the international
best-selling books dirty wars the world
is a battlefield and black water the
rise of the world's most powerful
mercenary army he has served as the
national security correspondent for the
nation and democracy now he was twice
awarded the prestigious george poke
award and is a producer and writer of
the award-winning film dirty wars which
premiered at the 2013 film festival and
was nominated for an academy award
anthony lowens stein oh my wrong paper
sorry anthony lowenstein is an
independent australian journalist
documentary maker and blogger who has
written for the bbc the nation and the
washington post he's a guardian
columnist and the author of three
bestselling books my israel question the
blogging revolution and prophets of noom
how vulture capitalism is swallowing the
world his new book is disaster
capitalism making a killing out of
catastrophe he is co-ad editor of after
zionism and left turn and co-writer of
for god's sake his books have been
translated and his journalism has been a
finalist in many global awards he's
currently working on a documentary about
disaster capitalism here they are
thank you all for coming
we're going to show a short clip i'm
been working on a film for about four
years with a new york filmmaker called
thor new writer who is sitting over
there new york filmmaker and the film is
about afghanistan haiti and papua new
guinea tells a story of individuals
characters in those countries who are
fighting back and challenging either
rapacious mining or other areas the film
is 90 shot
it is we've been to haiti afghanistan
and papua new guinea twice each we are
currently in the process of trying to
raise money to
finish it do a rough cut if anyone has a
lot of money come and talk to me or thor
afterwards
and here's a short clip of a film in
progress thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this country is going to be run like an
enterprise this new concept of business
foreign
[Music]
industry has to be seen as priority
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
i i know how difficult it is to
uh raise funds to do journalism projects
that are not going to be profitable
uh and
one of the things that always has struck
me about anthony's work
is that he is a quintessential underdog
journalist
and to set out to do a documentary
with a global focus
that
tells history from the perspective of
those who are being targeted rather than
doing the
targeting
is not going to make you a lot of
friends and it's not going to make you a
lot of money
and i think that um
if we lose the institution
of independent filmmaking of independent
journalism that's motivated not by
profit but by a desire to
tell history from the perspective of
those who are
victims of it um
then we have a totally bankrupt society
when it comes to open media and media
freedom
uh so i i hope and i believe that this
documentary will
see the light of day it will um and it's
coming
i know it will and you know it's it's
it's interesting because
you know you could
bring this dvd in your backpack and
screen it around the country and around
the global south and around the world
but because of the level of detail and
the way that you guys are producing this
i i really believe it deserves a much
wider viewing and i hope if there's
anyone in this audience that can spare
ten thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand or five hundred thousand but
yeah shooting too low
uh you should definitely approach
anthony and thor after this um
anthony is a
a friend of mine that i've i've done
events with him in his native australia
and now we're we're flipping it around
and i'm hanging with him here uh and i i
you know most of the way that i know
anthony though anthony though is uh is
through his journalism and i think
that's true of you know the opposite
that he he knows me through my my
journalism and i i i think that there's
this very small group
uh a very small tribe of journalists
from around the world
who
were sort of impacted and molded by
the anti-corporate globalization
uprisings of the mid to late 1990s that
were of course fueled by the global
south and then embraced by
sectors of activists in the global north
and then
further had their outlook on the world
shaped by
the post-911 reality
where you had
a
cartoonish set of villains in power in
the united states in bush and cheney uh
you had uh naked cold
uh
so-called free-market
capitalism being openly
defended uh or offended uh
by the brute iron fist of militarism
around the globe
and and there there is a small circle
of journalists globally that have made
it their business to expose the
machinery of
the connection between
war
and corporate interest and anthony's
journalism may not be well known in the
united states
but for people who really are interested
in investigating the global impact of
economic neoliberalism
and western militarism slash imperialism
anthony has been an incredible
voice in that struggle to get these
stories out
i have a lot of things i want to ask
anthony about and also people should be
thinking about questions you may want to
ask him but i i want to start with
the situation of refugees
who are fleeing syria iraq
and elsewhere
and migrating toward
various european countries
you you said something earlier to me
before we started this event that i
thought was really
fascinating and an underreported story
and that is you talked about the
paramilitarization of the response
to refugees
in europe so maybe you can
give an overview of that and explain
what you meant by that
one of the things that is
arguably the greatest story or one of
the greatest stories of our time is the
fact that there are now more refugees
looking for
asylum safety than the second world war
i think the un said recently 50 to 60
million people are now currently
searching for some kind of safety
and one of the things that's less talked
about as jeremy said is the reality of
what's happening not just in greece and
italy and i speak i spend time in greece
in the book but the fact that so much of
what the european union is doing and so
much the money that they are spending is
not about helping refugees per se it's
about surveillance and monitoring and
policing so a lot of the money for
example some of the money that was
recently um allowed to be given to
greece to
or you know under their austerity
packages had to be spent on surveillance
has to be spent on monitoring and
surveilling refugees an issue we don't
often hear about so when syriza the
greek party in power
made a
really inarguably completely
devastating capitulation to european
union austerity the result was they also
accepted apart from massive
privatization of their social services
and realities
is to surveil that means leasing out
israeli drones to monitor refugees a
range of other things like that so in
some ways the race actually did this
greece has done that over years and many
other european countries have as well
israeli bronze yeah
and which israel likes to you know lease
out its drones it's a thing
rather than buying it you can you can
get air time so to speak for doing so
and one of the things i think that's
really interesting about that apart from
being disturbing is that you have a
massive industry that is pretty happy
about the fact that there are now
god knows how many refugees surging from
north africa in the middle east to
europe letting it putting aside the us
or elsewhere
and i think the the question about that
is like i'd say is happening in the us
with refugees or immigrants from the
south is that this is massive big
business it's not just the question in
one mindset of helping people have a
better life that's maybe how you and i
would see it how can we help people be
treated better but it's a huge business
opportunity and
one of the things that so few
journalists are writing about for
reasons that any
who knows why that is apart from law
journalists aren't very good at their
job is actually understanding why this
has become such a big business and which
companies actually are involved and
greece is but one of those countries
italy as well and also ultimately what
the refugee crisis says about how the
european union based out of undemocratic
um brussels
what that future for the european union
is and for years
many on the left not so much the right
but the left saw europe and the eu as
the ultimate unified dream that's over
i'm not saying eu's going to collapse
tomorrow it won't but there is profound
disquiet in much of europe on the left
and the right for different reasons
including the uk
in saying what exactly are we signed up
to here like what exactly is the deal
what are we actually agreeing to are we
looking at greece as an example that has
been completely
devastated by years of austerity which
is only going to get worse under syriza
the government
or are we looking at something which
actually is far more democratic and the
eu inherently is undemocratic and that's
why
i think a lot of people are really
questioning what the european union's
future is which is a massive question
for the future of the 21st century
it's it's uh
it's interesting your characterization
of syriza because i think there
initially
there was a lot of hope so much and a
lot of optimism and i mean i want to
talk about jeremy corbyn and britain
down the line but you you said you just
said that that that the austerity stuff
is going to get worse under syriza yeah
explain that
i mean so people know i mean syriza
portrayed itself
as a a left-wing
uh
anti-austerity anti-austerity
push back against the sort of right-wing
policies of merkel in germany the
european union the nato infrastructure
that was the public portrayal but you
you now just sort of quickly moved on
and said oh these guys are total part of
the problem in fact they're going to
make it worse
syriza had a gun to its head for those
who don't know syriza won the election
in january they won another election uh
in september just recently
the reason i think there's been a
massive capitulation and janice
farakakis who is the former finance
minister of
i think prolific twitter
indeed tweeter or whatever yeah um
loves twitter and spent a lot of time in
australia weirdly enough over the years
teaching i think at sydney university he
one of the reasons i think he left the
government was he knew syriza was going
to capitulate in a profound way and yes
there was a gun to greece's head and
there was not the political will and we
it's a long conversation where the
greece should have made a decision to
leave the european union there was a
fear that if greece left the eu
the economy will completely collapse i
mean greece's economy has collapsed but
in a far more egregious way
and syriza made a decision or um alexis
cyprus or the leaders around he's the
prime minister others around him
that that was too far to go and the
reason i think it's likely to be worse
obviously i don't know for sure is that
what the terms upon which they've signed
are far more privatizations of public
services far more cuts of hospitals and
public health care and indeed also a far
more greater reliance on
monitoring and surveilling refugees
which is one of the areas less talked
about
in greece
as well and
the reason that's a problem is having
spent time in greece spend time with
various people seeing the devastating
personal effects of people who are who
spend their lives as you know
comfortable middle class people
literally can't afford to give their
children lunch like that is the reality
in greece today which obviously happens
in parts of the us as well to be sure
but in greece it's a devastating reality
and the effect of that is that you now
have in europe
i should say in europe and also in
greece a far-right neo-nazi party golden
dawn in parliament they're the third
largest party in the greek parliament
they won seven and a half percent in the
recent greek election their support is
growing not decreasing and they're
nodding actually literally in government
and controlling what's happening but the
surge of a far-right militancy in europe
is only going to get worse and
unfortunately to me an undemocratic
european union that imposes policies
that
make
european citizens such as greeks don't
feel like they're actually independent
most greeks i met say we're not
independent country anymore the
decisions about us are being made in
brussels we're not just all berlin or
whoever it's not made in
athens it's made elsewhere
and the effect of that is that people
are more likely maybe to latch on to
simplistic
far-right ideas which is and ironically
golden dawn the neo-nazi party doesn't
have any solutions to anything of course
their solutions are to bash refugees in
the streets
and there's such a deep state
environment in greece that for years the
police and military were in on that so
just to finish on that point the concern
that syriza now faces is they're
imposing what they fundamentally opposed
and therefore what that presents as a
deep challenge is for a major left party
that came into power pledging to change
the economic environment they
capitulated within five months
and the real deep reasons for that i
guess we don't actually know the
conversations that were happening in the
room between the eu and greece we have a
bit of an idea that's a problem but i i
have a a
two-pronged follow-up on this
on the one hand i'm curious as to your
thoughts about why angela merkel has
staked out the position that she has i
mean on the one hand she's trying to
appear as though she's taking selfies
with you know refugees and she's trying
to appear as though you know germa they
want germany to be this you know
uh safe territory for the refugees to
to enter uh and i'm curious
what your analysis of her position and
also the
uk's position is on on refugees
but to respond directly to something
that you said about
sort of fascist neo-nazi type parties
rising i've spent a lot of time in
the former yugoslavia and
what's interesting is that in central
southern
eastern europe
in a lot of countries you've had
sort of dueling banjos playing for power
on the one hand you you have the failed
neoliberal
experiment
uh when the us you know supported color
revolutions and all these things on the
other hand you have a kind of red brown
coalition that takes place where you've
got remnants of former authoritarian
governments milosevic in serbia for
instance
teaming up with neo-fascists
pseudo-nationalist entities
croatia now the president of croatia is
a borderline fascist
you know who is uh you know straight out
of some kind of a bizarre cold war
textbook
you saw this in poland and other
countries where there was on the one
hand a rejection of neoliberal policies
on the other hand then an embrace of
uh of of
pseudonationalistic policies so
on both of those sides of the of the of
the scale you've got merkel posturing
positioning trying to appear as though
she's friendly to refugees taking the
selfies but in reality one of the main
people leading the kind of war against
refugees and immigrants and on the other
hand you have
these kind of remnants of failed regimes
teaming up with
uh
fascists basically or you know
ultra nationalists
uh that that tend to go more toward the
right wing and campaign on issues like
we'll lower the price of bread will
reject nato membership will
uh
you know
privacy
nationalize public services again
how do you see all of that coming into
play germany is obviously a fascinating
case i mean the echoes of history in
that country are always
close to the surface i mean many germans
and this has been shown by poll after
pole
are deeply pissed off with the fact that
they feel like they're bailing out the
failures of europe greece particularly
in others and they say they're sick of
it so therefore unless they perceive
their government as taking a hard line
against those perceived lazy greeks
which of course is not true but but the
banks made a tremendous amount of money
off of this completely yeah massively
massively um and there's also in germany
a growing
neo-nazi movement which of course has
always been there but there are
regularly pretty much every week in the
former east
five bombings of refugee homes and
centres i mean this is a growing threat
i'm not saying they're about to take
power not trying to be a fear-monger but
this is a problem and
merkel said they're going to take 800
000 refugees this year apparently from
syria which if that is the case and
actually happens and that's welcome if
it happens
but to she is and this is not to excuse
her behavior but there's a lot of things
she's juggling i guess is the short
answer but economically and financially
um a number of greek ministers have come
out and said in the last months that
when they're in negotiations with the
germans essentially they were told that
you have no choice here no there's
nothing to negotiate you may have been
elected on an anti-austerity platform we
don't care we're making the rules we
have the money capitulate or not now
obviously syriza in greece could have i
guess
said screw you we're going on our own or
we're going to leave the eu but there
was this profound fear of doing so
whether the sentiment within greece is
going to increase to leave the euro zone
is i think possible and i think also
just briefly the
alliances with fascism i think often
outside europe this is weird sense so we
don't really understand what that means
that certainly in my country australia
here in the us is obviously far-right
elements that exist
but really that i can think of massively
in the mainstream obviously europe has
those echoes in some ways far more than
the u.s yes there's obviously fascism in
the u.s in some ways as well over the
years and i think the fear is that the
failure of syriza as a major left party
to
implement a strong
anti-austerity policy makes it far more
difficult for other left parties to to
follow suit so pademos in spain or for
that matter jeremy corbyn in britain
who are not actually in power yet so
let's wait and see if they ever get
there but the problem is that much of
the left certainly in greece is
demoralized beyond belief
demar lies beyond belief just to put
into context for people
uh
jeremy corbyn's
rise to become head of the labor party
uh i mean i know jeremy corbyn i've done
a lot of anti-war events with him
uh you know i i he's a very
controversial figure but in my view for
a lot of the right reasons uh you know i
i first came into contact with him when
i was working at democracy now as like a
rookie
kind of you know sub producer uh and we
would interview him about the north of
ireland and other issues a very you know
very controversial very clear-headed guy
though and a militant leftist yeah this
is it's the equivalent of like medea
benjamin somehow ending up as the the
head of the dnc in america i mean it's
okay for president
well not president it's not gonna jeremy
corbyn is probably not gonna become
prime minister um but i mean to my mind
it wasn't it was like one of the the
rare epic successes of
actual left movements to articulate
their ideas to have them heard under
duress i mean corbin was under fire even
as you were pointing out to me earlier
even from the guardian which was which
ways waged a war against him i mean what
corbyn managed to do there
is incredible because it was an enormous
[ __ ] you to tony blair and margaret
thatcher i mean thatcher who bragged
about how one of her greatest
achievements
during her time was was
providing the
space for new labor to rise
in in in europe which was the equivalent
of our bill clinton
era in the united states where he
co-opted the republican agenda
on domestic policies and then became a
very belligerent hawkish figure on
foreign policy this is an epic moment to
have someone like jeremy corbyn taking
control i don't know that he actually is
in control but officially being at the
head
of the labour party and yet uh there is
this war against him from even
the guardian
i think corbyn is a fascinating
phenomenon he's obviously only been in
the position for a few weeks so one
doesn't want to presume too much about
his leadership
but the remarkable thing about corbyn is
that what he's actually advocating apart
from renationalizing a lot of things
that have been privatized he supports
some academic boycotts against israel he
supports a form of boycott divestment
sanctions against israel he supports
never using nuclear weapons which is a
nice relief because the conservatives
think that it's you know always an
option
he
has a fundamental opposition to pretty
much any foreign wars i mean things that
actually this is what chomsky always
says views that actually are remarkably
mainstream these are mainstream views
that are framed as far left and
unacceptable to the mainstream that's
why that's that's what was kind of
amazing is because
they
corbyn and his allies made an argument
not in the media
not through official channels they
they showed that there is an energized
electorate
that was inspired by the ideas it wasn't
about i mean corbin is a highly
uninspiring individual he's a
monotonous speaker
he's not very dynamic he's very
principled but
the ideas that he put forward resonated
with a lot of young people and a lot of
ordinary working-class people he's the
most popular popularly elected leader in
british history obviously he's not
actually prime minister that's to be
sure but he's the most popular thus far
now whether as you said the election is
five years away he's gonna even be
leader then obviously there are many
factors factions within his labour party
who hate his guts and it was kind of
funny seeing i should actually say one
thing about corbyn he also pledged to
apologize for the iraq war that his
party the labor party of course joined
under tony blair which is partly why of
course the tony blair should be in the
hague was so desperate to not make
corbin leader um blair is like a
cockroach you can never get rid of him
so he will re-emerge in some way
somewhere
as some voice of apparent reason
entitled like lord of humanitarianism
something like that
he was
he was a middle east peace envoy for
five years and achieved the middle east
is now obviously peaceful so he's done a
wonderful job
but no i think there is a real sense of
he asked us briefly about what's
happening in britain i mean the
conservative government now talk about
this in the book in relation to refugees
massive privatization of all immigration
detention camps which the labor party
and the tories have both agreed on and
the
companies that are running those centers
are often the same companies that are
running them in my country australia so
circo and g4 race are two of the large
ones mighty company no one's ever heard
of mitie is now britain's largest
provider of privatized immigration
attention centers and i spent some time
in some of those camps in britain last
year and the conditions are awful people
are treated badly healthcare is
atrocious the guards often aren't given
appropriate training or much training
and that's a really key point because
the reason of privatizing these centers
really is about saying that you're going
to cut costs at all levels and that
means that the guards themselves aren't
going to get good training i mean i
think they shouldn't be detention in the
first place but if there are going to be
centers that's part of the problem
so corbin's got a massive struggle on
his hands he's not going to
revolutionize britain in five years if
he stays later then but i'm encouraged
by it and hopefully he doesn't
capitulate like syriza did so quickly
i just we're reaching the halfway point
of our discussion that we're going to
put it out i just want to remind people
that when you buy anthony's book it is
directly supporting
housing works and housing works is an
incredible
organization worthy of all of our
support and it's amazing to see
uh
this institution spread around new york
there's one not far from me
uh in in brooklyn and it is such an
essential part of this city right now so
i encourage you to buy anthony's book on
its merits but also know that when you
do it uh he's not getting royalties off
of it
verso's not making a profit off of it
everything goes to
housing work so it's just an extra
incentive to get the book here tonight
and to tell your friends about it also
and ask your friends in the city to buy
it from housing works i want to i want
to shift gear and gears and and uh and
ask you about africa
of course you've lived for
this year
the whole past year in in south sudan
uh which you know i mean i i used to
work for michael moore and he used to
say if it's happening happening in
africa it's not happening was how the
u.s media sort of view things uh it's
just you know either starving children
or you know barbaric tribal and there's
so many black people that you know and
they look the same and yeah the media
can't really differentiate that well
yeah uh
the
i mean sudan went through an incredible
process where it split
essentially in two
uh
and and that you know that got media
attention
um but there's there's something much
more interesting going on in sudan when
you look at western interests and that
is that you haven't you have in the east
of africa and increasingly in the west
of africa and north of africa
what it what amounts to a proxy war
between the united states and china
china was very early
to get involved in south sudan at one
point it controlled 40
of sudan's national
petroleum
organization
and the united states presence in in the
east of africa is largely military
china's has been largely economic you
pointed out to me earlier tonight that
china actually has troops deployed which
i i i didn't know
uh has
well yes their term but but china has
1500 or 1200 i think it's 1200 i think
uh blue helmets working under the u.n in
sudan which i mean i've never heard of
chinese troops being deployed in that
way but maybe you could walk people
through because it's something that
receives almost no attention in this
country what's going on in east africa
and sudan specifically between the us
china
and other world powers i mean clearly
what's happened particularly since 9 11
is that america has been on one level
focused elsewhere they've obviously been
invading iraq and afghanistan and
bringing freedom everywhere they go so
china was able to you must not have
gotten the memo we ended those wars
you're right totally finished you're
right they're over and they were really
good i know more please
um
i think what really has happened almost
with virtually no media coverage nick
hurst who are no rights for the
intercept where you
work and run has found that after
out of 54 african countries about 48 or
49 have some us military presence
doesn't mean there are massive numbers
of armies running around the countries
but some kind of presence training
influence surveillance whatever it may
be under the guise of helping struggling
states to get on their feet that clearly
is about two things one influence over a
rise of china and secondly resources
which some countries have more than
others in sudan and south sudan the
south sudan became independent state in
2011 it's the world's newest nation
still since about a year and a half ago
two years ago now there's been a brutal
civil war
no one knows how many people have died
but the international crisis group have
estimated possibly up to a hundred
thousand maybe more
um it's a brutal war and the reason i
think probably doesn't get much coverage
is for the reasons you give there are
obviously some media outlets that do
cover it
but ultimately i think it's just it too
easily um dismissed as
black africans can killing each other in
a civil strife what's the interest
though like what what do western powers
in china want in
i think the main reason that the us was
so keen to be a and john kerry called
like you know the handmaiden was
a way to have a stable base in east
africa against the rise of china it
wasn't said to be like that but you had
the bush administration george w bush
massively pushing south sudanese
independence when he was in government
there was also a christian element to
that i was going to say the evangelical
community in america hugely backed sudan
is muslim south sudan is christian
and the idea of supporting an
evangelically based country was a kind
of nice idea
so the bush administration said obama
continued that but arguably not quite as
with not quite as much support the
country came into fruition in 2011
china's influence before was independent
and also afterwards you could argue was
principally oil it wasn't the only
reason but there was a time there where
i think it was two or three percent of
china's oil was coming from south sudan
that's quite a lot and china is a
massively growing state and sudan of
course is easily framed as a
muslim terrorist supporting thugocracy
there's some elements of truth in all
those comments and of course in the 90s
it was giving protection to osama bin
laden so that sort of puts sudan in the
enemy number one category fast forward
to 2015 and the oil
output is virtually stopped because the
war is ongoing there's a peace treaty
that was signed in august this year
which has pretty much
not really worked it's falling apart and
i think the thing that's really
devastating about the relationship there
that america is pretty much disengaged
that america's involved to an extent but
there's not they are the
the great irony about america's
involvement there is that they were so
enthusiastic when it happened and when
the country kind of fell apart their
interest waned not least because i guess
they were interested in
bringing freedom and democracy to the
middle east and it seems that for the
remainder of obama's term south sudan
will be a low-level issue for the u.s
the irony is i'm not saying america's
engagement brings peace and democracy
far from it but in some ways although
america is at least critical of a regime
that they back the silver key government
is a government frankly of uh thugs and
war criminals that the u.s knew about
that before they backed them
and you had people like george clooney
and others who were pretty keen on and
clooney doesn't say as much these days
as he used to about it but he's busy you
know i don't know what he's doing making
films that bomb aren't relationships
married to an actually very good lawyer
uh who often gets identified just as
george clooney's wife isn't that great
she was one of the main lawyers for the
al jazeera amal clooney the main lawyers
for the al jazeera journalists who were
jailed in
uh uh egypt and she was always referred
to as george clooney's wife you know was
advocating she's also representing in
fact the deposed leader of the muldives
and ironically the and the elite and the
and the dictatorship of mold eyes is
being represented by cherie blair tony's
wonderful wife so they like to hang
around with thugs that's kind of their
thing
i'm gonna i'm gonna open it up in a few
minutes for uh questions uh from from
the community that's gathered here uh so
if anyone wants to start making a way
there i i only have a couple other
questions specifically that i want to
ask anthony and then we can open it up
and have a more freewheeling
conversation i want to talk about
afghanistan because i know you've spent
quite a bit of time there you were there
very recently of course we had this
horrifying what appears to be a war
crime uh
of the bombing of the medicinal frontier
hospitable hospital
in kunduz uh we've had uh and at the
intercept we've you know glenn greenwald
has been covering this in a very
uh thorough way you've had the evolving
changing
you know characterization from the
united states about what actually
happened there and there was you know an
attempt to
blame it on on afghan forces calling it
in then it became special operations
forces and it became you know the the
sort of passive way that we talk about
it bombs fell on it there's this
brilliant meme that's floating around
now of the new york times times headline
where there were things crossed out on
the headlines so it just said us bombs
afghan hospital you know uh but there
were like all these other
words in that um but it's a horrifying
it is incident and it is very difficult
to
accept the current and i haven't checked
the internet recently but the current
version that it was simply a mistake
that afghan forces had called this in
through u.s special operations forces
there's a long history as you and i both
know of the u.s targeting
civilian facilities going in the 1991
gulf war there was the bombing of the
ahmariah shelter which killed hundreds
of iraqis
uh there was the bombing of the al-shifa
pharmaceutical plan under bill clinton
yeah the bombing of radio television
serbia uh during the 1999 al jazeera was
bombed in iraq and afghanistan al
jazeera al jazeera and the red cross
bombed in afghanistan al jazeera's
senior correspondent tara kayub killed
in april 2003 in baghdad in u.s strike
then a reuters cameraman and a spanish
journalist named jose cuso killed in the
shelling of the palestine hotel then the
shelling of the sheraton hotel in
baghdad where jazeera journalists were
the only guests in the hotel at the time
uh and on and on and on uh
the the
commander of u.s forces in afghanistan
general campbell
said in front of congress a couple of
days ago
that
obama's
plan to just keep a kind of small force
based at the embassy to do
counterterrorism and force protection uh
was not sustainable and that they it it
would be better to have no one there
than just a thousand troops and he's now
pushing for a much more robust uh force
you've written about and investigated
the kind of economic and
civilian consequences of what the us did
by
invading occupying and staying in
afghanistan for so long maybe you can
give people a kind of analytical report
back from your recent time there and put
it in the context of what we're seeing
right now in the u.s so i was there last
in may with my film partner thor we were
there i'm working on the film and the
focus in this part of the film is about
afghanistan's natural resources for
those who don't know under the ground
there is an estimated possibly three to
four trillion dollars of untapped
resources three to four trillion
trillion
a lot that's about the cost of the iraq
war i think yeah and
and
during the soviet occupation that was
discovered and nothing could be done the
americans have been there obviously
since 2001. in short what we wanted to
look at and what the film shows is that
the afghan government the u.s government
wants to believe and claims that this
will be a way to potentially support and
fund afghanistan when the u.s money in
aid disappears or reduces so we spent
time at a an area near about one hour
from kabul in logar province it's
controlled by the taliban and there's a
mine there can run by the chinese who
bought who got rights to it many years
ago it remains
not started the chinese had an image of
mining many years ago but through
various different reasons insecurity
issues there's buddhist relics there
which they had to remove in short we
spent time with locals there being told
on the ground that their lives had been
made hell the insurgency had been fueled
they had no benefits they were being
shafted massively the reason i mentioned
that is that we also spent time in the
north um around missouri sharif looking
at a
rail line which is bringing oil and gas
in and out of uzbekistan who knew that
afghanistan had a railroad you mean like
a train an actual train yeah
um
so the reason this is relevant and
important about how the economic and
civilian connection is made is that the
us has spent hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars in the
last decade trying to support so they
claim a mining industry there that's
supporting some indigenous organizations
and foreign it's been a complete
unmitigated disaster and the reason
that's relevant is that and the reason
we wanted to feature that in the film
and i touched on the book but it's much
more in the film
is that
do we actually think that a country like
afghanistan which has been a war now for
30 more than 35 years
deserves a future which is almost
guaranteed to be wrapped with more
violence if you start
mining copper and other resources and
also the complicity of u.s corporations
and the u.s government in that process
and i think one of the things that's not
talked about as much as it should be is
that is that our legacy there our being
the west that us most u.s troops will
come out at some point you're right
obama i suspect may increase troop
numbers it's not going to go up to 100
000 people 10 15 20 who knows a thousand
but ultimately their the afghan
government is
claiming in the u.s government this is a
potential way and one of the things
that's a theme in the book as well is
that i can't think of one developing
country
and i write about this extensively who
have who are massively wealthy from
resources which actually manage it well
that's because outside companies
basically are screwing it up by choice
and that to me i think really says a lot
about how we view
our lives in the west because so many of
the so-called economic benefits that
we're getting from mines in papua new
guinea or the potential mining in
afghanistan
apparently helps us here live our lives
and have a nice fruitful existence but
actually the people in those countries
are
you know being very shafted and a place
like afghanistan it's a clear as we as
thor and i heard it fuels the insurgency
deeply fuels the insurgency one of the
things that i discovered when i was uh
reporting extensively on private
military companies is that a lot of
companies from south africa the united
states britain australia elsewhere
they started to do deals in the early
2000s
where they would be paid in mineral
resource
profit eric prince the
founder creator of
blackwater has a new company frontier
services group that just announced a
major expansion in eastern africa and of
course sudan is
prince actually was one of the people
that the the christian forces in south
sudan were consulting with and then
there was some congressional question
about it but they're asking to be paid
not in cash but in concessions from
mining and it seems like one of the
threads of your reporting whether it's
in papua new guinea or it's in
afghanistan or elsewhere is
is this idea of natural resources
but it's not necessarily oil it's
mineral resource which is
a very underreported aspect of
motivation for war so maybe and and by
the way uh i would love to hear from
other people in the audience after
anthony is done
answering this question if anyone has a
question we can move toward an audience
discussion so anyway but on this issue
of
you know people say oh it's about oil
mineral wealth in the countries you've
been reporting
i wouldn't say that for example the war
in afghanistan is simply because of
resources likewise i wouldn't i've never
thought that the iraq war was solely
about oil i think i think there are many
other reasons i think oil was one of
them but it wasn't the only reason
i think one of the things that comes out
very clearly is that we
we in the west the u.s particularly
australia the uk and many european
countries have made a choice to
make various countries reliant on us in
other words papua new guinea haiti which
i talk about extensively in the book
afghanistan they're independent on paper
but they're not independent in reality
at all either economically or
certainly not often socially so it seems
to me that there is a real need for one
of the things we try to talk about in
the film in relation to aid and
development often the privatized nature
that is how much do we know where our
aid money is going how much do we know
where the money that many of us might
give to a charity actually is going and
it's amazing how there are remarkable
ngos doing wonderful work around the
world of course there are but often as
i'll finish on this point some of you
may have read recent reporting about the
american red cross in haiti the american
red cross after the 2010 earthquake put
out an appeal they got billions of
dollars it emerged years later that the
american red cross had basically nobody
on the ground in haiti when they asked
for the money bit of a problem
virtually nothing really has been
created by that money that is like
virtually no no houses in other words
this is an organization which apparently
is brought beyond reproach although
as many people in new york will know the
american red cross failed miserably
after hurricane sandy as well here a few
years ago so again to me it's about
asking the questions about saying too
often i think we view an ngo maybe on
the left at least as benign and
ultimately there are a lot of questions
often about ngos that are for-profit a
lot of ngos are for profit they often
like to call themselves an ngo and when
the haiti earthquake happened the u.s
ambassador at the time and wikileaks
document showed this i know both of us
have discussed before the complete
essential nature of wikileaks and the
work that it does
that he called it a gold gold rush
and the gold rush in haiti was going to
be massive business contracts to make a
fortune i mean that's the way a disaster
is viewed it's through money it's not
through helping the haitian people right
i mean in kenya when i was reporting on
somalia i mean the the entire somalia
industrial complex is based in kenya
where all these ngos and
un government entities these people all
the people working they have nannies
they have huge houses none of them ever
have to set foot in in somalia and yet
they're making getting like crisis pay
and all this stuff i mean luckily we
have bill clinton to save haiti but um
and hillary and now chelsea as well yeah
all right so let's let's open it up a
bit and then we'll we'll see where it
goes from here hi oh hi uh when you talk
about sudan and the concessions isn't
also speak closer
yeah when you talk about sudan and
concessions uh
for wars um
isn't sudan the biggest plantations of
gum arabic of the highest quality in the
world which is
strategically important for coca-cola
and for ice cream industry like
haagen-dazs and unilever you know pen
and cherry and
and it might not make too much money for
sudan but it makes a lot of profit for
coca-cola and you know
i haven't reported on that i don't know
if you know anything about that i don't
know is the short honest answer i mean
it's interesting just i guess all i
could say is it's about i have not been
to sudan but
what's interesting is that sudan
traditionally of course has been allied
with iran for many many years that's not
a secret but more recently sudan made a
decision to ally itself with saudi and
support the bombing of yemen and that's
been interesting kind of pivot that they
are for whatever reason different
reasons have chosen to change their
allegiance which is pissing off iran in
many ways but i'm not sure it's a simple
answer i just don't know you're saying
the gum gum industry
you need it for mixing water and sugar
yeah yeah
i mean that's it's fat i mean it's
interesting
i don't know
i'm sorry i don't know i believe yeah
yeah go ahead hi nice to meet you guys i
hope one day to have some slight amount
of the success that you guys have i've i
tried with various stuff
exoticjewishhistory.com my name is
rymosha rudner
um again exoticjewishhistory.com
10 website you're not going to see much
there
um
my question is
that see i find a hard time even though
i i really the movie dirty wars it's
hard to say that i enjoyed the movie but
i got a lot out of it
um
and i agree with most of what you guys
have to say
um at the same time it disturbs me that
it seems to be like you know preaching
to the choir and it seems to be a
certain amount of certitude that you
guys have on the subject which i'm sure
you don't have in your private lives
perhaps just when you're preaching
um
for example i could see a different
point of view which i i i already hear
the titters of laughter but i can hear a
different point of view perhaps
that uh perhaps the refugee crisis is uh
something that is happening
to the people who are perhaps lower
middle class in europe in the united
states and it's taking away jobs from
them at the end of the day it's causing
their lives to be uh further
impoverished it's not decreasing
anything from the lives of the well to
do from the lives of the elite but it is
costing a lot from those who are at the
lower end of the spectrum especially
those who don't know how to represent
themselves well and i think that needs
to be taken you know taken into
consideration i'm sure you guys do
but within the context of this talk
especially when you're preaching to
people who are speaking to people who
for the most part as i would include
myself agree with your point of view
um we have to look at that fact that
people who make low wages
are in fact their lives will be worsened
by an increase of refugees be it from
mexico be it from syria et cetera
and that's something to be taken into
account granted the people from syria
are from mexico perhaps have less at
this point
but um at the end of the day it's not
coming what they're going to gain is not
coming from the well to do from the
elite right or left it's coming from the
poor okay
yeah your point's clear and thank you i
guess yeah my response to that would be
that um there's actually been a lot of
studies done about the effect on refugee
communities in various countries across
europe and obviously that is an argument
that says that it's going to affect
people's jobs in fact the evidence over
the long term is the exact opposite of
that it's the exact opposite of that two
reasons one in many countries certainly
refugees are sometimes doing work that
no one else will do which is frankly the
case in the u.s where let's face it i
mean if donald trump becomes president
which is a scary thought but not
impossible frankly the idea of getting
rid of 11 million
undocumented migrants apart from the
fact it's an insane idea the country
would stop functioning which says a lot
about the way america is ugly set up its
system of a service industry but putting
that issue aside in europe the evidence
is the opposite it's actually the
opposite so ultimately it seems to be a
sense that refugees in fact are helping
societies and actually increasing jobs
not reducing them so
yeah i mean the the one the one thing i
would add about this because you raised
the issue of
you know of mexicans uh in the united
states
first of all when you look at a at
companies like
disney or volkswagen most volkswagens
driven in the us now are manufactured in
mexico uh you know there
you can make an argument that
the the people that are
fleeing their own economic desperation
and coming to the united states are a
threat to
american workers and in some cases you
might be able to find evidence that
that's true
but that misses the much
bigger picture which is that
uh
huge corporations
are setting up a system where workers
from the so-called global south are in a
race with workers from the united states
including auto workers uh garment
workers
a whole slew of industries they're in a
race to the bottom of the wage scale
and you know they're
you you can reduce it to
the the kind of
trump style level of these people are
taking our jobs first of all most
you know americans don't want the jobs
that mexicans do in this country every
time we do a day without mexicans you
know in this country
it's it's
well i mean they're actually working way
below american wages in this country go
to any construction site in this city
you see workers from not just mexico
from poland from ireland from other
places who are who are being paid in
cash under the table
uh and and the thing is you know i mean
i i come from a working class family and
i hear the same frustrations from my
relatives who say those same kinds of
things because their perception is these
people are coming here to take our jobs
and it's not there's no point in saying
well you're wrong and let me let me
explain marx's dust capital you know let
me let me talk to you about no
but the point is
and i actually think that u.s labor
unions sometimes are good sometimes
they're bad on this on this question but
in general
workers are being pitted against each
other and and to turn and but to turn on
workers like worker against worker who
benefits from that the people that
benefit from it are huge corporations
are the are the are they mass level
employers
you can you can draw all sorts of
analogies in society to who the real
sort of villain is and it's you know on
the one hand you know you have big guns
and little guns is is the problem in
chicago that you have a bunch of thugs
that are murderers and that that's their
nature and they want to kill or do we
have a problem with guns in this country
do we have a pro i mean these are these
are much bigger questions than just does
an individual person who flees their
country to come here looking for work so
they can support their family are they
the villain oh they're not the villain
they're not coming here with the
intention of screwing an american worker
if they could get a union job and work
for union wages of course they would
want to do it we're wearing clothes
we're driving cars we're consuming
products that are made by workers in
other countries in some cases children
making clothes for children who are
being paid slave wages the idea that
we're going to focus our energy on
blaming the individuals who are trying
to support their families to me
is while i understand the frustration of
individual workers who face those crises
is totally missing the point of the real
villain here and i mean i appreciate you
raising this but i you know
mexican workers have much more in common
with ordinary american workers than
either of those uh classes of people do
with uh tim cook the ceo of apple whose
phones are made by kids in chinese
sweatshops and let's not also forget one
also
i would also say just one other point on
that is that the number of refugees from
these troubled countries that the us is
taking in and my country is shamefully
low
i mean we talked constantly between ten
thousand and now they're going to
increase to 20. yeah it's trying to get
a few more questions in here okay if
there's any women that actually want to
speak tonight that would be a welcome
thing you can skip to the head of the
line step up um
first uh first and foremost uh i want to
just thank you to housingworks and and
thank you both for this very crucially
important talk i just wanted to quickly
ask what you if you both
what you both think of
naomi klein's book on capitalism and
climate change i was curious to know
what you guys think of uh of her work
i
like it i support it i think it
obviously follows she's often i think
said that this changes everything which
is the
the book and the film i know is coming
out at the moment is almost like a
sequel of sorts to the shock doctor in
her last book
i think her message which for those who
don't know let's not go into detail you
should read the book and buy it it's a
great work
um essentially says the economic system
that exists simply is not sustainable
for for a long-term sustainable world
and that simply incrementally trying to
you know
do minor things that don't really
massively affect
our economic system it's not the
solution here i think she also goes
which i do like and often i like about
klein's work is actually goes into the
field and shows examples of people who
are doing it so it's not simply someone
who is pontificating from on high
actually goes into places in the us but
also around the world in the last book
and this one as well so now and
obviously i continue her thesis in a way
in my book as well i mean naomi i mean
just full disclosure i mean naomi's like
a sister to me she's one of my best best
friends so
all biases on the table uh i think she
had a real uphill battle with taking on
the issue of climate change i mean you
know naomi's first book uh
no logo ended up becoming a sort of
bible secular bible of sorts for the
anti-corporate globalization movement
and then
you know i remember when she was writing
shock doctrine her original title for
that book was going to be blank is
beautiful
i don't know if that's ever been
publicly stated but it was it was going
to be blank it's beautiful which was
a paraphrase of of of mao and the idea
of of like sort of blanking people to
the point where you can rebuild them in
your own
imagery uh and and and she was sort of
comparing some of the tactics of
mao's china to
rumsfeld and cheney and it was it would
have been a kind of revolutionary title
because it would have pissed off a lot
of sectarian leftists but it also shows
the nature of the universal nature of
fascistic
tendencies and i mean to my mind the
shock doctrine was one of the seminal
works to define
the
the era that we lived through with with
bush and cheney and it was remarkable
it's really hard to energize people
particularly in this country on the
issue of climate change it's not that we
don't have bill mckibben or we don't
have 350.org we don't have these these
movements but the the notion of the
destruction of the planet
is makes much more sense in the context
of like the next star wars movie than it
does in the daily lives of people
currently living and it's a big ask to
say to people well think about what's
going to happen in 50 years if we don't
do these things so i give her a
tremendous amount of credit because it's
an unbelievably complicated topic to
translate into kind of meaningful
everyday what do you do about it what
are you outraged about how do you handle
that outrage i think what she's tried to
do and i think she's very success has
been very successful at it is to put a
human
face on the on the immediate
consequences
of climate change and um
but it's it's it's a it's a tough tough
battle and i think for someone of her
at this point now her stature to do that
says a lot about her own humility
because she's clearly not trying to sell
a ton of books with this she's trying to
actually get people who know her from
other things to pay attention to a
really complicated topic and i think
it's brilliant that she's doing it
thank you
[Applause]
hello
uh i have an anecdote i'd wish you guys
would comment on which touches on some
of the things you personally are an
anecdote
it's anecdotally all right let's make
sure um
it's about the haitian earthquake and
the whole issue of another resource
which we're not paying enough attention
to and that's water usage and water
rights very important
uh after the earthquake when this gold
rush
or the yeah when the gold rush happened
one of the things they were very bad
need of was water now
haiti's an island surrounded with
mountainous streams and things like that
so you would think that repairing the
infrastructure
and providing water purification
equipment would be a priority but lo and
behold plane load after plane load came
in and deposited cases of fiji water
and very soon all of the canals and all
the sewers
into our port-au-prince were hopelessly
clogged with empty plastic fiji water
bottles which i don't really think
contributed too much to the recovery of
the drinking water supply
please comment so
i mean anthony has spent time in haiti
looking at these issues i mean maybe you
can
i mean what you're saying is that is is
interesting because you're talking about
how they're they're saying oh we're
bringing all this water and then they
leave all of this waste but it's maybe a
metaphor for
everything else or as you say an
anecdote of yourself when i said i've
been there twice in the last years with
thor i said my film partner and one
thing that we constantly heard was that
routinely there were things being
shipped in that haitians did not need in
other words there was not generally a
food shortage there was food available
in haiti for haitians it was being flown
in because haiti had been forced to do
deals with the us government to allow
u.s farmers to get access to the haitian
market that's what a disaster capitalism
means but also is the reality of haitian
workers and haitian farmers being seen
as secondary and less important than the
american worker that is a profound
problem we also heard about the issues
of water it wasn't our main focus but we
certainly did as well and that's
something i think really people often i
think feel on this issue it's a bit
depressing what are the so-called
solutions there's no simple solution but
i think one of them of many is almost
such an obvious thing if for example
disaster strikes actually think about
what local people want listen to what
they say it's not that complicated don't
always presume that an outside
contractor is getting paid a hell of a
lot of money knows better sometimes he
or she may know better but often they
won't and the problem in haiti has been
that so few haitians themselves actually
were employed or trained or given any
kind of experience so when those western
corporations left which they usually do
what's left not a lot and that to me is
often the legacy of of of an aid and
development model that often is pushed
but by pushed by usaid
without really a great deal of thought
into what the reality is for people on
the ground the thought seems to be more
how can we help u.s contractors and
actually haitians themselves right
okay
we only have a few minutes left because
housing works runs on volunteers they
have to start closing down the shop so
why don't we
uh there are three people here waiting
to ask questions
why don't we have each of you
uh ask your question and then we'll have
uh anthony summarize and and wrap up the
night
uh i was interested in the comment you
made earlier about the three to four
trillion dollars of mineral resources in
afghanistan and i i wanted to ask a
question about your thinking about the
changing face of disaster capitalism as
the
changing demands for minerals and energy
energy sources especially changes and it
speaks to the sort of notion of climate
change driving
transition to renewable fuels
how do you think that transition will
impact disaster capitalism where do you
think it will
hit the you know where will that change
be seen the most and and how will that
affect local people in some of these
places okay cool all right let's get the
next question i'm taking notes here so
we'll summarize it go ahead
okay
thank you guys for doing what you do
it's
i
it's really important to me personally
so i just want to thank you um
you speak speaking of the mic yeah i i
have a a bunch of questions but i guess
my most important one is
what do you guys think of bernie sanders
um
you know he's from australia and may not
know who that time is
um i i read the the thing in the
intercept about the the people who are
protesting palestine palestine and
them getting the boot yeah and like i
guess my fear with bernie sanders is
that it's just a smoke screen that like
you know will vote for the guy
and then it's not really going to be up
to him he's going to have to do what
they tell him okay keep going yeah yeah
um and then uh we'll take one more from
you because we're we really are short on
time so pick your best one out of your
list okay and and the other thing is
what do you guys make of the drop in
commodity prices
and do you see any systemic credit risks
as a function of that
okay cool thank you for those questions
yeah all right
last contestant
um this is kind of a loaded question um
but anthony said in his last talk about
they were using 911 as an excuse to do
this endless bombing and i just i just
wonder if there's any sort of question
as to the official story
okay so to summarize here let's just
take them one at a time quickly
uh referencing the three to four
trillion dollars or three trillion
dollars in in mineral resources in the
mines in afghanistan how does that
affect impact climate change disaster
capitalism
etc
so the short answer is that it should
but i suspect in the short term it won't
so when when thor and i are in
afghanistan recently the issue of
climate change comes up with people who
are
i guess i say not western educated but
people who are aware of the
conversations and debates that happening
beyond afghanistan there's no doubt that
mining three to four trillion dollars of
resources is a disaster for the
environment let alone climate change
there's no question about that and there
is at least very very small attempts in
afghanistan for some kind of more green
energy but i guess what i would say to
that is that in a country like that
which is so broken not that i'm saying
there shouldn't be talks about green
energy there should be but the truth is
that there are still enough countries
and corporations that will exploit those
resources and want those resources and
will pay for them for years and years
which is also the crisis that climate
change activists have about
transitioning to a fossil free fuel
world briefly bernie sanders yes i'm not
american yes i probably won't be able to
vote for him unless something changes
um
i think he's always had a blind spot
about palestine which has been
documented by a lot of people including
on the website mondo wise but i was very
happy recently that he came out with a
strong proposal to end the privatization
of prisons and detention centers i think
he's a breath of fresh air i don't doubt
like a lot of people instilled so much
hope in obama who's a different
character and look where we are in 2015
i think sanders could maybe on some
issues be
a re i mean he's had a history on many
issues of being
fresh and
injecting not just reality but
reflecting what so many people actually
do think about
politics uh you're playing more on one
thing about bernie sanders
i mean i i i know dennis kucinich really
well and dennis kucinich ran for
president multiple times on the
democratic ticket and and it was always
great to see him in the debates and he
always i think represented really well
and was able to articulate things on a
much larger stage than people like him
are normally uh given access to uh but
at the end of his run in congress i i
you know i asked him why are you a
democrat like why do you stay why don't
you run as a green party candidate or
why don't you
advocate for a multi-party system in
this country
and his answer was a terrible one he
just said well i've cast my lot with the
democrats
bernie sanders he's bad on guns too and
i understand why i mean he's from
vermont if he were to come out really
strong against guns he would probably
not even be able to win his own own seat
i wonder how big of a gun lover grandpa
is but like he's
he has to stake out that position his
palestine israel politics are just shy
of atrocious
uh and but
he is going to make the debate very
interesting um but but is that being a
useful idiot for
the the kind of duopoly that we have
yeah it probably is
until we break our
single party system in this country
nothing will ever fundamentally change
we have we have legalized corruption and
legalized bribery called campaign
finance where huge corporations are able
to purchase candidates of both parties
and they know which way the wind is
blowing yeah and you know so sanders
gives somehow legitimacy to this process
by engaging in it if we took our
brightest minds
either from congress where there's not
many bright minds or the or or broader
society and actually said let's let's
try to run candidates that are not
democrats or republicans and are not
beholden to corporate interests and we
actually had really serious political
candidates i mean jill stein who's the
candidate for the green party
extremely
sharp person
very smart good ideas no public profile
whatsoever if you have higher profile
people that are willing to cast their
lot
by to try to shatter the duopoly
then you you can you can imagine
slight
chinks in the armor of the empire but
until that happens it's it's
not and i but i'd rather have bernie
sanders in it than not except it gives
legitimacy to the anointing of a bush or
a clinton or some other
okay drop in commodities prices
we're on cnbc right now now has asked we
have to answer so i've got like five
seconds um
well
if you've got like less than that i know
i mean look i think the drop in
commodities in many ways actually is a
positive thing i mean clearly there has
been a massive reduction in the ability
for
a number of corporations including shell
to actually i mean they're still making
a lot of money let's face it but the
move that obama allowed to for example
drill in the arctic shell has now pulled
out of that which was didn't last very
long
i think there is going to be desperate
desire by these corporations to actually
try to find more and more resources
which is going to be difficult with the
current economic situation a drop in
commodity prices to me actually i've got
i mean that to me is actually a positive
if it if it leads potentially to some
kind of greater reliance on
less dirty energy and briefly on 9 11
look i've always said this question
often comes up
i don't doubt for a second it was the
official story is i believe i think it
was done by bin laden i think it was
done by 19 hijackers the question that
is remains unknown about that event to
me has always been the role the actual
real role of saudi arabia i'm not
suggesting that someone was pushing a
button in riyadh to make it happen i'm
saying that 15 of the 19 hijackers were
saudi that part of the 911 commission
has not been released who knows what it
would say but more importantly as i've
often said for years if america is
actually serious about fighting
terrorism which it's not it would deal
with saudi arabia i don't mean invading
i'm just saying saudi arabia is the one
of the key global sources of terrorism
and america prefers to follate it rather
than criticize it
and and of course i mean you know what
i got my one clap when i said for light
you see yes that's always if you say
[ __ ] you get a clap
uh
i mean i you know on i mean to to sort
of
close all of this
the way that
bush and cheney and rumsfeld and others
were able to
exploit
the
horrors of 9 11
has not been fully investigated and
you know we
the the kinds of crimes that were
justified on the basis of
911 uh were epic in scale which
continued and and and and they continued
to this day
president obama's justification
for drone bombing in yemen is still
linked to
911 the the the 60 words in the
authorization for the use of military
force
is still the justification for bombing
people who were toddlers when 9 11
happen under the understanding that they
were involved with 9 11. i mean we we do
live it's a cliche but we live in a
semi-orwellian
existence in terms of how all of these
things are
justified
i want to thank anthony lowenstein
lowenstein very much for writing this
book for the work that he does
for smart questions from our audience
and most of all to verso books for
publishing this amazing book and the
housing works for hosting it buy the
book housing works gets all the proceeds
from it thank you all very much
[Music]
[Applause]
is a longtime
volunteer uh
[Music]